[Music]
so
good morning internet good morning
everybody good morning
people all over the world and welcome to
ndc manchester
where i'm not and you probably aren't
either yes hello
everybody and how are you all doing out
there um
my name is dylan beatty i am gonna be
your host for the rest of the day
here live on the internet we are
streaming
nbc manchester the first nbc manchester
conference
uh live on youtube all day we're going
right through till six o'clock tonight
uh we got some amazing speakers and
content coming up for you we've got a
stacy cashmore will be joining me in a
few minutes to talk about building your
personal brand using blazer and personal
apps we've got steve sanderson
uh janani subia irina skurtu heather
downing mark rendle ian cooper
richard campbell and carl franklin
joining us later with a special
live edition of dot net rocks so it is
gonna be an
awesome day uh the way that this thing
is gonna work it's not just a broadcast
it is a two-way
interactive event uh say hello in the
youtube chat i can see hey lars is on
the call hey lars how you doing
um robin dan tom so yeah get involved
get in the chat
say hello let us know what you're
thinking we're going to be running all
kinds of interactive stuff through the
course of the day we're going to be
running some
prize draws my keyboard has warped in
the sunlight yeah i left it too near a
glass of water and it melted and went
all went all curvy so
so yes welcome and it's been a
very very strange year i was just
looking back
through my calendar for the last 12
months and uh so this time last year
we had nbc copenhagen was the first to
the third of april 2020
and uh it was all set to go you know we
had a venue booked in copenhagen and we
had speakers and people had got plane
tickets and all this kind of stuff
everything was happening and then as you
know we all
remember and know well the pandemic hit
and it hit
hard and it hit very very suddenly uh
things started locking down
and we had about three weeks to figure
out how do we run a conference over the
internet
and we uh scrabbled we got hold of all
the speakers we could we're like have
you got any ideas we talked to partners
sponsors we did the most i think the
most intensive week of investigation
of different formats for doing online
video and presentations and
chat and all this kind of stuff um and
we came up with a format and we made it
happen and we ran
ndc copenhagen online and
at the time you know if you all think
back to it we're like it might be like
this for
for a month month or two maybe until the
summer if you you know you remember that
and some people were like it's going to
be longer and some people were like it's
only going to be a couple of days
so we're like we'll do copenhagen online
and then we had ndc porto which was
april last year right the end of april
we had that
all set up and ready to go and uh
started putting some plans in place for
doing that online if we had to and we
did
and then ndc oslo which is our biggest
flagship event that last
june we ran that online we had over a
thousand people connected live for
three days of sessions and stuff it has
been uh astonishing
learning curve for everybody involved in
exploring the the limits of the
technology figuring out what's possible
how we can make all this stuff work
um but we did it and you know we're
developers we're nerds as soon as we
know how to do something we get bored
and we're like let's do something
different
and so we wanted to launch ndc in
manchester this year there's an amazing
technology scene up in manchester in the
north of england
uh we're gonna have some some guests
joining us a bit later to tell us more
about that and how you might be
interested in getting involved with some
of it
but we had an amazing venue lined up and
all this kind of stuff
and they were thinking is it gonna
happen is it not gonna happen and when
it became apparent that we weren't gonna
be able to do an in-person event in
manchester this year we thought well
what should we do instead uh we could do
another but because it's a new event
because we've never done manchester
before
we wanted to do something a little bit
different we wanted to connect with some
people we'd not had a chance to
connect with before we wanted to have a
chance to
um you know reach a new audience give
some new speakers an opportunity to
become part of the whole
the ndc community and we thought what
about a live conference
i'm actually what what uh so jacob
bradford who's the manager of ndc
conferences who kind of puts all this
together behind the scenes what he
actually said to me
what if we did a conference that was
like eurovision like eurovision song
conference
um so that's me i'm gonna be graham
norton or maybe terry logan if you're a
viewer of a certain age for today
but that's the kind of energy and format
that we are trying to go for today we
are
uh live on the internet we're gonna be
streaming all day we got guests
joining us in the the studio here we'll
talk a little bit late
later about the studio setup and how we
we put all this stuff together
but i'm going to introduce you now to
some of the tools that we're going to be
using to make this thing feel like a
live and interactive event
uh so throughout the day our speakers
are going to be streaming to your life
and we're going to be using a platform
called slido
to take all your questions so we're
going to do a little slido warm-up
exercise now so if all
you jump across to here you can join
the slido at slido.com
ndcmcr that is the code for today
and we're just going to run a couple of
little word cloud polls just to
kind of wake everyone up and see if it's
all working out there so
let's kick this off get over there
ndcmcr
and just let us know stick your comments
there it's going to build a dynamic word
cloud for us
um what country are you joining us from
this morning i've already seen some
folks in the chat from uh
from nepal oh wow awesome hey nepal we
got germany we've got south africa
um we got by the way the way the slider
thing works we're going to be doing some
prizes and giveaways which is why we ask
you to register
later there's going to be some
interactive ndc quizzes so give us your
your name and your email address and
that way if you win something we'll be
able to follow up later and
find out your shipping details someone
from mansfield uh
yeah so richard said login yeah just
it's just registration we just we need
an email address so that if you win
anything
uh we can send you your stuff and figure
out where you are
um all right we've got uh what do we got
uk
england netherlands denmark united
kingdom bristol
uh stepper switzerland we got someone
joining us from hello world hey hello
world nice to see you
um hello world says hello world back
we've got a yorkshire
lincoln porto this is this is awesome
and the word cloud is working
and the latency is predictable and all
these little details uh this is the
first time as i said we've run an event
with this
this particular format and so
uh we're juggling a whole bunch of stuff
uh so yeah richard just just uh create
an account name an email address
um like i said it's because if you win
something in the prizes that where
the prize draws and quizzes we are
running later on slido
we got to be able to get hold of you
otherwise you have this thing where it's
like
we say all right well uh bob one two
three one the quiz and then we get a
hundred emails from people going hey i'm
bob123 can i have my prizes please
um and we have an authentication problem
so
uh yeah login email address name join in
with that and we're gonna be using that
to do
various bits and pieces throughout the
course of the day
but it's time to push one of the buttons
here on my
my magic little elgato stream deck that
is the nerve center of this entire
operation
and uh let us get the first of our
speakers
onto the call today i think stacy is
here and standing by
uh let's switch that across and i'm
gonna push that button there that's
gonna fall off there
[Laughter]
good morning stacy how are you good
morning i'm
fine thanks how are you doing
[Laughter]
oh you have no idea the amount of
equipment that i've got i'm in my little
home office here i've got the second
room in my house
that when i moved house a couple of
years back i have a room where i can
keep the computer and the drums and
stuff
um and uh stacy is pretty quiet let's
make stacey louder we crank that up a
little bit and we'll crack that up a
little bit there we go
um yeah we're fine we've got uh about
probably 10 miles of cable just in this
room and about another half a million
miles of cable around the world
and if you've ever done live events you
know the whole point is the more cable
you got the more likely it is that
something something may go wrong
at some point in the proceedings how do
you make life interesting
how are you stacy how have you been
keeping busy during lockdowns
uh i've been keeping busy in lockdown
trying
to do way too many talks
yeah oddly enough i give them more talks
in lockdown than i did before lockdown
well you don't have to travel so you can
use those extra days to do more talks
a little bit easier i talked in america
without getting on a plane
which for me is awesome um i have a
little fear of flying and going across
the atlantic is something that
kind of scares me just a little tiny bit
so one of the yeah it was nice to be
able to do that and
i've just started my um twitch stream
yeah i'm not ready to do live coding yet
i've not quite got that
level of courage but i'm building a uh a
lego 911
on twitch every sunday now which is a
lot of fun streaming lego on twitch
that's pretty awesome
so uh are you keeping like like frame so
you could do like a time-lapse
fast-forward build or you just
people go on and i'm not doing that for
this one what i generally do want to
build lego is just take lots of photos
and then just completely
um spam twitter with 20 pictures of
every bag that i build
but as soon as i'm streaming this one
live i don't really want to stop every
five minutes and go just get pictures
[Laughter]
so i'm just doing pictures of the end of
every stream this time and
uh uploading the build to youtube just
as a standard build
i think there are there are some
companies who have done very well out of
everyone having a lot of spare time and
i think the lego company is very
definitely one of them
and did you see the new space shuttle
discovery that was announced this week
i have two things i want to buy i i want
this well i want to buy the lego
shop but yeah the space shuttle
and the haunted house because that that
haunted house the adams family-esque
thing
with the vertical drop lift
that needs to be in my modulus street
fantastic
so what are you going to be talking to
us about what are you working on and
what have you brought here to ndc to
share with us stacy
i am going to be talking to you today
about
building your own brand which um
it kind of came from a
tweet that i saw last year that was
if you're posting to dev.2 to medium
whatever platform it is
as awesome as those platforms are you
are spending your time your energy
your expertise on building those
platforms up
and wouldn't it be better to have your
own place on the web and build your own
brander
so this is kind of the first steps to
starting to do that
i'm old enough to remember the internet
when there was no social media and
everyone had their own blog and their
own website
and their own mailing list and you know
things like like twitter and
microblogging didn't exist
so i'm very interested to see what what
is your you're going to be sharing with
us
um right on that note uh let's
hand over the stage please will you give
a big welcome
presenting live at ndc uh
are you sharing your screen stacy will
they be live coding indeed
okay you want to bring that up hopefully
we will switch across and if all this
works
it's always daunting being the first
person speaking at a conference
um because you're the one who gets to
discover all the problems with the
equipment that nobody found in rehearsal
it's either going to be awesome or it's
going to be hilarious and we're just
going to make the best of it so you show
your screen i'm going to push this
button and try not to knock the stream
back over this time
and uh we'll take things from there cool
thank you very much all right
and good morning everybody thank you so
much for joining me here today it's uh
i'm
absolutely psyched to be presenting at
nbc it's
uh we don't have your screen yet
sorry we don't have your screen yet you
don't have my screen yet that's so weird
because i press share i hate zoom
[Laughter]
do you have the screen now we have the
screen now there we go
you are live let me push that button
there and yes
we're good to go we have the first
fun of the day trying to get zoomed to
see our screen
how many developers does it take to
share a screening zoom
um yeah like i was saying i am really
psyched to be presenting at nbc when i
first started speaking a couple of years
ago
this was kind of on my list of
one of the conferences i desperately
desperately wanted to give a
presentation to
so this is awesome to be here
now like i was just saying last year i
saw this timeless tweet come across my
timeline
talking about building your brand um
that if you're blogging on somebody
else's site you're building their site
and
as awesome as these sites are i
personally blog on dev.2
and it's a great platform it's easy to
use it looks nice
there's lots of people using it but all
of my stuff is under dev dot 2
stacy cash i'm not building my own brand
and because that spoke to me i thought
well let's do something about this
so i went out and i got myself a domain
name and
because who can ever stop at one domain
name
i actually got myself three domain names
i got staceyclouds.net.com and dot dev
because
i couldn't decide which one to do and
then i did nothing
because i think there's loads of people
out there that will recognize that
buying domains and using domains are two
completely different hobbies
and the thing that stopped me from
moving forward was
the problem of eating the elephant if i
was going to make my own site
then i wanted to make my own site
that meant that i wanted to write it and
play with stuff
and learn things and it suddenly goes
from being this
simple thing of just installing
wordpress on a free hosting thing
somewhere and giving it a custom domain
and turning it into i need to write an
app to
display blog posts to allow people to
search for them to do authentication so
that i can do things inside of the app
to make it look awesome which is
interesting because i am
not a css expert as you're about to see
and all of the other things that you
need to do to make a really cool site
i have enough to do with my job at the
moment and
this thing was just so huge it was
sitting on me like a
lead weight and i just let it kind of
fall by the side just a little bit
and then in the middle of last year i
started playing with blazer
and specifically i started playing with
client-side blazer
and deploying it to azure static web
apps which
are currently in preview and
i started to see lots of possibilities
for what i could do with this thing
in my day-to-day job i use angular to
build web applications
and i am not an angular expert we have
an awesome team of developers that do
that but with blazer it's c-sharp that's
my day-to-day work
i can write stuff in the same language
as i use in the back end
deploying it to a static angular um
application inside of azure i only have
one resource
i get continuous integration delivery
out of the box when i create it
it just kind of makes my life easier
and it made me see that rather than
trying to eat this elephant
i can start to build my brand up in
small
bite-sized morsels and try and go step
by step
until i reach a point where i can go i'm
happy with this
i've now got a place where i can
introduce myself on the net
and on that note hi i'm stacey cashmore
i've been a software developer since the
mid-1990s and i'm a microsoft mvp
in developer technologies now
when i talk about static web apps
there's an amount of
advantages and disadvantages that i
think i want to cover before we get
started with the fun stuff
now first advantage there's no server
it's serverless
and yes we all know there's at least one
server in serverless but i don't care
about it
it's much easier to maintain than having
to make
a fully fledged azure app service web
app and
trying to organize everything
independently
it also allows me to host my azure
functions in that same
single resource inside of azure as my
front-end runs which means
i don't have to have separate functions
i don't have to make them taught to each
other
it's just done for me again it makes my
life just a little bit easier
for a side hustle and the third one is
that workflow
when you create a static web app inside
of angular
it gives you a github action which gives
you continuous integration continuous
deployment
it even gives you a way to do pull
requests and check your work
in a production-like environment before
you go live and this is all out of the
box
i don't have to do anything for it and i
like things i don't have to work for
there's also disadvantages of course if
you've got the advantages it also goes
the other way too
the first one there is that wonderful
word
preview this is not in general
availability yet
i don't know when it's going to go into
general availability and that means that
whilst i'm using it for my website and
whilst i might use it for some
small things at work i would not run
production loading this
just yet i want to wait until it's
general availability before we do that
it's also at present github actions only
i know that they're working on getting
it to work
with azure devops but right now if your
code's not inside of
github it's really difficult to work
with it's probably not the technology
for you
and then there's two more things which
are worth mentioning which they're not
necessarily
disadvantages but i like to talk about
them one
is scott hanselman's wonderful phrase of
knowing the magic one layer below the
metal that you're using
and you can't really do that with this i
am using an azure static web app and i
am using the out of the box
github action and it is one
single action which builds your site
discovers your site deploys your site
handles the pull request environments
for your site
i don't know what it does inside and i
kind of wish i did
it's not a problem it's just i wish i
had that little bit extra knowledge
and the last one i have heard people
complaining that in order to set this up
you have to authorize the azure portal
to make changes in your github repo i
don't have an issue with that i know
what it's doing i know people who are
against it
on principle and for them it's just not
the technology for them to use today
with all of that aside let's start to do
the
fun stuff now and let's actually create
a client-side blazer application
with an azure function api make it do
something
to show you how it works and then let
let's get it deployed
after that we're going to make it do
something really fun so
the first thing that we need to do is
create our static web app
so inside of my visual studio i hope
i've made this big enough for everybody
to see
we are going to create if the computer
does its thing come on you can do this
a blazer app we're going to call this
client
and when you set up your workflow inside
of the azure portal
by default it looks for client and api
as a project name
so you can call this what you want but
it just works
much cleaner through the step through if
you just call it client here
i need to put my code in that location
so that my
github repo picks it up and i need to
give it
a special name this is just so that the
demo picks it up this isn't something
you particularly need to do it just
makes it quicker to show you stuff
so for the blazer web assembly app we're
going to be running in net 5.0
we are going to configure it for https
but because we want to run it in a
static website we are
not going to click the asp.net core
hosted switch
and because i'm doing nothing with
progressive web apps we're going to
leave that one as well
so let's create this one and let it
scaffold up
and let's hope that the computer can
handle both the zoom
and creating a little application
i remember computers in the 90s were
really slow too it seems that no matter
how powerful they get they don't get any
quicker
now inside of our solution we are going
to be adding a new project
and that's going to be our azure
function this is how we're going to get
our data to our client-side application
and like i said we're going to call this
api just because that's an
easy way to get this set up
we want a http trigger
so that we can call the api let's get
this scaffolded
come on you can do it computer and there
we go
now there's a couple more things that we
need to do just to get this working
locally
first one is because we need to
run both the client and the api to do
debugging i want to set multiple startup
projects
here in our properties
and that's kind of it if i deploy this
now it will work but it's not going to
do anything special for us yet
so the first demonstration i'm going to
show you is just how to get data from
that api
and anybody who's created a blazer
client-side app will recognize this
counter fetch data
and index page that we have and we're
going to use this fetch data page
in order to do the first demonstration
what this does out of the box is get
data from a json file on the server
and it just puts that data on the screen
so that you can see to get data from the
back end and put it forward
we're not going to do this from the json
file we're going to use an azure
function for this
to show how to do a call to the back end
first thing we're going to do is rename
this to weather forecast because i
hate the name function one
and then because you really don't want
to spend the next 35 minutes watching me
do typo after typo after typo
i've got some code snippets i'm going to
bring over
so this is your function it's going to
be a really simple one all we're going
to do is return
an array of weather readings just to
pretend that we're that json file
that our client can use so this is all
we need here we're just literally
returning some hard-coded data and it's
going to come through to our client
in the client itself we need to make a
couple of changes
in our fetch data page we need to get
the data from the right location
so let's bring that across instead of
bringing it from the weather.json we're
going to get it from this api
weather forecast now we can deploy this
right now
to a standard web app and it will work
for us we can't
debug this yet because inside of a
static web app there's
a proxy and done so that the api and the
client site run on the same url
that isn't the case on my computer so
we're just going to need to make
something to allow
our web app to go across site in order
to get the data that we need
first one that we need to do here is
create inside
of our client application a new file
i can try uh let me just create this
class and now have a look
so let's create this
go back to the page then and
come on
is that better okay
so now that we've added our app
settings.json
which apparently i i did totally the
wrong thing here but yeah it's called an
app settings.json so it'll do
we're just going to bring in one setting
and that's going to be our api prefix
and we're going to point this at
localhost 7071
so we can talk to our api this is where
the function runs by default
but we need to know how to use this
because having it is one thing using an
is a second and for that we need to make
a change to our program cs
and on line 20 we have
our http client that we're going to use
to get this data
and it gives it the base address of just
um the host environment and we don't
want that
we want to add this little bit here
saying if we have a configuration for
api prefix use that otherwise
then we'll just use a host address so in
azure it will just run normally
on the local machine it allows us to
talk to this different port number
and talking to that different port
number unfortunately gives us a second
issue
and that is that we are now making a
cross-origin request to our api
so we need to allow the function to cope
with that
so we're not going to add a class
because i'm adding totally the wrong
thing there
we're going to add a new item and this
item is going to be
a json file again and we're going to
make
a launch settings so that when we hit f5
it does a certain thing
and for this all we're going to do is
bring across
a command line argument that says if i'm
running this
just run it with cause enabled for
anything so i can talk to it from my
client side
and if i have done everything correctly
here
she says hopefully the build should
start we should get
our function running we should get our
front end working
and we should be able to see things
happening
come on you can do this little computer
honestly yeah here we go
so now we have our client uploading the
first time you load the blazer app it is
a little bit slow because it is bringing
that wisencompiled.net environment down
into your browser but once it's there it
is kind of blazingly
fast and i just want to show you on the
back end
that i really am getting the data from
where i said i was getting the data from
so if we come here we've got our data
loaded
and we can see that it's coming from
we are talking to that um function in
the back end
one last thing to do before we make our
first deploy and that is set up our
routes
when you're making a client application
because everything runs in the browser
the server doesn't know about any of
your routes
if we deployed this as is we could click
to everywhere we would go to all of the
routes
but if you press f5 on something you're
going to get a 404 error
because it's going to go to the server
looking for your route and it doesn't
exist so we need to give it away to fall
back
and find the right location now when i
first did this
i did it in totally the wrong way i set
up a really
complex proxy using azure functions
it worked but it was a little bit
hideous
and it turns out there's a much easier
solution that we should use
and that is the roots.json
is a file we can put in our www route
yet another json file
and you know what i might actually give
it the right name
it's early in the morning
and inside of this roots.json we're just
going to tell it to do
tell it what it needs to do if it can't
find what it's looking for
so anything that's not found redirect to
index.html and of course returns that
status code of 200
otherwise we still get a 404 in the
browser
now we can deploy this and it should
work well for us
should so let's push this up to my
github reaper
yes save this let's check that it does
actually push otherwise the next bit is
going to be a little bit boring
yep that's gone and now let's jump to
our browser and
actually show our application
now i have my repo here
so if i refresh this there's my api
there's my client
and we're gonna set up a new static web
app inside of azure
i have a resource group that i've
already made this laser talk demo
resource group
and we're going to add a new resource
here
and that's going to be our static web
app which is in preview
we will create this
we'll wait for azure to catch up check
this subscription and
resource groups correct
check i can type see this is why i have
code snippets to bring across
because typing when people are watching
is um interesting
laser demo i'm in the netherlands so i
want to run this inside of west europe
and then i need to sign in with github
that thing that
like say i know one or two people that
just really have an issue with
so let's log in there yep that's now
authorized then we just need to check
what code we want to deploy
so i want to deploy the blazertalk demo
i want to deploy the main branch and
then you get a load of presets that you
can do so you can deploy angular react
spell
vue and the one that we're going to pick
here the laser
we need to tell the github action where
our client is
where our api is like i say this is why
i called it client and api
and give it an output location that it
builds to now as far as i can see
this can be anything you like as long as
it's not an existing directory inside of
your repo
otherwise bad things happen so let's
review and create this
that looks good and
static web apps take like seconds to
create they are
really quick so the deployment's
complete we can go to the resource
and now we have this ashy stone i love
the names they come up with for this
and if we click on this and if
zoom stops getting in my way we can now
see that we have a static web app it's
live
it's waiting for your content where is
that content
well that's here we have this github
action that has just been added
and this is kicked off and like say this
builds
our client it builds our api it deploys
it and it makes it all work
wonderfully it also takes about five
minutes and i don't particularly want to
stand here and watch this for five
minutes there's other stuff which i'd
rather go through with you so we're
going to come back to this soon
in the meantime i want to go back to my
code
and now that we've
made our static web app let's start
working on making it
um a little bit nicer and not just a
standard blazer application
let's actually start to build our brand
our first one i want to do is just close
all of this
to clean this up a bit and then we're
going to clean up our solution just a
little bit remove stuff we don't need so
that we've got a clean base to start
with
first one is we don't need that weather
forecast so let's get rid of that one
the second one is i don't want this
counter demonstration so we can get rid
of that
i don't want the fetch data
demonstration so let's get rid of that
in our shared folder there's a couple of
changes i want to do just to get rid of
a couple of extra things
and the main layout i want to get rid of
the blazer information
because i want to add my own stuff there
at some point
and in our navigation menu and all of
this is scaffolded for you out of the
box so you don't have to think about
layout in the beginning you can delay
that till later
again not eating that elephant but i do
want to get rid
of the navigation links for the things
that we've just
removed so now we have this cleaned up a
little bit
now we can start to add our own things
and we've got three steps that we need
to take in order to start putting our
own work on the net the first one is we
need the api to get the data that we
want to display
and we need to pass it forward to our
website
and then in that website we're going to
need a service which gets a hold of that
data and stores it for us so we're not
doing a call
every time we want to see the data and
then we're going to need to make just a
couple of components to put it on the
page and to show it to our users
so the first step in all of this is
getting the data from dev.2
i say that's where i post when i write
blogs
and they have a really nice api
available for us
we can just go to articles and passing a
username and we get a list of the
summaries
for that user so here we have a list of
my articles i've written
you don't need a developer key for this
this works out of the box
and we can use this to start putting our
own information
on our own web page
so let's go back to our code the first
thing that we need to do is add a couple
of models
if we're going to do this because we
need to know the data we're receiving
and we need to know the data that we're
sending out to the client app
so let's add a new folder because i like
to keep my code
a little bit organized and we're going
to add two classes here
the first one is going to be a text post
summary
and this one is just going to hold the
data that we're going to send through
to our client side application
and here we just have the id of the blog
post the url the title description the
cover image which i don't use in this
demo but i forgot to take out of the
link
and the publish date for that particular
blog post
then we need to know what information do
we want from that dev.2
api so we're going to add a second model
here
and that one we're going to call a dev2
blog post summary
and for this one i just used a tool that
i found
in google i pasted the json result
and it gave me a nice c object a c sharp
object back
so that i can just get the data i need
i've removed all of the extraneous
things that i'm not interested in so
again i'm only getting the id the title
the description
the url and it's just um
something that i can now use to read the
data i want
from that json that i get back
now we need an adapter to convert
between the two
so let's call it adapters
and of course this you could do with
something like um
i've forgotten the word because my brain
has just gone empty
but we could do this automatically but
it's just
a small piece of code so i don't
particularly mind adding it
add a new class and we're going to call
that
blog post summary adapter
and this doesn't do a whole lot
this just takes in adjacent input
d serializes it to a an innumerable of
dev2 posts
and then we just read out the things one
by one like i said you could do this
with automapper
but it's such a small piece of code i
don't particularly mind doing this by
hand just for one adapter
last but not least we need our function
of course
because without a function we can't
actually get our data back
so let's add a new azure function to our
project let's just call it blog posts
we want a http trigger
we get a nicely scaffolded
class back which we're not going to be
using
instead we're just going to have a small
get function
that runs on blog posts
come on computer what are you doing and
all this does is get a http client yes i
should probably use dependency injection
for this but for demo
it's fine and we're just getting the
articles from dev.2
converting them into our blog post
summaries and returning those to our
client
and that's all that we need to do for
our azure function this should now work
for us
now we need to actually display this
data in our site
and for that the first thing i want to
do is add a
model to the front end for the data that
we're going to receive
and yeah i should probably share this
between the back end and the front end
here but
again it's such a tiny amount of code
that for a demonstration i don't mind
repeating myself just a little bit
so let's add a new class again
we're going to call that blog post
summary spot the deliberate mistake
there
and inside here again we just have the
id blog url
title description cover image and
publish that so this is now available to
us
inside of our frontend
then we're going to add our service so
let's add a new folder here for services
again let's try and keep it slightly
organized
and inside of services we want to add
another class and we're going to call
that blog post summary service
and all this is going to do is
make that call to the api
but only if we need to here we are
injecting the http client because we get
it out of the box
in our client application and we just
have one function which loads summaries
and what it says is if our summaries
property is null
or if we have said force this load so i
always want to get new summaries
then get the summaries from our api
and that's it this is all that we need
to do to get the data from our
function into our application now we
just need to use this service
inside of our site now
if you're using a service inside of a
razor component it is useful to use the
dependency injection
so we're going to add that here and i'm
just going to import the using statement
so in our program.cs we just add a scope
service which is our blog post summary
service
we now have it available to us we can
start making our components
now the first one that we need to do is
we need to make a page
for our blog posts so we're going to do
that
inside of our pages folder here we're
going to add a new razer component
because
all pages are razer components
over all pages arrays of components not
all razer components or pages
i'll explain the difference in a second
and we're going to bring in just a
snippet here
at the top we have this page
property and we're going to set that to
blog post and that is the path in the
site
in order to reach here and then inside
we're just going to check to see whether
or not we have summaries in our service
class and if we don't we're just going
to say we're loading
get back to us in a second when we do
have summaries we're going to put each
one on the page
using this component that we're going to
be making in a second
but first of all we need to make the
code behind for our
razor component in order to get this
summary service
so let's add a new class
now that you can put all the code in the
front end but i just have a personal
preference for code behind it doesn't
matter
which way you do it uh if you do call
your code behind
the name of your component.cs then
visual studio
does nicely organize it for you here
and then the code that we want to bring
across here to make this work
we are implementing icomponent and our
backend
class needs to be a partial class in
order to work
with that frontend component we're
injecting our blog post summary
and all we have here is on
initialization load the summaries
that's all the code that we need the
service then does its thing and when
they're available
we will display this component
but of course we need to display this
component so
let's add that now you could put this
component in the page but hopefully if i
have time you'll see why i'm not doing
that
in a minute so new folder called
components
i think that's built right i hope that's
about right otherwise things are going
to go wrong in a minute
and in this component we're going to
want to make that blog
post summary component that we were just
talking about
so blazer component blog post summary
and here we just have a simple piece of
html
without that page directive so this one
cannot be used as a page
that just takes the summary title
description and blog url to put
our summary on the screen
and as you may have noticed we have red
squiggles again and that means that we
need another code behind file to make
this work
so let's add that class in here
and it's a really simple code behind
class
and all we do is add a parameter of a
blog post summary
that we can display on the front end our
red square was now gone
we can almost use this now and i say
almost because
we need to add a using statement to get
access to this blog post summary
but if you're doing anything in blazer
rather than adding the using statement
to each of the components
there's this wonderful underscore
imports.razer file
and we can add our components in here
and
if we go back to our
[Music]
blog post razer page now we can see that
it's picked it up from the right
place there's one last thing that i want
to do
for my first attempt at building my
brand
and that is why is the user can come to
my site
and they can click on the blog post and
see the list of them
i want them to see the latest blog post
on the front
end first so i think i've just about got
enough time
to show you this one too and for that
one we have our index raiser this is our
main
page and at the moment all it does is
say hello world welcome to your new app
light of lighting blah
we're going to add a back end
or a code behind to this one too so
index.razer.cs
and here we're just going to bring
across a couple of code snippets
so the first one is just our empty class
make sure that it works
and then we have the summary that we
want to
put on the front of the screen so we
have our blog post summary service the
same as we had before
we have a private property of a summary
and we have a public property with a get
and what we say is if our summary is
already loaded
put that one on the screen if we don't
have a summary to display yet
then get it from the blog post summary
and for that we need just a couple more
functions to make that work because we
don't have get blog post summary yet
and for this one we just say from our
service summaries
if they exist order them descending by
the public state as in i want the latest
and get me the first one because that's
the one i want to put on the screen
and of course on the initialized async
we need to call that load
summaries again now we can add
the code to the razer page itself
to actually get our
function and we don't want hello world
because hello world's boring these days
we want
build your own brand
and again if the service summaries is
null we want it to show loading
if we have it if we don't have any blog
posts and just say
sniff sniff we don't have one if we do
have a blog post we're using that same
blog post summary component to display
it on the page
so let's run this one locally and show
you this in action
so hopefully this builds reasonably
quickly again come on computer you can
do it
seriously it doesn't matter how fast
computers get they are never fast enough
they always leave you looking at it
thinking why are you taking so long
it's doing stuff and of course it's open
the browser along the screen again so
let's bring that here
and here we have build your own brand we
are loading from the back end and here
we have my blog post setting up an azure
environment this is a series that i was
writing a while ago i need to do the
next one sometime soon
and if we click on the link we go
straight to dev.2
so we can actually see our code
and i realized that i forgot to put
the navigation link in here so i'm gonna
have to do this the hard way
come on
if i go to my blog post screen now we
can see
all of the blog posts that i have
available and again we can click on any
of them and open them up in a new screen
so we have taken that first mortal
of putting our own website onto
the internet we're still using all of
the cool stuff dev.2
it's just that first step people can now
find it on our site
now before i push this up to github i do
want to make sure that i
add the navigation links because
otherwise it's
way too much of me having to type
and for that one we come into this
navigation shared class
the one that we deleted everything from
earlier and we're just going to add an
extra one to go to blog posts
and i don't want a plus button i want a
document button to be displayed
make sure i've not broken anything
so now we're going to push this up to
github and hopefully it's going to
deploy in time for me to show you this
working before i run out of time
so add devdot to link
we're gonna commit all and push
and then let's see whether
of course we need to do a pull because
when i created the
um static web app it created
that um action for us so we need to do a
pull before we can push
that seems to be done now let's go back
to
our actions that first one ran we can
see the second deploy is already going
we have that continuous delivery set up
because i push to master it's going
straight out
and if i now go to my blazer demo
and we click on this link there is
our hello world app live in the world
deployed automatically
and using that api back end to make sure
we get the data that we want
so that's kind of the first bits that i
wanted to show you there's only one
thing left to do whilst it's deploying
and that is this url yeah ashy stone
does look cool
but it is not the brand that we want to
build i got my own url
so let's have a look at how we can add
our own url
to our static web apps now for this one
i'm going to go through it quickly
and then go for it a little bit slower
for you to show you each of the steps
and i do that because
this takes a few minutes to work i have
a static web app already set up
i can come to the custom domains i can
add a new one
i'm going to add www.stacyclouds.com
and i'm going to validate to make sure
that works
and then i'm going to add it so this is
now creating the custom domain
like say this takes a few minutes we'll
come back to that in a second
i have a second app here and i can go
through
a little bit slower trying to show you
what i've just done
so a static web app you can add a
a single right now custom domain to it
so the whole custom domain z
is a little bit of a misnomer i hope
they fix that before we get to general
availability
and if we click add we get this nice
slide in panel saying
what is your url because we need to
validate this before we connect to it
so if we do www.stacyclouds.dev
and i try it tells you you need to add a
cname record
with this value so that it knows that
you have access
to this um url and you're allowed to use
it
now if you don't have that available
it's going to give you
a validation error the cname record is
invalid please make sure it's correct
this can take about 48 hours for it to
go through sometimes that's why
this one is set up before and it's the
only bit of this that you can't say in
40 minutes you can set up this amazing
thing
because this bit takes two days you
don't have to do any work for two days
but it takes two days
if you have a url where it's not that
there's no cname record but except for
something else you get a different error
message
so this lets you know that the request
envelope is invalid
the custom domain is linked to something
else you can't use it for this site
so we have two error messages telling us
what we need to do
so that is how we set this up let's
cancel this
i have five minutes left this is always
the interesting part of the demo the
last two things
take time and are they going to work
fast enough
custom domain is currently being created
the github action is still running
this could get a little bit interesting
um right what can we do whilst that is
waiting to be deployed
uh there's one last thing that i can
show you whilst it's being deployed
actually and that is
the workflow that i was talking about
when you make a pull request and you
want to check that something works
before you merge it
i have one set up earlier for those in
the uk lupita here's one i made earlier
when you create a pull request and there
is a github action
for a static web app it will do you a
deploy
to your url dash
your full request number this is pull
request number one
west europe and then the rest of the
standard application
so if we go to this location we still
see
our application and i think i made a
change here
i made a change on my site too oh the
weather outside
is frightful because when i first made
this demonstration it was terrible
weather here and snowing outside
if i go to the standard web app and i do
that like say by removing that dash one
dot west europe
and i reload the live site and go to
fetch data we can see we have
two different pieces of information and
that allows us to check that the changes
we've made are doing what we want it to
do
before we actually push it to production
and again
this all comes out of the box which i
kind of love
so that is how we do our
pull requests the other nice one here is
obviously you don't want this to sit in
the air forever
uh but when you complete your pull
request it will delete this
and clean up after itself and again you
don't have to do anything which is
always cool
one word of warning here and it's also
mentioned in the documentation
this is life for the world to see if you
are putting something up to your web app
which you don't want the world to see
you can't use this functionality i'm
afraid you have to just test it locally
and hope it works in production
now how we're doing we have the custom
domain created so i can show you the
custom domain now
so we had for this web app talk let's
close this one
come on close for this
um static pr if we open this link
we have the website yet again that
wonderful blazer
just scaffolded application if we now go
to www.stacyclouds.com
we see that same application it's
working for us
um there's a couple of things to know
here one
is it only works for www right now you
can't do anything other than www
which means if somebody goes to
stacyclouds.com
they're going to get a completely
different page
parked on the bun because that's where
my dns is located
you can fix this with all sorts of
different um
things depending on how your dns allows
you to handle this
you can set up an azure function to do
linking food to this
but it's something to bear in mind
hopefully before we go to ga they're
going to fix this because obviously
this is a big no-no if you actually want
to use this for a proper production
thing
the last one i see that
our second deploy is finished
so if i go to my ashy stone the one that
we've just created
go to the home page we now get
our dev top 2
latest blog post on the front we have a
blog post button which takes us to all
of our blog posts
you'll notice this displays instantly
because
we are keeping those blog post summaries
inside of that service so we don't have
to load them each time
and when we click on it we can drop out
to the outside world
so that is pretty much what i wanted
to show to you today in the last 40
minutes
39 minutes we have managed to create a
website we've made an azure function url
we've deployed it into azure using those
static web apps
and then we've made changes to start
building your own brand
without eating the elephant there's lots
more stuff i still need to do to this of
course i want to make it look awesome i
want to put my own css on the top of it
i want to host my own blogs and change
that canonical url in dev.2
so that google starts to point to my
site just a little bit
but i can do this step by step as i go
forward
and start to build up my own brand on
the internet
now if this has got you interested you
want to have a play with this then i
recommend going to ms learn and taking a
look at the documentation for this
this qr code will take you straight
there and if you don't want to build
this
i would still recommend going to mslan
because there are
so many amazing resources there that
can help you improve the way that you
use microsoft's technology
so that is it for me today thank you so
much for spending this first hour with
me thank you so much to nbc for having
me
and i hope you enjoy the rest of the day
thank you very much stacy that
was fantastic let's get a massive
global round of applause emojis
we have some questions in slido and in
the chat so the
the top voted question is and this is
something that i actually a lot of
people asked about blazer
um it does building a blazer app and
then hosting it
in azure is there a cost of entry is it
possible to do this
without incurring costs right
now the static blazer web app is free
so um it's it is possible to do free i
believe
i believe if you use the azure function
then standard azure function pricing uh
applies to it
but you know what unless you are doing
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of calls to your function it's pretty
much free
so there you go yes it is free you can
do this stuff for free um
another question that comes up about
blazer that a couple of people said in
the chat
uh is it gonna be another silverlight i
see that
that would come up every time uh it is
not another silverlight i am very
pleased to say
because it is a wasm compiled version of
the dotnet runtime
it is native to the browsers so
so wasm is web assembly which is
actually baked into the browser it's not
any kind of a plugin or anything
and exactly as we've learned from long
history once something is in a web
browser you can never take it out
yes otherwise bad things are going to
happen except java applets but you know
[Laughter]
that was a good thing uh quick question
can we get the source code for this demo
i assure you what you were pushing stuff
up to github there
is that a repo you can make public or
share with us um
i what i'm gonna do i have one repo
which is without the dev.2 stuff and i
will put that link on twitter because i
can't remember it from the top of my
head so i'm going to share that one on
twitter
and i think i'm going to have to make a
blog post out of this talk as well
so my partner's going to kill me for
saying this but inside of four weeks
there's going to be another blog post
kind of going through how to do this
uh question from lee you talked in the
demo there about some 404s are they
logged anywhere before the redirect
happens
uh no they're not logged anywhere i
don't believe
i will happily be corrected there
presumably that's something you could
plug in a handler or something if you
did want to capture those before
redirecting
yeah i would assume so this is uh that
the whole
um roots.json part of blazer
it's something which i've not got into
too deeply yet that's one of the bites
of the elephant that i
still need to take uh so i'm not a
hundred percent sure exactly how this
works i don't know if it's the static
web app itself
that takes this because there isn't
anything running
this is all purely inside of the static
web app so i don't know how you can put
some middleware into this um
what you can do or what you will see is
that
if you put in a route which doesn't
exist
you will still get your hey this page
doesn't exist
um thing coming up because it can't find
your route in the client side
and for that you can put your own
logging software in there
and i think i'd probably recommend doing
that because unless you explicitly want
to know when somebody deep links to your
application
i don't think logging the 404s to the
back end is
entirely useful
cool all right thank you um a couple
more questions
uh before we take a short break um does
the link require the server to load
all of the json or can it for example
transpile to odata
uh i have absolutely no idea
i'm going to be totally honest there i
really don't know
there you go um never be afraid to admit
that you don't know something it's
an opportunity to learn so absolutely um
uh question richard says is the
scaffolded layout there in blazer is
that based on bootstrap do you know
i believe so it looks bootstrappy it
also it also looks like bootstrapping
it's i mean the next step that i'm going
to do because the link that i showed for
the stacyclouds.net
it looks remarkably similar to the one
that i've just shown on the screen
my next step is just stripping out all
of this css and trying to learn css
whilst doing it
that sounds like a fun project i look
kind of cool before i take the next step
forward and
i hate css the other not my thing the
other nice thing folks watching on the
stream might have noticed is that the
the purple gradient on the blazer
default thing
is almost exactly the same gradient as
the ntc manchester branding
we asked them to do that especially
because we knew this was going to happen
um now just a couple more questions two
last questions both about
uh github actions one of them is can you
align github actions
with your different azure devops
environments
um it's not something i've done the
first time i gave this talk
somebody was really um not necessarily
the politest
in the chat telling me i was completely
wrong for saying you cannot use
um static web apps in azure you just
have to run around roundabouts to do it
so
possibly i i do know that the team is
busy working on
uh getting azure devops to work with the
static web apps
um i believe it was supposed to be
available in march but i'm guessing it
slipped
fair enough um and uh last question
is can you add step actions to github to
do qa tests and to block deployment in
case of failure
it is just a standard uh workflow file
so
if you want to do those tests before you
call
the actual um github action that does
the
uh static website stuff yep you can do
that you can do what you want inside of
there
fantastic all right thank you very much
stacey for joining us this morning
thank you very much for having me thank
you folks on the stream for all your
excellent questions
uh we are going to take a short break
now we are going to
interrupt the stream just for a second
and there's a couple of comments and
chat about folks only getting 720 pixels
of high def on the other end of it
and uh we have found what i think is the
setting that needs tweaking but i can't
tweak it without stopping the stream
we're going to be off the air for about
15 seconds
then we're going to take a short break
uh during the break head over to
expo.nbcmanchester.com
our partners have got some expo booths
set up over there
uh fill out your details it for a chance
to win some amazing prizes we got some
airpod airpods pro or airpod pros we
don't
what what's the the plural of that uh we
got some special lego sets giving away
we're giving away some some workshop
tickets and various other things
so head over check that out we'll be
back in
like i said about 15 seconds then we're
going for a commercial break and
then we will have ian cooper joining us
to talk about tdd
revisited so we'll see you all in a few
seconds
[Music]
we're back we're live and apparently
according to anthony in the chat 1080p
is working now all right
let's admit the next of our speakers
please everyone welcome to ndc
i'm gonna press a button here that is
gonna fix the layout it's all very very
sophisticated here at
the headquarters as you can tell uh
there we go
and uh welcome ian cooper how are you
doing
hey my friend i'm all right this morning
how are you yeah okay
i'm i'm live on the internet with uh
200 300 odd people watching which is
always an exciting way to start the day
it's better than espresso for giving you
that
that little shot of energy in the
morning so
i've had to lock the cat out for
the cat has become possessed and attacks
me
so i decided that i didn't want the
viewers to wonder why is ian screaming
strangely during the middle of his
present presentation
it'd be difficult to explain the cat is
actually biting me
excellent stuff we are actually just
want to check we've got some setup to do
we're going to take
a very short break we are going to run a
commercial reel we got a bunch of
sponsors
uh we've got eventy we've got imago
which is the manchester airport group
uh we've got synopsis we've got uh all
kinds of people black marble have helped
us put this event together
they've supported ndc throughout
everything we've done pre-pandemic and
during the pandemic
we're gonna hear from them now for a
couple of minutes and then we are gonna
be back in a few minutes
with ian cooper and tdd revisited
we'll see you shortly
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
at identity we build technology that
makes it easier for dealers to sell
and consumers to buy vehicles
so what ibendy does is we build a
platform that facilitates online
retailing
this means that we basically make it
easier for people to buy cars and for
dealers to sell them
we do this from end to end
so the full journey from people
consumers coming to the site
right through to the finance
applications that go through so to
facilitate that we have really important
relationships with banks
with vehicle manufacturers and with
vehicle retailers themselves the tech
stack we use is mainly aws and we use
csharp.net as our predominant backend
language
and we use a little bit of azure as well
we deploy most of the stuff in
containers using kubernetes on eks
and we're a big fan of event sourcing
here that helps us to separate the
domains
out into separate areas which allows us
to
keep those domains nice and segregated
and also facilitates the auditing which
is a big part of us working in a
regulated environment
i chose ivendi mainly because of the
people they're very welcoming they're
really knowledgeable and seem really
passionate about the technology and the
quality of the products that they're
[Applause]
creating
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to margo we're an
airport-centric travel company and by
mark
the country's largest airport group most
importantly we're a globally unique
digital tech business based right here
in manchester we operate as an
innovation hub a truly agile e-commerce
business driven by
data and the latest tech to provide
airports across the world
with a unique blend of products
technologies and services for their
passengers
we have become synonymous with airport
customer ecommerce platforms which were
constantly evolving
if you plan to fly again in the near
future you may well use our system
without realizing that it's actually a
mango product we are a business for
someone who wants to create
and do something a bit different for the
techies
we have a fail fast ci cd approach
using.net core at the back
view and react to the front and aws
cloud hosting expect to grow
our team over the coming year so please
keep an eye on our mago linkedin page
for the latest jobs thank you
[Music]
yes
so
[Music]
and we're back hello internet how are
you all doing
out there um yes joel you need to go out
and buy a 4k tv so you can get the
maximum stream quality out of this uh we
are here in the virtual studio with ian
cooper how you doing ian i'm good my
friend yeah
yeah ready to sort of share some stuff
about um tdd with everybody so
so you had a talk from uh was it 2014
about tdd where did it all go wrong
yeah i kind of was 13 or 14 but but
long enough ago that we got old yeah and
it was a it was a
a talk that got so many hits on youtube
that it made you cool with teenagers i
understand
it did yeah the uh my my stepson
who is convinced i know nothing about
anything decided he wanted to become a
youtube star
and i did say to him or have you ever
seen you know my youtube video
and he he replied what that you and your
five mates watched
and when i pointed to the numbers on
youtube like for at least 10 minutes
he was slightly in awe of the fact that
i seem to be some kind of youtube star
he since disabused himself in most of
those notions but there was a moment
dylan just a moment
it was just a moment where you were
actually cool
yeah remember where i was actually cool
thanks for that again thanks to the
power of test driven development
indeed so what else uh we've got about
five minutes before we we kick off the
talk itself um what else have you been
working on during the whole
the weird lockdown pandemic thing in
um interesting yeah uh so we're about to
get out a um version nine
of uh brighter which is the open source
project
i work on which helps you do messaging
in network and it's been a little bit of
time getting v9 out
we had a couple of the other
contributors go away on paternity leave
which is a which is a good thing
um but uh not quite originally in our
kind of planning
uh model um and uh
yeah there's some good changes coming we
clean up really
um our outbox and inbox support
uh we always had it but it was we had
different names because of the time at
which we wrote them those names weren't
really standard and we
our behavior was a little um unusual so
we've we've now
cleaned those up a bit we've got new
versions of some of our
uh transports like kafka and sms and sqs
and we've got for the first time we've
got an actual good
work solidly working one for azure we've
always had kind of prototypes and we
know that
it's fairly easy to write your own
transport for products and we knew that
people
out there had written their own
transports for a year and we finally got
some of them submit one back to the
project so that we've now got a working
one um and uh yeah so we're
pretty pleased excited to get that out
um we've been
playing a bit with things like you know
github actions we've got a slightly new
pipeline
um but uh toby henderson a friend of
both of us
has been beavering away trying to get
that to work properly so we can get that
all released yeah and that's been that's
been quite exciting recently so i'm
pleased to see that getting back on
track
and you've also been running some
occasional so ian and i for those who
don't know
uh we helped run the london.net user
group
which ian started uh when dotnet was in
beta i believe
like before even visual studio.net went
went to release in 2002 or so
it was yeah and often talk about the
fact that um
you know i was lucky enough to get into
speaking really because when we started
the user group
there were no speakers no one knew
anything about.net
so we had to kind of like go away and do
the research ourselves and come back and
present to the rest of the group
so it gets you over that hurdle of
talking to other people quite early on
it is one of the interesting things you
know i run workshops for for people who
want to get into conference speaking and
all kinds of things
um and there's two kinds of people i
talk to the the people who they see
someone who's on stage and they're just
amazing
and they're like oh i want to do that
that looks like so much fun but then
there's the kind of
the inspirational ones which are the
people who go to a meet-up and they see
somebody and they're like
i'm terrible but i'm better than that
yeah and
it's one of the really interesting
things about you know community events
is you do see people kind of very very
early on when they're still
figuring out the levels in the format
and it's a you know one of the things
that i think is
has been really interesting about ndc
online for the last year or so
um has been we're still seeing a
pipeline of of people who want to get
into conference speaking
and are submitting you know they've done
a talk at some online user groups and
meetups and they're submitting
that content and trying to you know get
that on the agenda for ndc and other
events that i work with
um which is brilliant that's something i
thought might not happen
i thought a lot of people would just be
like i'm going to wait till this is over
and then i'll try and get into speaking
but it hasn't and it's amazing to see so
many people
still enthused about about trying to get
into it and stuff
yeah i do wonder whether also in some
ways
you may even find that you know the
ability to do it from home
you're pulling in people who are more
used to you know twitch streaming models
etc so i'll be getting are we getting
some people who actually have been
working in this
kind of format now yeah singing with our
format
there was definitely a moment where i
was like i need to talk to people who
play minecraft on twitch because they
know more about this than any of us do
um so anyway it is their world suddenly
isn't it it is it is their world and we
are just playing in it but
uh we're starting to get the hang of it
i think anyway i make it uh 20 plus 10
by the official event clock here
so uh ian if you would like to share
your screen i will push the magic button
and hope that nothing blows up when i
push it this time
uh it didn't blow up i just knocked the
thing off last time i did this
all right let me just find the right one
[Music]
let's play that there we go
the magic will work uh you've done the
thing you need to click the button that
switch
switches the presenter view in the other
view but i'm gonna i'm gonna punch that
so uh
we're gonna switch the stream over
hang on so i did have this working i
managed to get it to do the right
the right screen there is there is a
hilarious combination of factors that
comes into play when you're doing this
which is the quite often when you do
something in zoom it moves windows
around that you had lined up
just neatly and just nice um actually
they all do that everything the the ones
that run on your desktop zoom and
uh you know webex and various other
other apps i've used
have a habit of going now we're going to
put this window over here now uh so
let's see what we can
see there is a yep hit it and if this
works
so there's a button top left that will
switch the displays
swap displays button that's the one you
want boom there we go
all right please give a big ndc
manchester online welcome
tdd revisited
in cooper hey all
and welcome um let's talk about uh tdd
so many of you may have seen that i gave
a talk back
in 2013 at ndc honestly called tdg where
did it all go wrong
and this talk doesn't contradict any of
that but it's designed
to give you perhaps slightly more
focused guidance for if you
kind of agree with the sentiment of that
talk of what you and your teams can
should take forward as as practices and
i've divided it into a set
of what i think of our fallacies that we
all hold about tdd
and what principles we should be using
instead
um you can find me on twitter my dms are
open
if you want to ask me about in this
material i will try and reply
my small children permitting um
nothing much too interesting to say here
i think dylan's spoken about quite a lot
of this just now with you and i
um uh and i would encourage you all to
try and get into
speaking if you can start your local
user groups they'll be hungry to hear
from you
uh and it you know you really can help
focus and develop your own ideas
as you just mentioned i work on open
source project on brighter we are
always keen to have new contributors
come and join us okay we've got a lot to
get through so let's really crack on
um so i'll talk a lot about these
fallacies and principles and at the end
i'll talk a little bit about clean
architecture
and how that can actually help us
okay so let's get into it the first
fallacy i want to talk about
is this is the key one i think and
that's the
idea that developers write unit tests
when we're doing test driven development
if i go away and look at wikipedia and
look at what its definition of unit
testing is the key idea is it's saying
that we want to
isolate the unit which is under test
and have substitutes uh which
effectively stub
in for the other units we may be
collaborating with
so that we can test that individual unit
in isolation
and that leads us to this idea of having
a unit test for the individual little
black box
an integration test which tests a couple
of black boxes talking to each other
and a system test which tests all of the
things
in one and the goal is this kind of idea
of defect localization i'll be able to
know
that the defect belongs inside this unit
that i am testing and that's where the
problem is
and if it's basically got tested units
then when i have two units tested
together the problem is how they
integrate
right and our goal is to essentially
help us find where these
where these problems occur
and there's a requirement really here to
have some notion of what we call a test
double generically
so usually we refer to this as a mock or
stub or a fake
we have a requirement to have those to
exclude the things
that aren't the thing that's under test
right
otherwise we can't achieve this defect
localization
and the height of this kind of approach
when people
in the kind of test driven development
area to talk about is this idea called
need driven development
and the idea behind need different
development is we start kind of at the
outside we write a class
and then we say okay it needs to talk to
another class so i will replace that
dependency
with a mock and that means that either
we need to have some idea of our class
hierarchy before we kind of begin our
testing
we may if we're very xp focused take
something like
crc cards and play those and have an
idea therefore of what we think our
object structure is
or we may do it by process of discovery
we write the test around our outer class
and as we dig
into it we say that's probably something
that's responsible for another class
and rather than write that class now
i'll simply stub it out
i'll put basically the definition for a
mock into my test
and then essentially i'll move on and do
the rest of the work that relates to
this
class and that leads to this pattern
where you are testing the expected
indirect outputs by that we mean
we test all these calls and make into
other classes and often
we're using that approach as saying well
i can figure out whether
this is behaving correctly because at
this point it should pass
this value to this other class
with you know in in the parameters it
makes in the method call to it
um and the problem with that a little
bit though is that
now our our test
understands all of the details of our
implementation
what we don't have it's something that
solely focuses on the contract
the thing the contract of the thing we
are testing right
we've coupled our tests
into our implementation details if i
want to change
how that works i now have to change the
test too so let's say that
one of those collaborator objects that
i'm talking to
i decide actually it has too many
responsibilities i need to split that in
two
in order to split that in two i have to
change my test
because i now have two mock objects that
i'm talking to
so this is coupling the test and the and
the implementation details are
inextricably linked together now by this
new driven development process
and my kind of experience of this um
even back in 2007
was that this was highly problematic
so when i wrote a class what i tended to
end up
with was under this kind of approach was
i had to basically take every single
collaborator
and provide a injection point in the
constructor
by using in a strongly typed language
interface where you can use duct typing
and things that are
dynamically tight so that effectively i
could inject all my collaborators
and the problem with this became that
all of our classes tended to end up with
three or four dependencies that they
were injecting
and because that collaborator itself
when we wanted to pass the concrete
typing it had
three or four dependencies we saw the
rise
of inversion of control containers
because it became too complicated to
build the graph ourselves
we couldn't do poor man's deon or the
compositional route i simply created a
few top level objects
which when they needed something we just
knew it up i had to essentially get
everything built via essentially this
model
of using an ioc container and we added a
lot of complexity to our code
just to support this idea of doing need
dragon development
but the problem became that our
as which before our tests will now break
whenever we want to change any of that
kind of graph
that we've set up so our tests have this
enormous dependency on this
this graph of need that we've created
our tests have become very needy
our code has become very needy and
that was never really our goal
our goal was to really think much more
about a contract first based approach to
testing
to say i want to understand
what is the contract that i'm expressing
in the code under test
i want to explore that through my tests
i don't want to understand the
implementation
of that contract and that leads us to
our first principle
which is the developers right developer
tests
and the word unit testing crept into our
lexicon
because it was something we used in
verbal
communication on common parents and kemp
was very aware of that in the tdd book
he said you know
verbally i call them unit tests but they
don't match the accepted definition unit
test very well
and in fact in the book the only single
place that he uses unit tests
is to deny them in this book right
everywhere else she just tends to use
the word test or occasionally in some
places small
test so explicitly ken is saying
these are not unit tests and they don't
meet that definition
so so what are tests how can we define
them what
should they be well one
key thing to understand is that the
cycle of
tdd is red green and refactor
and one of the problems you will find
with using a kind of
unit testing approach is that you end up
in many cases not doing very much
refactoring
and occasionally when i run a kind of
workshop around tdd i push people
through the exercise of using the unit
testing approach to doing a cata first
and one of the observations they often
find is they do have a red stage and
they have a green stage
but there's very little refactoring and
that's because you've done much of your
design thinking
up front in order to allow you to mock
everything out
when you've done the design of thinking
up front there really isn't much need to
the refactoring step
whereas if i use an approach which says
i'm going to do refactoring um and i'm
going to do refactoring
up and down green and in green what i'm
doing is writing sinful code
i am cutting and pasting from stack
overflow i'm writing a huge transaction
script
i'm understanding the algorithm so that
my tests go green
and it's in the refactoring step that i
produce the structure and the design
and so really in refactoring
[Music]
we remember that we say i can basically
change the implementation details
without changing the observable behavior
and therefore i don't need to write
new tests right that's the key goal of
refactoring
right you can say i can go and change
the implementation details that's safe
to do
because the tests will preserve the
behavior for me and if i break the
behavior
tests will for warming and that's
exactly the same
in the tdd cycle of red grain refactor
that's not something that occurs
post tdd in tdd you're doing exactly the
same thing you're changing the
implementation details but the tests
tell you
it's fine you haven't broken the
contract
you still behave the way the contract
expects right
and i can't do that if any changes might
my internal structure would involve me
rewriting the test
so this notion that i've coupled my
tests
deeply into my implementation details
can't work with refactoring it limits
refactoring
it it truncates the the tdd life cycle
from regular refactor to red and green
and it provides a maintenance headache
for you because you start trying to
change your code and your tests keep
breaking
and ken's been you know talking about
this recently making the observation
that if a
program's behavior is stable from an
observer's perspective no test should
change in other words
if i'm changing the implementation but
the behavior
that i'm expressing is the same then i
shouldn't have to change any tests
and the thing important thing to
understand about tdd is is a kind of
contract first approach to design of our
api
okay right api really i just mean
exports from a module
however we want to define a module in
our use case be that something explicit
like a python
module exports or be that something like
uh access modifiers being public
in um something like dotnet
right um but what we're saying is the
contract
is what we're actually exploring with
tdd it's a way of doing that contract
first approach of saying hey
i want to create a usable contract to
express this behavior
and i want to check my implementation of
it right afterwards
and so if i change the implementation
without changing that contract
if i support refactoring then i don't
need to change
tests
and can also talk about this only you
know 2019
ken was making the same point again
right
he's saying test should be coupled to
the behavior of code and decouple from
the structure of the code
seeing tests that fell in both counts
right so our tests coupled to the
contract that we have under development
they don't couple to the implementation
they don't use things like mocks heavily
and kent's statement of personal style
which he made in an interview with
martin fowler and dhh
was to say that he doesn't go very far
down the mock path his test is
completely coupled to the implementation
interface if you do that right so you
don't use
mocks to isolate the sut you're not
using a unit testing approach
okay um you don't want to observe the
indirect
outputs
and a part the problem here is that the
key idea in unit testing is that
failure of a unit test implicates
one-on-one only unit and that is if you
like
the driving force that basically the
method the class the module or the
package or whatever you have
you owe the failure must direct you
towards the failing limit
but in test driven development
where we work with what we call
programmer or developer tests
the goal is that failure only implicates
the most
recent edit
so the idea is when i write a test and i
go and effectively make
some changes to my code if existing
tests fail
then i know that essentially that most
recent edit is the source of that
problem
and that's how i get defect localization
it is defect localization based on the
most recent change that i made to the
code
and that's fundamentally those two lines
are what test driven development is
we can there's an overall definition if
you go to the c2 wiki this definition
which deals a lot with the kind of ideas
that came out of the xp community in
agile and you can find some very useful
references on there
it has a very good definition of what
test driven development
actually is right so test driven
development produces developer tests
and sometimes we call them programmer
tests and really i think as a community
we should get used to using that name
over unit tests because unit tests have
all this baggage about unit testing with
the client
so in test different development i'm
producing developer or
programmer tests
and it's a process of discovery it's
where essentially i
keep writing new tests and i then add
more implementation details and that
most recent edit is effectively the
thing that's in flux
and as a result of that i will figure
out whether or not basically i have chat
i've broken my code and what i can then
do is make a decision
i can either and this is one of the one
the kind of real you know
hardcore xp community would advocate is
i revert that change when i see it break
things and try again
whatever i was doing there isn't the
right approach it will break existing
behaviors
or you know and i tend to be pragmatic
and do this but spin up that debugger
right
people don't like that because it slows
you down it breaks your focus and your
concentration but
in many cases it's just a simple
obstacle mistake that i can move and i
would move on from debugger if that
doesn't quickly tell me what's going on
in some cases just you just know you see
that you see things go red and you know
right
and we don't use mock objects to isolate
the class under test
right and it's not really colossal we'll
come to that in a minute
but i don't use mock objects
now there is a place for a mock and
that's that essentially we want to be
able to run tests
quickly and as a result of that we want
to better run them in parallel
to run them in parallel there are
certain constraints
one of them is that we don't want to
have essentially what we call a shared
fixture
so a shared fixture is anything where
two tests are
talking to some kind of state like a
database or the file system or something
that's basically static
where essentially the running of one
test could
input the results from another test and
those are things that we want to
essentially
replace with a mock so we talk about
isolation in tdd
we talk about isolating one test from
another
not talk about isolating one thing under
test from another
and the purpose of mocking as described
originally in kind of kent's tdd book
was to solve that problem
of hey i have this thing that
essentially is shared state
and that's going to be a problem for my
tests because i effectively have to make
sure that they don't interfere with each
other
usually that's between that's i o and we
also find
that if we tend to basically replace our
i o
in our testing it solves a couple of
other problems that we may want to
basically use a mock for
speed if i'm talking to something that's
i o like for example a third party
service
or essentially a database will tend to
slow my test down
we want fast feedback right i want the
developer to be able to essentially
almost seamlessly
you know finish writing their
implementation these are their tests hit
test and they can see the results
i don't want to break their their rhythm
right and fragility
quite often when i talk to io it may
fail for network reasons
like the tests are much more fragile so
again i may want to essentially replace
with a mock there
but the reasons for using mocking are
isolation
speed or fragility it's not to do with
basically isolating the sut
that's not the purpose of tdd we're
writing developer and programmer tests
we are not doing unit testing
okay next fallacy i want to talk about
is that the trigger for a new test is a
new function
um and this is this kind of idea that
whenever i want to write a function
uh and i i should need to have a new
test first
and journalist is predicated on the idea
that a function has a set of
preconditions
things that are true beforehand we
exercise the function then we can test a
set of post conditions things that are
true afterwards
okay and the idea then within this kind
of model of tdd
would be to say well that's great
because essentially i can use my setup
to basically set up the preconditions i
run my code and i've got a set of
post conditions and great i've got
testing around my functions
the only slight problem for us is if
i've got this thing that's very granular
what kind of checks the actual overall
behavior i've got these parts
but where does the whole come from um
and that
leads us to really in getting into what
the world of acceptance testing
all right we'll talk a little bit about
that in a second
um and testing becomes basically this
idea of confirming the functions that we
have
and at least ideas like parameterized
testing where we're saying well really
i need to test my function on the whole
range of possible conditions
and then this glider acceptance testing
and really we're moving a bit away from
tdd there
we're getting much more into the idea of
testing and how i think about regression
right okay
um and these uh these ideas like
acceptance testing that creep in
uh the tdd have a sense as an idea of i
need to have an acceptance testing
framework cause us all sorts of problems
and we'll discuss those in more depth
later
the other thing i note about this style
usually is that my experience is that
when i return to my tests
i find it difficult to understand them
right
it may have gone red when i go and look
at the tests that have gone red
in this kind of style i'm like well okay
the test is now
red because the post conditions are
failing on the preconditions
but is that because the behaviors
changed
and actually i need to fix this uh test
because its post conditions have changed
or is this that the post conditions
remain
true and therefore i've got a bug
and part of the problem here is intent
there was this dream that we had that we
wouldn't need to write documentation
anymore
because test-driven development would
give us external specifications
i better go and look at my tests they'd
be clear examples of how i use my code
and the developer could just go and read
my tests and go great i know how to use
this
uh this code this this framework or this
library all this code completely
correctly
um from looking at the tests and that
kind of gets mocked
now you'll see out on you know and the
twitter rt mocking the side direction
for specifications hahaha that didn't
really work out right
but the answer really is that they're
doing tdd all wrong that's why
we don't have that because this glit
unit of granularity tells me nothing
i i can't contextually understand what
this is for
so the principle we want to look at is
that the trigger for a new test
is a new behavior
so when i look at kemp's book tdd by
example this is a typical
example of the kind of thing that ken
is showing you writing a test against we
need to be able to add amounts
in two different currencies and convert
the result given a set of exchange rates
okay and if i read that with a more
modern kind of like perspective i could
say
okay given that i have a set of exchange
rates
when we add amounts in two different
currencies then we convert the result
and many of you when you look at that
hopefully we'll go hey i
recognize that isn't that this kind of
give and when then approach
right um that bdd advocates basically
recommend
and it's true right even at the point of
tdd by example
what we're actually being asked to write
is given when
then statements about behavior that we
want to see express that's what tdd is
focused on in the examples that were
given
originally so i could i can demonstrate
it like this given i have a set of
exchange rates
when i add two amounts and different
currencies together then i get results
in the first currency just rephrasing of
exactly what kent wrote written
right given the take of the world before
the test when i exercise the behavior
under test
then we expect the following changes
and you can switch that in different
ways in your code right you could use
some front expressions that directly
but to honestly people like gerald
massaros have talked about basically the
fact that
the four-fold test model you know your
setup if your code is your given
your actual method that does the
exercising the test is your when
and then your assert statements are
where you verify uh essentially
the the then statement then you've got
to tear down model afterwards
and actor ranger cert from bill wake is
really expressing the same thing
but they're all trying to express the
same thing this given when then model
and even back in you know junit with
this four-fold test model
we were trying to express the same way
right
so really we are focused very much on
behavior
and that's i think what led dan early on
in the history of test-driven
development
to make this statement about hey a
behavior-driven development is a better
name for this right
because this idea that basically tdd was
a technique for testing
which leads us down this path of unit
tests
integration tests system tests mocks
is not really correct tdd is a technique
for contract first exploration of
behavior
and so that's why really dan came up
with this idea that behavior-driven
development would be a better name
because it shifts your focus from tests
to behaviors which is really what
kent was trying to get up get at in that
given went then statement that he wrote
he just didn't call it given when then
right
so later bd becomes quite different
thing i'm not really advocating that you
still start embracing bdd
um you know that's a different kind of
platform i mean i'm really recommending
you do tdd right
and that bdd in its original kind of
assertion
was actually effectively tdd done right
and so we can look at how we should be
doing in this way more
right the next test that you write is
the most
obvious step and this is the fundamental
process
right of tdd i say i need to write a new
test
what's my new test gonna do right it's
gonna be the next most obvious step i
could make
right the smallest change towards
essentially getting towards the
acceptance criteria
for the behavior that i'm trying to
basically express here
and the behavior that we're trying to
express
tends to be acceptance criteria on a
user story or use case whatever it is
that you're using
um to implement so essentially you know
in my life cycle
i've got some agile process it's
creating user stories or use cases
my product owner nowadays effectively
customer will sit down and give me a set
of acceptance criteria
those acceptance criteria may be phrased
there's something like given when thens
and say you know given this state when i
do this then i do that
the next test i write is the next
smallest
change that i can make to basically
implement
that required behavior and that may
involve me writing
a a new method on a class it may involve
me writing
two or three classes that are
collaborating to exhibit that behavior
right but it's the smallest possible
change that i can make
often that's a function because that's
the smallest thing but it may not always
be
right so don't think about the artifact
of hey i watch people and they seem to
be adding functions
think about what they are doing what
they're doing is making the next
smallest change they can make
hence why we get when you see people
practicing tdd you get this idea of
saying you know fake until you make it
i'm going to return null
i'm going to return zero i'm hard coding
my values and you're a bit like well why
would you do that
because that's the smallest change i can
make to get that test passing
and it may push me to add new tests
to explore the criteria in more depth
that does read the question right hang
on a minute if it's my tdd
that's essentially if i'm driving my
test driven development practice
by looking at behaviors looking at these
given when thens what is the acceptance
testing stuff
for and again we'll return to that
the other thing that's used worth noting
is when i get to the red when i'm
practicing red grain refactor in my
green step i have written sinful code
i've cut and paste and stack overflow
and i've put that in to get the
algorithm working
because my goal is to understand the
algorithmic solution of the problem as
fast as possible
when i get to refactoring i'm going to
write clean code i'm going to improve
the quality of the code
and that may mean i say you know i'm
going to take this section of the code
in the green and i'm going to break it
out and make a new class
that's an implementation detail it's not
part of my
observable behavior of my contract
meeting acceptance criteria
it would be in a module it wouldn't be
exported if you're using access
modifiers like public private urban
private
and i don't need to write new tests for
those right
refactoring step items are not part of
my observable behavior they're an
implementation detail
i can change them when i refactor
something therefore i shouldn't couple
tests to them
because tests will make my code more
more rigid
because i have to keep changing all the
tests in order to change those details
right so i don't couple the tests the
details
i say hey that's okay that's hidden
that's a private it's not exported
it's fine you know there's no need for
you to basically have tests for that
we know that we have coverage of it
because refactoring shouldn't be letting
us
introduce something because it's a
series of safe moves
that essentially creates untested paths
the original test tests this code oh
it's not a refactoring move right i'm
just doing a whole scale rewrite that's
doing a refactoring move
i may introduce new paths right and it's
always worth having code coverage tools
to check
i haven't introduced new paths etcetera
but you don't need
to write tests for every single thing
you create right if you
if you sit there thinking how do i test
my private methods you don't
okay um yeah and this is just saying to
effectively you know
make sure you remember that in order if
you're not getting a true red green
refractor life cycle
if you're not getting to the point where
you really feel the need to do
refactoring
then um uh you're probably because
you're doing too much
design up front and your tests know too
much about implementation details
so you mentioned this a couple of times
now it's time to kind of address this
there's this fallacy that customers
should write acceptance tests
so what was going on here um uh customer
tests
sometimes called originally function uh
uh functional tests
the idea was we wanted to test basically
the functionality of the user story
and the key goal here was that we had
some notion that the
xp used to call an on-site customer now
i really tend to get that as being the
product owner
someone who was basically whose
expectations around domain was asking
basically for the things the domain
needed okay
and the idea here was that that customer
would write the tests they would go and
write tests but because they were often
not a developer
we provide them with some kind of dsl
early days things like
fit which basically used a table driven
approach so i could go and put
values in a table which is very easy i
think perhaps easing the dsl in many
cases
right um they could go and write those
and then effectively we would then
automate them to prove that they worked
but there's a problem with this right
and the problem effectively is that it
requires quite a lot of work from us
writing effectively these dsl based
uh acceptance tests requires developers
to be able to
have a toolkit that parses the specif
takes those parameters figures out how
to use that to drive stuff
we tend to end up with this if this dsl
is chaotic
um we need to basically tell the user
hey this language
you need to basically constrain yourself
to talking in these terms in dsl
which feels an awful lot like i'm asking
you to write it in a programming
language
and we said the problem is you weren't a
programmer right a lot of effort
and find my tdd if i'm now saying hey
i'm doing developer and programmer tests
i'm writing contract first essentially
i'm using the test to explore that
contract and the contract i'm exploring
is the behaviors of my system as given
by these given when then
use cases if that's tdd and i can have
multiple classes under test in that
if that's tdd what what is this
giving me an addition now james shaw
let's talk about his experiences james
shaw was one of the authors
of fit right so he's got skin in the
game james essentially built
one of these early acceptance testing
tools
and he began to stop he stopped using it
and the question is well why did james
stop using it right one of james one of
the authors of fit you've invested time
and effort in building these tools
why did james want to stop using that
and his key problem was that customers
don't participate
there's this idea that we're writing a
customer test
right um but the customers don't often
don't write it
if what you find is that you're the
person as a developer sitting there with
your
um cucumber based tool or whatever
effectively etcetera or your foot based
tool
and you're the one writing the tests in
the dsl
what have you actually gained that was
supposed to be your product owner
writing those
do they even view them do you sit down
with them and you sir and they say oh
great
um fantastic i've really been looking
forward to the end of the iteration
so i can sit down with you and we can
read through the
um cucumber tests together uh and uh
i'll get lots of value from that in
seeing you
make them go green and i'll know that
the behavior i wanted is
available look at the ui no i don't want
to do that
i i really want to focus on this dsl you
built for me
um that doesn't really happen never
right i think i've managed to force
people to do that by literally we're
strapping them to a chair
um but it doesn't really ever happen and
they have enormous
cost right there's a whole semantic
dissonance for the developer who's
forced to switch between a tool written
kind of in their own language
that they're using to do development in
which is one of the key goals
effectively behind test driven
development your
x unit testing framework should be in
the same language you're writing it so
you don't have the context switch
but i've got a context switch here over
to the dsl i've often got to define
basically you know what is this domain
specific language that i'm needing at
this point
right hugely expensive and doesn't
really give you any value
and the problem i think is that attd has
come to exist
because when we've created a notion of
unit testing as being our test first
practice
what we've ended up with is these small
tiny chunks
that we are testing around so we're
forced into the position
of needing something like hdd to check
the behavior
but if tdd is being driven from the
acceptance criteria
which we've established is the original
intent we can rewrite those clear
statements of basically what are we
testing this behavior as a given when
then clause
then we don't really need atd because
the tdd has already done that
ken originally you know talked about
http and tdg by example and he said i
think it's problematic because the
length of the cycle
is too long and because many of these
tests
can't go green until all the subparts
are written
they express they spend much of their
time read
if they get spend much of their time
read developers tend to ignore them
all those tests are red yeah that might
be somebody else working on something
that's not complete yet
and at the end of the iteration we go oh
we've got to make it all go green
we crunch we're not agile anymore we're
not we're effectively crunching a tiny
little waterfall process where
effectively we
fix these all up at the end of the
iteration
so what's the principle here the
principle is that customers
product earners if you like simply
specify the acceptance criteria those
given when then clauses
right and james talks about this talks
about basically what his new practices
he was asked by stevo
if you don't use fit anymore james what
do you do and he essentially said well
i want the customers to illustrate with
examples and the developers will simply
use the examples directly in their tests
the examples are a guide for them how to
write these tests right
and if we think about that that's the
model we're proposing for test driven
development right
we've got these given when then
statements and i'm using those
to write the next test i'm using those
to say what's the smallest change
i can get towards completing that
requirement okay
so we're not necessarily directly coding
the given when then in and the
frameworks that do that are a little bit
problematic because they force you into
this model of
actually focusing on the given when then
rather than the contract
of the api under test so i would tend to
always favor x unit over that nowadays i
went down that route and it's painful it
hides the api
so they're a guide to us writing the
test right the next smallest thing
but what they will give us a lot more
is this idea of documenting a
self-documenting code
because now our tests are focused on
saying hey
um here's how you call the code to get
this behavior
here's how you call the code to get this
behavior you say you get the code and
you can determine that when i've called
the code this behavior
this is what the results should be and
suddenly our tests become much more
comprehensible
i can now look at my tests and
understand when it's read
what behavior have i broken
okay great we were changing that
behavior that's fine i need to change
the test
wow that behavior is really important i
don't want to break that
i've done something wrong it's in that
last edit that i made
um hey am i going to revert it or am i
going to try and debug through that
you know i think that length is pretty
close it's probably a silly mistake
let's debug for five minutes and then
figure out whether that's wrong
right that's the cycle of tdd not let's
go over and write some tests in cucumber
and then figure out basically lower down
in our when we write these tests which
are basically mocked
mocked out completely around these
individual functions
that essentially may be the behavior is
incorrect and that whole design needs to
be changed when we get to the end of the
process
right the whole process of doing atgd
locks you into a waterfall development
model
okay the next fashion i want to look at
is it doesn't matter if you test first
the test glass the coverage is the same
right we still got we've still got test
coverage and in fact you see people
saying hey we've done some analysis
we looked at the data around the test
coverage people who did test first and
test last
and it turns out it's the same so it
doesn't really matter whether you do
test last
it's just as good right
okay so what is this test last well
tesla
says what i'm going to do is i'm going
to go and write
some tests for the corresponding units
after i've finished working on
it's explicitly a unit testing process
it says effectively i've already got the
code it's got units i'm going to test
them
and then maybe i'm going to write some
integration tests right
and often i think it's the prevalence of
test after
in people's approaches towards doing
development
that has essentially really pushed
forward this kind of mockest approach
it's not even really knee driven
development that's got us there okay
and we have to do a lot of thinking up
front in this model
right we have to explicitly make all of
our design decisions
before we get feedback on them from our
tests
so we lengthen the time between making a
design decision
and getting feedback on that design
decision we throw agile out the window
and we say you know what i just want to
write code and test it after i love
waterfall that's me all over okay
we don't want that approach really do we
right we want to be much more agile
and that's the problem we've created a
really long feedback loop for ourselves
my experience is that essentially this
tends to lead to the problem
of us writing lots of speculative code
code that's not actually
governed by any given requirement it
makes it difficult for us to know when
we are done and it often leads to rework
because when we get to the end and we
look at this behavior expressed by the
hdd statement
we find that we didn't implement the
right thing and then we tend to get into
this horrible world where we
have to spend a lot of time and effort
on that code maybe i can kind of hack it
to make
it work with the acceptance criteria and
so we end up with poorly designed code
because we designed our code ahead of
understanding what we were designing
for right and often we're making
speculative judgments about what we
think we necessary
and it turns out we don't need to do
that or understanding it was bad enough
that they cost
we have to rework the whole thing
so we need to stop engaging in this
waterfall style process and calling it
tdd because it's not
right um tdd is a process effectively a
contract first exploration of behaviors
of the system
where we say what's my behavior what's
the smallest thing i could do towards
implementing that behavior
let's effectively do get that to pass
green by
figuring out what the algorithm is now
let's do redesign
around a provable requirement that we
have
that i need to implement
yeah so our principle is only write
production code in response to a test
only write production code responsible
to a test means we
can't write speculative code right the
only
code we've got here is the code that
makes that test passed
and the green phase tends to mean we're
just we're not writing tons of code oh
maybe this is how
how i'll implement it we're just doing
enough to get that to pass as quickly as
possible
we get to refactoring step we're only
refactoring code
that exists because its purpose is to
satisfy given requirements
right i don't have good enough
requirements
to be able to write that next test take
that next step
towards basically implementation and the
problem is about
our requirements it's a prompt for a
conversation with the customer i don't
really understand what it is that i'm
writing
what is what is the acceptance criteria
looking for
and when i do this i don't really know
what the results should look like
um can you tell me about this edge case
that seems to be to be a problem that i
can't understand right there's a back
and forth dialogue about the
requirements
and it's dialogue right i don't have to
get them to sit down and write that
i'd have to say to them hey i'd like to
know how this works can you go and write
that dsl into cucumber for me explain
that i'll be waiting
right i just talk to them and say hey
how does this supposed to work
what we're looking at basically you're
saying what is the contract we need to
express this behavior
there are two things you're doing with a
test first development approach
you are designing as you go right
you are saying here is the i'm exploring
the contract i need to satisfy this
behavior
and as you go you explore that
requirement
and you are you doing scope control you
are saying i
only want to write enough code to meet
that requirement
two goals scope control and design
right neither of those are things that
test after gives you test after will not
give you scope control
because you have all you have you are
right you've already made your design
in advance of the testing with the
acceptance criteria so you've already
committed the sinner creating
speculative functionality
right and it won't give you feedback on
your design
step by step you've already made your
design you're getting your feedback a
long time later
you're not saying what's the smallest
design increment i could make and
what with quick feedback on it
so test after fails as a process that
controls design
that moves our design forward and it
fails basically as a process that does
scope control for us
it is not the same and the fact that we
get similar amounts of test coverage
is irrelevant to our assessment so if
you see people you know writing a white
paper and saying i look to the two
and i get the same amount of text
coverage they've kind of missed a point
that they're testing for the wrong thing
and they will always therefore get the
wrong result
next fact is you want 100 test coverage
of your code this is an interesting
fallacy because
i'm going to talk about something kent
said which is basically tdd followed
religiously should result in 100
statement coverage
right so am i denying what kent said
same thing as i don't think the tdd by
example book tells you we need to know
about tdd
right well really all we're saying at
this point is if my process
is essentially to never write code
speculatively but only write it in
response to a requirement
then effectively i will always end up
with 100 code coverage
right because i say okay i've got a
requirement here's the next smaller step
i can move towards that
here's the implementation for that in
green and when i refactor i'm just
changing the structure of my series of
safe moves
that don't introduce new paths etc and
therefore effectively it's covered by
the original test
so in principle i couldn't ever not get
a hundred percent
right how have i written this code that
isn't
isn't covered by my test okay
and it's only really something like test
after that would introduce this problem
i've speculatively created lots of code
when i come to basically implementation
step
because really i effectively i've done
my design in my head beforehand
um i wasn't doing proper red green
refactoring cycle right
or an accident where effectively when
you do your refactoring you don't get it
right and you introduce a new path or a
branch
right
but so why do we even if we're doing
proper test driven development
even if we are actually a test first
team why might i set a fallacy that you
have 100
uh code and the answer is that actually
i don't believe that all of your code
should be tested by a test driven
development approach
right we'll focus on what tdd is
which essentially is this idea of saying
effectively it's developer tests
we write those developer tests in
response to basically implementing the
next smallest change i can make towards
implementing a given behavior that the
customer wants in the system
and i may say that there are areas of
the system that doesn't make so much
sense for me to do that right
and so what i may focus on initially
rather than 100
test code i'll come back to what those
areas are in a second um
is when i do refactoring the most useful
way to look at coverage is to say
hey before this refactoring what is my
coverage percentage
after this refactoring is it still the
same if it's
not then i've probably introduced
some uh untested code branches
all right
so this leads to this principle not all
codes be driven by tdd
the purpose of tdd is to provide you
fast binary feedback
on a design that you are creating in
order to satisfy customer requirements
if it's not the fastest way to get
useful feedback
and do the other thing that is
all right so some suggestions
i would avoid test driving visual output
because probably what's happened is a ux
designer has given you
the design so i'm not doing exploration
of the design of this
i am just implementing that design right
it is often fragile and is often slow
and it's often not binary in terms of
the feedback
that may be a more suitable place for me
to think about a
test after strategy for regression
and the quickest way to get feedback
basically to run my code and look at the
ui that i'm creating
and ex do exploratory testing on it
if i'm spiking something or i've got
some kind of throwaway code
there's no need for tests around that
right the spike is getting me feedback
it says
i don't know how to do something and i
want to get feedback on it
hey i've got this new um sdk that i need
to understand
how am i going to understand it oh i'll
just spike it right now some folks find
it helpful to basically approach those
by using some kind of x unit tool etc
and that's fine go
go for it that's your preference but
don't do test driven development for a
spot
right um integration
right so what do you mean my integration
in this context
if i have some mocks that i'll provide
me with basically support for
isolated test fast test and uh
avoid fragile tests so generally around
io issues
whereas essentially i will find that
that basically is difficult
then maybe i want to test those after
because i tend to find that i'm just
implementing a given specification that
already exists hey how do you do this or
you just fill in these parameters and do
this thing and then basically that just
works
in this sdk our framework i'm not
exploring that design in any way really
i'm just doing it
and in that case maybe test alpha is
just as good i'm testing essentially
that really i
hook up to that integration okay maybe
even running it
is actually just as good and i may
really only need the regression to say
hey don't break that now
okay and don't ever do basically tdd
around third party code it's not yours
all right and so that means you won't
necessarily get to 100
and that's fine because really we're
talking about a test pyramid
right what we have in the test
parameters we say the further up the
pyramid you are the longer the time to
feedback
the more it costs us to write down the
more fragile those tests are
so we want to focus a lot of our effort
down the bottom where i get the fastest
feedback
on the work that i've done it's the
lowest cost to do that
it's the clearest form of feedback
because it's binary it's red or green
and it's the least fragile as i go up
the scale
it may essentially get harder but
don't write a test using x unit if it's
going to give you longer time to
feedback
can be more effort and more fragile than
doing one of the other things in the
pyramid
okay if the the fastest way to feedback
with the lowest effort and fragility is
to put the software in front of a
customer do that
right we're focused on agile in
shortening the feedback loop and tdd is
a way of
shortening the feedback loop as you make
design decisions
about the api that you are building in
order to implement
a given customer's requirement expressed
by behavior
and if that's not the quickest way to
get that feedback
do something else right it's a practice
that is a tool that you can use that
will help you in the right context
use it in the wrong context and it
becomes a burden
right okay
as we kind of try and close out i just
want to talk a little bit about clean
architecture i don't it's not a whole
talk on clean architecture i do that
separately
um when we talk about therefore tdd and
we're saying
hey you know i want to think about
basically
mocks for isolating my tests from each
other
for making sure that basically they run
fast and making sure they're not fragile
but i think in that i o out is there a
good way of supporting that i'm really
clean architecture we're supporting that
so clean architecture is an idea of the
synthesis of a number of existing ideas
um portsmouth adapters architecture
sometimes called hexagonal architecture
um onion um boundaries controls and
entities from jakobson
and i think there are quite a few other
examples in a sense it's a pattern
that's been rediscovered with continuing
right
and really it's just a layering strategy
okay
so in layering such as just a ways of
organizing our modules
so that we have like things in the same
layer we can prevent things like cyclic
dependencies
so in the center we have modules that
deal with entities or domain
right so our domain is in the center and
entities are things where you have
state plus behavior that effectively is
coupled to that state otherwise we're
tempting
as a class an object-oriented world
right around that we have application
workflow which tends to encapsulate our
use cases
right so typically you might implement
this by something like the command pane
etc where you say effectively
take the following entities do this work
with them and then basically give me a
result back
and then we have outside that the kind
of frameworks which are allowing us to
interact with the outside world with
databases
with um uh http with messaging right
often third-party oss libraries that
we're using and beyond that we have
essentially the actual devices
themselves the web
uh you know the actual database etc and
the key thing to understand about this
model is
it depends inwards model what we mean by
that is things in the outer layers can
depend on things on the inner layers but
you can't
you can't depend back outwards what does
that mean in practice it means that the
entity layer
is a clean poco layer it has no
reference to
anything i o based and that makes it
very easy for us to avoid those i o
concerns being significant in tests okay
so this is a kind of like different way
look in that same diagram i've got some
delivery mechanism
it comes to a boundary layer which
generally that's basically an sdk like
so
if you're writing a web application
that's your kind of your controller
i took some kind of interactor service
layer command something like that
effects
etcetera which talks to my entities i
shouldn't talk to entities directly from
the boundary layer
right and that interrupts myself go and
do stuff like go and talk to entity
gateway so in other words go and talk to
something
data storage to go and get mentors out
from me right because essentially i
don't talk to my entities directly from
my boundary
um then essentially i may need this
request and response model
dtos if you like right okay
when we use this kind of approach what
it means is we tend to want to focus a
lot of our test driven development
against these use cases there
okay that's where the behaviors are
expressed
that's where essentially we say hey i've
got this user story
which is really a lightweight music use
case and it wants to do
this thing that has this acceptance
criteria that lives at that use case
layer
so that's where i write my tests
sometimes um it's worth thinking about
x units just another adapter it's
another way of driving my tests in the
same way that i might get an http
request
in and drive that use case from my
controller
actually just another way of me doing
the same thing right
you might drop all the way down and
avoid use cases
and test the actual entities themselves
because you need more granularity in
what you're observing right
and this is really what's at the heart
of what kent calls
gears in tdd by example this idea that
most of the time i'm driving along the
fourth or fifth of the use case layer
but sometimes i want to drop down to the
entity layer below
because the going gets a bit sticky so i
drop down to first a second
right and then essentially i can
navigate to the entity layer and then
kind of come back up
so that model is a bit like this i've
got some x unit framework which drives
my test
right which has my my setup my exercise
and my teardown inside it right
i established my request model in my
setup okay what are all the variables
that i need to essentially drive this
test with
i then pass them to whatever effectively
is helping me deal with the entities
if i've not done the lower level so i
call my use case
it exercises my entities which may well
effectively emerge from refactoring
of my actual use case right and then it
returns to me some values back
the response model which i can then
check with my assertions
and we may as part of that test need to
essentially consider how it's going to
interact with io
this entity gateway and that's the area
where i may choose to use a mock
we don't td against other adapters right
generally speaking
x unit and it at the same level i don't
want to step up the
up up one level to drive those i don't
want to drive my controllers
really with the x unit you're better off
making sure those work by simply having
some kind of script that drives an
end-to-end test
that essentially says you know what if i
go through the controller i can check
basically everything's hooked up
together because that's mostly what
you're doing
you're checking that the http or
whatever gets turned into the correct
call to your use case layer and that
will usually be sufficient and give you
the fast feedback that you need
to determine that you put everything up
watch us are grounding the tests at that
point
they make you feel good but it probably
doesn't actually give you any useful
feedback
and that can be as simple as basically
you know curl and basically jq driven
from a bash script to be honest with
okay so let's review but come to the
come to the end let's review them what
we think the fallacies and the
principles are
developers write unit tests
is a fallacy right developers don't like
unit tests
right developer tests the trigger for a
new test is a new function
second fallacy the trigger is
effectively the next smallest step i can
make towards augmented behavior
customers write acceptance tests no
customers defined acceptance criteria
and our tdd
expresses those behaviors it doesn't
matter if you test first or test last it
does
um you want scope and design control and
you want 100 test coverage of your code
now you want to use
tdd because you where it gives you the
fastest feedback on your design
decisions
and you want to make sure that in your
refactoring step you don't effectively
introduce new paths that are untested
currently
the developers write developer tests a
trigger friend tested in new behavior
customers write acceptance criteria only
write production code in response to a
test
and not all of your codes were driven by
tdd
great and thank you very much
great stuff thank you ian if you'd like
to
stop sharing
and you're back in the room thank you
very much for that that was uh that was
excellent
some really interesting stuff in there
uh we have i think two minutes for
questions and we have a couple of
questions come up in slido
um so the top voted question we got is
how do you approach unit testing when
you're testing a class with numerous
dependencies
without mocking and does this allow for
testing code in isolation
okay so the first thing i'd say is why
do i have much dependence dependencies
right so really the only reason i want
to inject a dependency would be a design
decision that i've got something that
run time that varies right so that's
kind of notion of open close principle
i want to inject this theme because i
may have different expressions of
it my class is very consistent it has
kind of this engine but you give me a
policy and i'm going to
keep different policies right and that
is essentially something that i should
be checking
um by really just saying hey you know i
want to basically express this
criteria that i've got different
policies i can apply and i want to see
the outcome
in my contract the other option could be
that effectively i want to inject it
because i've got some kind of slow
operation like io etc and in that case
effectively i may well have a wrap
around it that i can kind of mock out
but otherwise i'd question why i have so
many dependencies in the first place
that feels like it's a speculative
design decision
and not one that effectively has been
made by a classic term tdp approach
right just legacy code then try and
effectively figure out whether you can
write proper
tdd style tests uh eventually and just
doing you
in the constructor for many of those
dependencies right um
you know new is really underrated use
new more is what i'd say
great stuff uh nice simple one is there
a blog for your presentation uh
yes i think a lot of stuff in there is
is code better dot com slash ian cooper
we put a link to that in the chat
any other quick resources you want to
point people to for that
no no i mean no not really i i probably
should uh do a new set of blog posts now
i've done these kind of fallacies and
principles and i probably may try and do
that at some point
um the other thing really though i'd
always recommend just go and read kent's
book tdd by example
particularly if you've been practicing
ttd for a while
um ken have been practicing tdd for
probably i think about 10 years or so
when you wrote that book
and it really is a book for experienced
practitioners to understand like a
masterclass it's what probably not a
great introduction he gets down voted a
lot on amazon for that
but if you've been practicing tdd for a
while go and read it and be amazed at
what kent knew about tdd
when he wrote that book right um
it's it's one that expresses clearly he
had a lot of experience at time of
voting
excellent and uh last question uh
there's a couple more which i'm sure you
can follow up on twitter
last one we have time for by mocking out
io asks jimbo
is there a chance that a fundamental
area is not being tested with a fast
feedback loop
is this uh supposedly covered by
end-to-end tests
yeah i mean in theory entrance has to
cover that look if if it's really a
concern
you have to figure out what's the what's
the fastest way to get feedback
on that area of concern right is
basically the fastest way to get
feedback writing a
test off to test around that specific
area so we look at say brighter we have
unit tests around kind of most of the
core engine
when we talk about transports there's
that messaging middleware
they're quite often test after tests
which are just confirming that behavior
they run slow
we don't run them all the time we tend
to run the basis part by ci cicd process
but they're very much test after kind of
approaches that's why i say use
different approaches to different things
great stuff
okay thank you very much uh thank you
for being part of it
uh we are now gonna press all the magic
buttons on the stream and
things are going to happen and people
are going to appear i believe joining us
now
we should have uh boris from synopsis
will be on the call any second
let me just check a couple of these
details here that's fine that's fine
and uh we have boris are you there
remove that remove that uh the process
of running a hey how are you sorry
um i missed to hit the mute button
the process of running a stream like
this has been likened to
um you are entertaining a bunch of
people who are sat in their seats
watching like a one-person show
and they're not allowed to realize that
you're also flying the plane and they're
on a plane
so you're simultaneously you know
engaging with the audience and talking
with the guests and everything and
clicking all the buttons and making sure
nothing goes wrong anyway yes
hey boris how are you and welcome to ndc
manchester
yeah thank you very much i'm happy to be
here
and thank you to uh so some boris is
from synopsis who are one of our
partners the people who help make all of
this possible
and mean we can give it all away on the
internet to all of you watching for free
uh boris tell us a little bit more about
a synopsis what are you doing at the
moment that
that's exciting yeah so i'm the senior
sales engineer from synopsis
and i often get the question what does
synopsis do
and i usually answer that we amongst
other things help
software companies also to develop
secure high quality software
fast what does this mean well as we all
know
effective application security is not
all about just installing
tools it's about ensuring that people
processes
and technology and all are aligned to
address security risks at all stages
of the application life cycle and
synopsis
offers the most comprehensive solution
portfolio for building
integrity security and quality into your
sdlc and the supply chain
and therefore we offer solutions that
help you manage security and quality
risks comprehensively
across your organization throughout the
application
life cycle now i know that this is a
little bit marketing
but to say it simply uh the shift left
has been a theme for several years now
right there we help the developers lift
the weight of the secure development of
their shoulders
however by combining the benefits of
developers with the security and legal
personnel also
we evolved into the shift everywhere
concept and created an ecosystem
that helps companies to develop secure
high quality software fast
but don't let me keep you away from the
granite content
on the manchester just be sure
please visit our sponsorship page and
enter our competition
to win a pair of airpods pros
fantastic thank you boris so yeah
synopsis that's synopsis with two wise
s-y-n-o-p-o-s-y-s
like synopsis plus systems kind of mesh
together i believe is is
where it came from well it has its
meaning
so yeah check them out uh they got a
booth over at expo.ndcmanchester.com
so uh head on over there they are giving
away a pair of uh
so we're doing earlier is it airpod pros
or airpods pro
airpods pro airpods pro a pair of
airpods pro to one lucky winner so so
leave your details there
um we'll be drawing that later they'll
be in touch uh thank you very much for
joining us boris thank you again
synopsis for supporting ndc manchester
right i believe that we have joining us
now
live by internet and undersea cable and
satellites and all kinds of
amazing technology uh
we should have here on the line any
second
i will now juggle some buttons first of
all i'm going to switch back to that
so you can see me as i juggle buttons
over here
there we go uh we have martin thwaites
uh let me pin martin hello martin how
are you doing
manchester um where the weather is
manchester weather
and i believe we also have joining us on
the call any second
now uh although currently without video
let's see uh gemma can you hear us
hello hello uh
let's see if we can find your video
gemma there you are
magic guys and a surprise junior
developer joining us for this part of
the stream
so let's push that button look at this
i'm gonna push all the buttons today
fantastic look at that so uh martin
is uh for those of you who've not met
the martin is kind of the reason
nbc manchester exists um he's been
involved in in ndc events for years in
all kinds of ways in london and oslo and
stuff
um and is based in manchester and the
conversation started what was it martin
two years ago now
um i think it's probably about three or
four actually when i was banging down
the door of
um the ndc organizers saying that
manchester is awesome
and um we have an awesome community so
um come and do it up here um
it's taken a while um and obviously
last year we were going to do it live um
but
um circumstances um but uh yeah
um it's been a long road
together but yeah so here we are
virtually and uh next year we will be
there
in person absolutely 100 nothing can
possibly go wrong
um and uh gemma so i first met you gem
in
uh nbc oslo i think two or three years
ago
um and since then we've done a bunch of
events together in and around manchester
and you
were doing and are doing all kinds of
things to do with the the manchester
tech scene and hack manchester tell us a
little bit about about all that
um sorry is that my child taken away the
handover process and
yeah so it was it was really good to
come along to uh ndc oslos um
i was sharing sharing some of my ideas
around
uh turning user stories into comics uh
it was really nice to meet all the all
the
cool people who went on there went on a
nice trip didn't we
on a barge looking for shrimp the shrimp
cruise yeah one of the things
we haven't managed to replicate yeah
unfortunately trying to do a shrimp
sort of cruise around manchester would
involve going on the uh the canal and
getting some uh
getting some trolleys i think wouldn't
it be martin
yeah picking those up uh from yeah not
gonna work
yeah a couple of years ago they tried to
bring in the mo bikes
into uh into manchester and they all
ended up in the canal
um yeah so uh in manchester it was
really nice to have you come and help
compare
um the uh the the hack manchester
awards show so hat manchester is a
25-hour coding competition
and i've got a little ferret running
around in the background um northern
northern af and so yeah we had
we had a 25-hour coding competition
because that's when the clocks go back
oh it was that weekend wasn't it i wrote
because that was the
we did um so jess white and and morton
brockley who are also friends of ddd
they did uh friends of ndc they did a
ddd in nottingham the day before and
then we did a popcorn for nottingham
and it was like a great just all these
kind of events you know tekken
in the uk is often perceived as being
very london-centric
um like you know a lot of things
everything in the uk show business
politics everything tends to congregate
around london
um but it doesn't need to be and there
are these amazing tech communities all
over the country and
yeah that was knotting him on saturday
and then hack manchester happening the
same weekend
uh that was that was quite a by monday a
lot of people were very tired
very very tired that weekend was was
epic
so what's been going on obviously one of
the interesting things about the the
last 12 months is that
um geography in theory doesn't matter as
much as it used to because a lot of
stuff is online
but i'm still seeing a lot of kind of
you know loyalty to regional meetups and
community things
how have you seen that playing out in
terms of what's happening around
manchester and the events that take
place up there
so um so last year about two weeks
before the pandemic um
i went off sick with burnout for about
three months so i was kind of off the
scene and i came back to work three
months and then i went off a maternity
leave as you saw with a little
little tiny human that greeted us before
um so i've not been
going to um to all the events however
uh we're in manchester we've got uh
we've got a couple of really quite
active
uh slack groups so one is the event
organizers which i kind of
look after and there's manchester tech
and so that's still been going
quite strong i think and martin you're
on that one more than me um but with the
tech event organizers we've got
um we've got a calendar events uh kind
of been dipping into and keeping an eye
on what's been going on so xp manchester
has still been meeting up and they've
been they've been doing
still monthly events all online and ruby
northwest ruby user group
actually had jb rainsberger who's over
in the states
come and talk at one of their evening
events not too long ago
python north west has still definitely
been going strong we've got
code and stuff which i think is it's a
really good little group that's
teaching people who are interested in
coding how to code abuse and getting
jobs
uh what else has been going on martin
can you think of anything else
there's there's loads of stuff and i
think the the the difference is within
manchester that it's
such a tight-knit community you know
we've we've got you know there's two
user groups or two
slack groups that we're talking about
there and that's it congregates this
community and
and it's it's very different to that you
know you say london centric
the london tech scene and the manchester
tech scene are very very different we're
incredibly close-knit the um the
the people that go on the manchester
tech slack which i advise everybody to
go on to there's lots of awesome
conversations that happen on there
and yes and i've got it up there and
that yes we are shouting you out yes
um and but you know we we are so
different we've got dotnet north which
is a
the northern one which um we've got lots
of things just in and around manchester
as well it doesn't have to be just
uh the boundaries of manchester we we've
got
liverpool we've got nottingham isn't too
far away we've got
sheffield we've got leeds we've got hull
we've got sunderland you know they
that's all those communities that sort
of
they are very close to it up in the
north
and they a lot of those have been doing
the online events and you've still got
this core set of people that go to
dotnet north they might go to donate
chef and a few others
um because it's easy but i am seeing
that a lot of people are sticking to
those kind of user groups instead of
going yeah well there's one off in
um the us that's on a um i don't know
eight o'clock in an evening
um but they're still sticking with these
ones that are in the the northern areas
the ones that
they're um they're used to very
different
for the folks on the stream who are
watching who aren't familiar with the
geography of the united kingdom
uh if you've seen game of thrones it is
exactly like that
that is is basically how it works um but
no it's
uh it's been really interesting seeing
the way you know these communities of uh
almost seen it as a challenge um you
know the
the whole geography was it was a
convenient thing but it was also kind of
separate you know
you mentioned they're talking about the
london tech scene uh london doesn't have
a taxi london has about a hundred tech
scenes all
fighting over the same venues and the
same attention span and the same
sponsorship budgets and and those kinds
of things
which you know makes it a really vibrant
city but uh
i do you know very much get the sense
with the events i've done up there you
know you'll go to a a meet-up and you'll
see familiar faces even if the
technology is like oh
i didn't know you did javascript or i
didn't know you were interested in in
python and these kinds of things
um is that something you think is is
going to continue happening as we we do
more things online
i think i think what's interesting in
manchester um
as you say london's big manchester's
like one of the boroughs
in london um whereas you've got like you
said lots lots of competing ones so
um you know you can walk across
manchester in about half an hour 40
minutes which is where you start to see
you know see people walk even just
walking through the city you get
somebody going hi
i spotted you from this user group just
just with you going for your lunch
um so i think i think that's going to
continue i think what's going to be
really interesting
um with um with post pandemic
is the fact that people aren't going to
be going back to the offices i think
that's happening with
more and more of the of the companies
certainly with ours anyway
um but i think people are still craving
that interaction
everybody is you know saying you dylan
desperate for desperate for going out
for a pint and for
going to a gig um and i'm totally with
you
i i'm really looking forward to even
just going out to like baby groups or
pushing the baby along the prom and
you know meeting up with family just
being near people you know
yeah i think we've definitely got that
something that i've done
i've been contemplating running a few
years ago is um
it's like going for a little walk
getting people together going through
manchester for a little walk and
um i think there's part there's there's
like a park bench an agile park bench
event that goes on in manchester i think
that emily webber runs
so in london emily weber once um and
again it's by the dependent and
manchester um um
yeah it might be really nice to start
getting people out and seeing each other
and giving them a reason to go back into
into the city center um but yeah i think
we're still
still gonna see face-to-face ones um the
benefit that people are finding with the
remote ones is for
people who have you know got little
limbs or got caring responsibilities
like me
and as you have as well martin and it's
it's making it a lot more accessible
actually
the scene it's not about you having to
like stay after work and get some food
and
you know not putting the kids to bed and
things like that so i think it's
actually going to help
the scene from my point of view anyway i
think he's got two things to it so it
has got this idea that
um like you say that i have i have
children and
um getting out to a meet up for six
o'clock and not being back till 10
o'clock and
all that kind of stuff it does wear on
you over time so
you know i've seen a lot of when i've
been going to all the online meet-ups
especially around manchester
you say that there's a core set of
people going there's also this other set
of people that
are from manchester that are going to
these local meetups that i've no i've
not seen before
and it's brought in a massively diverse
crowd which has been
really game-changing um because you
don't get the you know the people with
the kids the people with
responsibilities
and it doesn't have to be you know young
children after it might be the taxi
service that you're on
um to take your kids to every one of
their meets that they go to
um but it's widened this community out
which i think has been really
interesting but i have still seen that
these people are coming they're not
people who are coming from the southeast
or
um people from um i don't know scotland
or places like that that are still tame
same time zone it's been people local to
manchester united so they've seen this
manchester
uh meetup go all right yeah i can attend
that one and i
i don't know what the mindset is but i
do feel like people from manchester
united
a lot of the northern towns it's an
identity thing
you know the that i am from manchester
and i don't see the same in london
and that people have that london
identity and nobody's problem
like union identity nobody's actually
from here
it's like supporters of manchester
united not only from manchester
what's really funny actually just on
that um when you when you see
um job applications coming through
manchester everyone's very very careful
not to say whether they're red or blue
[Laughter]
because i mean manchester united is one
of the most internationally recognizable
brands
like yeah well
i think united probably i'm not going to
go there we're not you're not getting
what balls look at us
oh yes little anecdote while we were um
while
me and jacob were trying to find venues
for where we might host um
ndc manchester the idea of running it at
old trafford did come up
and um i i've never seen an idea being
dismissed
so quickly um which was quite
interesting
um but you know you say about manchester
united me and jacob we walked around
manchester united
we walked around in a day very slowly
and checking out loads of different
venues but we were able to check out
pretty much every sizable venue
um within the centre of manchester
within a day even having lunch
and some coffees in between that's just
how
the center of manchester is but we do go
a bit further you know you've got stop
poor you've got
um going up as far as bolton and and
that kind of stuff which is still
inside of this manchester tech seat so i
i didn't notice
so i knew sorry jen go on
i was gonna say yeah so one of my hopes
um for for post-pandemic is that the
small towns that are sort of around
manchester
which have kind of i think they've been
falling victim to what's what's
happening around london
so everything's around the periphery can
i get sucked till the light and soul
gets sucked into
into london that's kind of happening in
manchester uh i'm from preston
and preston actually seems to have a new
revival and i'm hoping places like
bolton blackburn
you know rams bottom i don't know if
you've heard of this term but silicon
ramy
silicon ramen you had it you heard it
here first andy see silicon ramy that's
it's gonna be the big thing we hope
i'm really hoping that people um are
able to go back into the towns
and again if this if there's um remote
events it means that they aren't
um needing to stay in you know and
consider the commute back and
getting stuck on falling asleep on a
train which i think's uh happened quite
often
but we've got yeah we've got we've got
events around slightly saying liverpool
we've got ones in cheshire
um so so i think we've also got people
who are originally from around here
who will also want to kind of come to
these events to to have that bit of
nostalgic as marty says everyone's
really proud to
to be from from the north and your
little town
cities so if we could separate we
probably would
not know that one interesting thing so
you know
ian cooper who was who was on the on
earlier talking about tdd um
he and i sort of you know helped out
organizing the london.net group
for many years now and one of the things
that we are anticipating
is the you know traditional model like
you just said there martin you go to
work and then you go to a meet-up and
then you go and have some food and beers
and you end up kind of
that's your entire evening um and we're
wondering you know when people are not
working in offices anymore a lot of
companies are going fully remote
they just they looked at how much they
were going to have to pay for empty
offices for the next
six months and went no it's fine we're
just that's it we're remote now
so we have all these people who are
working at home
and you know i i can't see people who
have been working at home than traveling
into the middle of a city to go to a
meet-up at 6 00 p.m
because that used to be convenient when
you were at work and i'm wondering if
we're gonna get like
satellite meetups happening where it's
kind of it's more
more geographic than it has been before
it's the people who are like you know
5-10 minute journey from the venue
talking about whatever's interesting
maybe even doing it later in the evening
you know work all day
put the kids to bed have your dinner and
then you're like well
we'll start at eight o'clock and we'll
go through until the pubs kick us out or
whatever do you think that's something
that might be happening
it was something that that started off
like that though didn't it
so um you know i remember the whole
manchester tech scene started off with
um
geek up it was called and then we've had
all the splinter groups kind of because
it
became so big and then geeker wasn't
quite needed anymore and we i i started
one up impressed him so again preston's
about 40 minutes away from
the city centre for manchester um but
also i think
it's quite easy to get into town again
we call it town rather than
the city uh whereas with london it's
it's quite
a um you know it's quite an effort it's
obviously very expensive to live there
um but we've already traveled down there
i consider it an ordeal not effort
london um and and i think we also need
to remember
um we are still going to see a lot of
people still working
in um in the offices or in the city in
the city
and the co-working spaces because not
everyone's able to work from home
um and i think i think we need to start
really thinking more about that
diversity of people who
haven't got a spare room or it's it's an
ordeal on the you know
somebody who's a bit younger and you can
imagine can you imagine sharing the
dining room with your parents house
working from there so we're still we're
still going to have a core group of
people
that need to have an office uh whether
that's
the local shopping centres that are
starting to become derelict and they
start to open up so like you said
satellite places that are outside
but i think people are still going to
make a bit of a bit of a moment of it
and it could even
start doing more day events as well so
that people can
can make a bit of a you know an event
about it come into town meet up with
some people and
and make it more of just a you know an
after work
bit of a bit of a social i think some of
the conversations that i've been having
have
been around that value exchange because
this
it needs to be a very little value
exchange when you're already in the city
you're already in town it's i'll i'll
just go there and i'll pack on an extra
two hours to the end of my day
and there's pizza and there's pizza so
the value exchange of the
the quality of the talk the the amount
of talks that might be there the
diversity of what those talks might be
um am i going to travel all the way into
manchester
um for a one-hour talk from um somebody
who i can go and look at it on youtube
that there's maybe not as much there but
when we look at say
we'll do it at three o'clock in the
afternoon and we'll do two
one hour talked in there and it'll be
some really interesting thoughts yeah
absolutely i'm there
i'll spend the morning in the office and
then i'll do that in the afternoon and
you know i'll make a bit of a day of it
like um like ms says
i think there's there's gonna be a lot
of trying to work out what that value
exchange is but also
how do you do some sort of hybrid events
i know i mean you've done i've talked
quite a lot about how we what the soft
future of conferencing and meetups is
going to be is there going to be this
idea of i'm going to travel into
manchester and i'm going to sit in
spaceport or i'm going to spit i'm going
to sit in any of these
are you
[Laughter]
a co-working space from about five six
years ago
and we've moved times have moved on
martin
well you know am i going to go in there
and i'm going to sit and i'm going to
watch somebody stream
from america onto a projector just so i
can go there and sit with some people
and have some pizza
and i'm probably not but i am going to
travel there if they're going to come in
and i'm going to be
in person with it and maybe we will
stream those things and i think it's
going to be really interesting to see
how the manchester tech community does
that as opposed to some of the other
tech communities which
are potentially more remote um you know
you've got some of these ones where
they don't have as many people as
manchester have were we're quite dense
um in the amount of people that we've
got in a small amount of area
and the amount of companies that are
landing here is also going to be quite
interesting
that what are they going to do if they
land in manchester do they consider
themselves a manchester tech business
because their head office is in
manchester but all their developers are
from around
the country you know and it's going to
be really interesting as to how it
really
changes how we reap meet up so we have a
we have a question in slido from uh neil
barwell hey neil how are you doing
um neil says i've always thought it was
the midlands that seemed to struggle
bracket smart devs notwithstanding it's
a long way to london or manchester for
the evening
what do you think you think we need to
do ndc and dc midlands as well
well um so i i lived in nottingham for a
while so actually yeah i actually know
jess
uh well she was working she came to to
uh at manchester in that
um and i would go to uh evening events
um it would be a bit of a trek but i
would go to an evening event
uh in manchester from nottingham um i
would also try and get over to
um to birmingham this is actually quite
a good tech scene going over in
birmingham um
jess uh jessalyn rose um well would be a
good person for saying what's going on
but i think they've got a little
group uh bristol's got loads and then
then starts going to the south west it
depends where you mean in the midlands
it is quite narrow though
it's just not got very good connections
so you know for for manchester
we've actually got a good train that
will take you to lead so you can go to
an event in leeds for the evening or
like you say go to liverpool
um yeah so i think there's also a bit
more of a culture around the north
around driving um
you know in london it's well if i can't
get the tube there or i can't get the
train there in
like half an hour it doesn't exist um
whereas in manchester will quite happily
drive you know for me
um shout out to the old and tech
community by the way um
sorry richard richard on the manchester
text like i said i need to so
all right um but you know we'll travel
40 minutes in the car
um to a meet-up um because there's a lot
more parking and things like that and i
don't want to have to be
pulled into a train and things like that
and i think that's something that
doesn't exist
inside of london but doesn't exist
outside of london whether that
is you know allows us to go down to
milton keynes um and i do
um i do keep track of that we have david
on the youtube chat saying midlands try
newcastle we got andy on slido saying
how about nbc glasgow manchester's a bit
far down south
there is clearly an appetite something
i've often thought would be interesting
would be kind of putting a small
conference together and taking it on
tour
um on a train right i had a great idea
listen to this we've got a really good
little train that's over it goes down
the
uh the sort of east lancashire and it's
um it stops off and it stops off in each
each job you can go for it to a
different pub
it's like imagine having like a talk on
the train
and then you get off you go to the pub
and there's like some more stuff goes on
they go back on the train
have another dog and you can decide
which carriage to talk
that's such a good idea and because we
have 5g installing we can livestream the
whole thing
so that people who don't want to be on
the train uh one of the things we we've
definitely seen with ndc in the last
year
is uh we've seen people joining the
online events for whom attending in
person
would uh probably never have been an
option for all kinds of reasons you know
visas and travel and caring
responsibilities and getting time off
work all these kinds of things
um which martin said interesting to what
you said about you know the future of
conferences and events
so i definitely think that whatever
happens
we've validated this idea that there are
people out there who will tune in from
home and they will participate
and you know what i think one of the big
challenges for you know us as event
organizers and speakers is
how do you do something so that the
people who tune in on the day get more
than just watching it on youtube
so all of you out there you can tell us
how we're doing right now because yeah
you know
and the folks watching this on the
replay tomorrow will be like i want to
ask my questions but i can't
so richard says in the chat that we can
do a conference on a train because the
tunnels have caused problems with the
wi-fi
[Laughter]
small details small details we can fix
that we just need those pringles to
wi-fi repeaters at either end of the
tunnel
one of the reasons why i was pushing for
nbc manchester is because i do believe
that
um we need to diversify from london um
we need
um a separate thing one of the things
i've been talking to people in the us
about because they don't really get
this idea and i think we've discussed it
a few times around you'll be able to
take
the term better or is it something like
a year is a long time or a
oh yeah in america uh uh in america 100
years is a long time and in the uk 100
miles is a long way
you know and that's that's really
something that i
being more than myself i do feel like
that you know being going to
um hull which is an hour and a half on
the train doesn't feel as far as london
which is only half an hour further
yeah and because it just feels like
there's so much
more that goes with it i'll more than
happily do that and that's why i
believe that sort of manchester sucked
up quite a few different areas from
you know from glasgow um i know it's
four hours or something it's you know
it's not exactly short distance but it
goes as far as sort of nottingham and
potentially cleans i don't know but um
nottingham is an hour on an hour
20 minutes on the train um it's a lot
easier
um so you know i wanted that idea of
something that isn't london
um and obviously being from manchester
that was the only choice
what's the famous joke that they they
asked people in birmingham what is the
uk second city and they all said
birmingham and
they asked people in glasgow what's the
uk second city they said glasgow they
asked people in manchester and they said
london
yeah and only one of those is right just
[Laughter]
um well you know that's that's why i've
been pushing for this idea and you know
it was
it was devastating for me that we didn't
get to do it in person
um you know we had the iconic venue of
um science and industry
so let's just talk a little bit we've
got a couple of minutes left just let's
say a little bit about the venue because
we were
uh supposed to be in uh mostly the
museum of science and industry which is
this uh
phenomenal venue in in manchester tell
us a little bit about some of the events
that you've organized there jim
so uh we have had manchester united
manchester united we decided to
to close that down uh last year because
of the pandemic and things like that
but yeah it's it's an amazing um
place where you've got um i think we
have stevenson's rocket there last year
a couple of years ago
and we've got a baby you know the first
uh
first computer in the corner if everyone
we have the actual uh overnight event
it's part of the science festival as
well
upstairs in the conference center and we
have people there all night
unfortunately can't walk around the
museum in the middle of the night um
and then we have the big after show
downstairs we say we've got baby there
you've got
um you know there's a there's an
airplane so we have stevenson's rocket
um but yeah playing some music on the
on stage um i have
magically appearing glasses of wine um
yeah that's that's
a great one we've run that um but it's
it's a fantastic venue and the the foods
there is brilliant
i've been to agile manchester there as
well we had some people do massages
between talks that was amazing i think
we'll have to have a chat with uh
with jacob about that that's uh that's
definitely something to go on the list
and but you know we were we were looking
at what venues we could do
there were some options um but
manchester science and industry museum
is manchester you know it was just
when we walked in there you could see
that it wasn't um
solidifies manchester it's brick walls
it's kind of it's built in spite
of what it is it is actually it's an old
industrial warehouse isn't it
so it's it's it's from the old train
station
which incidentally is where we were
actually going to do the the main
conference which was
in what's called the 1830 warehouse um
which is three floors
um of big beams and
brick walls and low ceilings and high
ceilings
and it was just yeah one being jacob
watching it was just
yeah this is this has to be it this has
to be where we do it
the um they also have another build in
there it's full of airplanes there's a
nice big glass
glass and steel structure and they have
the astronaut experience as well don't
they
um which is a a nice vr experience in
there
um but it's just it's we're an
industrial town that's our roots
and it just personifies what we are um
we're the worker bee
that's our you know massive the logo for
us
it just like says our identity there's
national identity and there's local
identity and
you know when you you speak to people
who are from manchester that is
who we are and so i just need to press a
button hold on a second
one thing i didn't mention before we
said about different kinds of events
um it was the manchester girl geeks
hundreds tea party on sunday
so i started off the manchester gill
geek dinners years and years ago and
it's turned into these little tea
parties
and what they've been doing is they've
been doing things like it always happens
at a weekend
but they've been doing like pokemon um
you know
pokemon go meetups and doing like litter
picking and things like that so
that might be another thing that you
know another direction the meetups start
going in
but also around the venue museum science
industry
beautiful places to walk we've got
castle film drop down by the the canal
we'll be there next year nbc manchester
atmosi
in person with a train and massages
installing and wi-fi
it's all going to happen we guarantee to
do at least one of the things on that
list
[Laughter]
thank you both very much for your time
folks watching on youtube uh
i'm getting some reports of crackly
audio we are gonna take a break
we are gonna plug and unplug and reboot
and bash some things with a stick and
see if we can just say everything fixed
if people want to manchester text like
and jump on there if you're not from
manchester we
we kind of accept other people
and there's that there you know you can
go on technology calendar to find out
what events we've got
um northwest tech events northwest and
you'll find the calendar
and they're linked to the both the site
groups fantastic
thank you both we'll be back in a few
minutes we've got arenas go to joining
us to talk all about
grpc in.net before that
here is a word from our supporters
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
at ivendi we build technology that makes
it easier for dealers to sell
and consumers to buy vehicles
so what ibendy does is we build a
platform that facilitates online
retailing
this means that we basically make it
easier for people to buy cars and for
dealers to sell them
we do this from end to end
so the full journey from people
consumers coming to the site
right through to the finance
applications that go through so to
facilitate that we have really important
relationships with banks
with vehicle manufacturers and with
vehicle retailers themselves the tech
stack we use is mainly aws and we use
csharp.net as our predominant backend
language
and we use a little bit of azure as well
we deploy most of the stuff
in containers using kubernetes on eks
and we're a big fan of event sourcing
here that helps us to separate the
domains
out into separate areas which allows us
to
keep those domains nice and segregated
and also facilitates the auditing which
is a big part of us working in a
regulated environment
i chose ivendi mainly because of the
people they're very welcoming they're
really knowledgeable and seem really
passionate about the technology and the
quality of the products that they're
[Applause]
creating
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to margo we're an
airport-centric travel company owned by
mac the country's largest airport
group most importantly we're a globally
unique
digital tech business based right here
in manchester we operate as an
innovation hub a truly
agile e-commerce business driven by data
and the latest tech to provide airports
across the world with a unique blend of
products
technologies and services for their
passengers we have become synonymous
with airport customer ecommerce
platforms
which were constantly evolving if you
plan to fly again in the near future you
may well use our system without
realizing that it's actually a mango
product
we're a business for someone who wants
to create and do something a bit
different
for the techies we have a fail fast cicd
approach using.net core at the back
view and react to the front and aws
cloud hosting expect to grow our team
over the coming year so please keep an
eye on our mago linkedin page for the
latest jobs
thank you
[Music]
bye
yes
[Music]
okay everybody welcome back how are you
all doing out there
uh we are going to be running the first
of our ndc manchester quizzes we have a
a couple of small quizzes we are going
to be running over the course of today
to uh to make this an event that isn't
just like watching a youtube stream
while they're recording it
uh we want this to be interactive we
want to give away some prizes we have a
free ticket to ndc manchester next year
which as we've just said we are planning
and hoping we'll be real
and it will be at mossy taking place uh
on the ground with real people in real
rooms
uh because we miss that the stuttering
and crackering has gone
thank you richard that's amazing uh
whoever's running the poll stop running
the poll i am in control here don't
touch that button
thank you very much uh so we are gonna
run
through take a couple of minutes to get
some folks connected
the first prize winner is gonna win a
ticket to nc manchester
um three runners-up are going to get a
limited edition so any of you been to
our ndc events in previous years
the nbc hoodie is a much sought-after
collector's item there are
people out there who have collected the
whole set um the last year we have not
been doing
ndc hoodies because of logistics with
shipping and all this kind of stuff but
for manchester we're gonna run some
special edition printed just for the
winners only ones in the world so enter
our competitions
for a chance to win one of those we'll
uh give it another few seconds for folks
to get
uh lined up and connected and everything
and then
we are going to be pitting our wits
against five fiendish questions
about computer programming so you all
ready now then
there is a latency of about three or
four seconds
between what happens here and when you
see it on youtube so if you are playing
along on the quiz it is vitally
important
that you look at the slido screen not at
the screen that is there
on the wall behind me um because that
screen is going to be four seconds below
and you get points for faster answers
so open up slido on your phone or get it
on a web browser that's where we need
your attention that's where the
reactions are gonna count
if you're just watching along at home
watch along at home enjoy it let's see
who wins
so starting the quiz question one
what was the c sharp language originally
called
was it c plus plus plus was it d
was it cool or was it visual pascal
seven six five four
three two one let's see how we did the
correct answer was cool
which stood for the common
object-oriented language
which was a sort of working title
prototype um anders heilsberg who
designed pascal
he was the uh designer of a lot of the
stuff that was in the first version of c
sharp
um and uh so so the visual pascal
connection is there that wasn't the name
um d is a real language which was called
d because it came after c
now there's an interesting uh the word c
or the programming language c
um came after b and b was called b
because b
was a condensed version of bcpl and bcpl
was the uh something common programming
language i can't remember what the b
stands for um but then it became cpl
which was just the common programming
language
or the cambridge programming language um
or christopher's programming language
so there's a rumor floating around on
the web that the c in c stands for
christopher
which is sort of slightly true um and c
plus plus plus actually the sharp in c
sharp is four plus sine c plus plus plus
plus
and you arrange the pluses together and
that's where you get the sharp from and
in music c sharp is one higher than c
so the correct answer is cool common
object-oriented language and
the winner after that is
richard pearson correct answer in seven
seconds
nice going richard uh let's
have a look at the next question so
which one of these is
not a real programming language
is it j sharp f sharp b sharp or q sharp
one of those is not a real programming
language
which one is it
i was doing uh if any of you were doing
the the advent of code puzzles that they
do i did those last year and they they
have a
questions each question they so
so no one thinks f sharp is not a real
programming language that's a strong
show of support for f sharp um f sharp
and j sharp
and q sharp are all real things
they are all real programming languages
created by microsoft
j sharp is not around so much anymore j
sharp was
microsoft's visual i believe it was
bytecode compatible with java
at one point and it shipped if anyone is
is old enough to remember
visual interdev um we're talking that
kind of pedigree you know there was
visual basic visual interdev
and there was visual jsharp and then.net
came along and of course fixed all the
problems and now we don't have any
controversy about programming languages
anymore let's have a look
at the leaderboard q sharp of course is
the microsoft's quantum programming
language which is extremely awesome
um and uh b sharp is a band i saw in a
ski resort in france about three or four
years ago who were also excellent so if
you get a chance to see the b sharps
check them out
and mikkel and tom are both on the lead
fastest answers uh there 22 seconds each
let's have a look at another question
which programming language was created
by cynthia solomon
was it pearl logo haskell or
rockstar
see the live results on that
and the correct answer is of course
logo uh cynthia created logo as part of
an educational programming project
um logo is a uh it's a dialect of lisp
in a lot of ways
a lot of people who've worked with logo
just remember it as being you know move
the turtle around the screen and draw
lines and things um
logo is actually a pure functional
language with an awful lot of very very
cool stuff in it
um pearl was invented by larry wall
haskell is a simon peyton jones i
believe
and uh i think if i'm remembering this
correctly
um the team who put that together are
now working
on lambda support in microsoft excel so
if anybody ever says
excel is not a programming language you
can point out that it is a pure
functional programming language with no
side effects it has a rapid evaluation
loop
it has an interactive prototyping
environment and it has lambda support
created by the same people who invented
haskell um
and rockstar there is uh why would
anyone invent a programming language
called rockstar that would just mean
that all the rockstar developer ads on
linkedin became
meaningless uh but i did it's at
codewithrockstar.com you can check that
out let's have a look at the leaderboard
tom has sneaked into the lead let's have
a look
there are five questions in each of
these quizzes by the way the next
question which of these
languages is the oldest
which of these languages is the oldest
now i just need to check my working for
this one because i had this all lined up
and then i was looking at some resources
last night
and something popped up that said maybe
perhaps my information on this was out
of date
uh let me just check my notes here
this as we said this is the fine art of
running a
live show and uh flying the plane at the
same time
and the answer is yes there we go
the answer by a nose believe it or not
is
python um python is the oldest of those
languages python was first released in
february 1991 visual basic was may
1991 and then javascript and java were
released in very rapid succession
in 1995. so the oldest one of those
languages is python there's an
interesting
discussion goes on sometimes about uh
what if python
had been the language that ended up
being embedded in web browsers
um because you know it was javascript is
is based on scheme
brenda mike developed it based on the
scheme syntax and then uh
the legend has it that marketing
influence from sun microsystems
did some deal with netscape and said no
no the language has to look like java
otherwise no one's gonna do it
um so we could have had schema and lisp
in a browser we got javascript in a
browser we could have had python in a
browser
and the question i think is interesting
there is actually two questions one is
if python ran in browsers what would the
browsers look like now and two
if python ran in browsers what would
python look like now
but yes python is the oldest one of
those languages tom is holding on to the
lead
uh let's have a look at the last
question in this round
according to the tayobi march 2021
survey
which of these languages is the most
popular go
ruby rust or visual basic
mark says do i get a prize for being
lost in the quiz
i think we can probably work something
out
um which of these languages
is most popular it is visual basic
visual basic for all of the excitement
and community
uh it's so the tyobi index is based on
doing massive surveys of content
published on the web
and uh vb when it comes to people
sharing code and publishing stuff online
and documentation and stuff
vb is still more popular than all of the
others now vb has history you know there
is a track record here
visual basic has been around for a long
time people have been writing systems in
it since
forever and a lot of those systems are
still running and you know popularity is
not just about
um new things and greenfield projects
popularity is about how much code is
actually out there running on this thing
and yeah vb visual basic
is more popular than go ruby and rust
sorry hacker news
the statistics do not lie and that means
that at the end of that quiz the winner
is neil
barnwell neil we will be in touch by
email
assuming you put the right email address
into slido there um we are going to be
in touch we are going to send you out
your uh
your ticket for ndc manchester next year
tom mikhail
douglas richard we will get in touch
with you to arrange some
limited edition ndc manchester hoodies
we will be doing some more quizzes over
the course of the day but right now
we are going to press some buttons and
we are going to switch over and we are
going to welcome
uh live by the power of the internet uh
irina
is joining us from uh from romania i
believe
yep that's right hello everyone
that's one of the things that i enjoy
about being
on a pandemic we just plan to travel
everywhere
but i'm kind of tired of working from
home
and presenting at online conferences see
i i think what
go on sorry i really love manchester i
had a
customer there and i travel the lodge to
manchester and
it's simply the best beautiful town
in the whole world for me it is our
great pleasure to welcome you to
manchester virtually
uh what are you talking to us about
today now
today i'm gonna talk and try to convince
you uh to use grpc
if you're not doing grass properly
i mean um we all uh go to
uh and say that we implement rest apis
but we kind of do not respect all the
the condition that rest has and why not
look at grpc it's much nicer and faster
okay i'm just going to stop your second
it looks like we got some crackling on
the audio which uh suggests that one of
the cables here is is misbehaving
just bear with me one second i'm gonna
say we can fix that up before we kick
off your talk
uh we'll be right back in one second so
let me punch that one there
oh that's the cable that's patching into
there
that should be fine that should be fine
that should be fine and uh okay irina
could you just uh talk to us give us
some words and we'll see what the
audio signal is coming through on the
other end yes so i will try to convince
you that
it's a good idea to embrace grpc and.net
i know there was a
workshop uh yesterday about grpc with
mark
randall and i'm sure uh if you
participated or heard about it you'll
know a lot of things about your pc now
but for
other people that weren't part of that
workshop
maybe i'm gonna try to convince them i
will ask them at the end
if i convince them all right that grpc
is good enough
fantastic uh we are gonna start there's
some folks reporting crackling audio uh
we are probably gonna have to look at
that in
in the next break it is uh clearly some
some wire here that has got crossed and
isn't pointing where it's supposed to be
crossing we'll try and get that fixed
but in the meantime
uh please put your hands together and
welcome to the nbc stage
uh talking about embracing grpc and dot
net irena's got two
hello everyone i'm hope i'm hoping that
my
my slides are visible so first of all
who am i i'm from romania from a city
called yash
i'm a software architect at a company
named indava that is
uk based i organize a user group
i teach.net and i blog from time to time
but not as often as i could um
and today i'm gonna try to convince you
that using grpc it's
a very good idea and it brings us
a lot of benefits but first of all
we cannot talk about modern technology
under our tool belt
without remembering the times i mean
the monolith times i remember that i
enjoyed
working on monoliths because everything
was there it was a single code base in a
single language
but i didn't care at that time about
scaling
scaling was somehow hard not impossible
but
hard and costs a lot of money
it was a bad user experience for some
users
but for us as developers i remember when
i was a junior developer
um i had a big solution that took a lot
of time to build
and i remember that i just pressed the
build keyword
and i just went out and grabbed a coffee
and sat with my colleagues because that
long it took
to build a solution so the fact is
with the monolith everything was there
if you needed something
you went there you looked at the code
you instantiated some code or
if you were lucky enough to have a dia
system
you injected the things there and
everything worked like
look it works you didn't need to worry
about i don't know kubernetes or
microservices or whatever
other services that you need to drag
over
in your machine in order for them to
work or in docker
and it was very easy you have a chunk of
code that you shove it into production
and when the release came
um it was all or nothing i mean it
either it worked or it didn't
if you were if you had the single
instance
of the production server so i remember
coding uh in web forms
and also in asb mvc and everything was
somehow in there you had the front end
you had the back end
all in a single unit and you had one
database or
maybe several databases but you know as
soon as the year passed by
the paradigms are changing and they tend
also to come back
from from time to time but asp mvc
front-end and back-end it was so nice as
an infrastructure
back then when you compared it to the
web forms
and it was nice and an easy experience
for junior developers to learn
but nowadays i see a lot of companies
and projects that are are splitting
that self-contained onion architecture
into the front-end application and
back-end application with whatever
databases they use
and the front-end is usually coded by
the front-end developers
react view or whatever js framework that
appears
um it's taken care of we as dot-net
developers we do not care about
those we are coding kpis and
we are doing microservices and pretty
much
life is easier but we need to understand
that the future is distributed
because the the data is growing the user
demands
also growing and we need to adapt to the
modern times and
when we need to process a lot of data
modern times means that
you need to go distributed or else
you kind of need to spend a lot of money
to scale that big
chunk of code so now the modern
applications
are either like this uh have a front-end
app that consume
consume a lot of back-ends a lot of apis
and those apis have databases or maybe
have some other backends that they
integrate with
or the other part when you have
microphone trends
if you're lucky enough to work with
microfrontends somehow
life is easier but the party are the
same
you have front end and the back end and
nowadays
because we need to serve our business
and our customers
you'll see architectures like this
not very good architectures but you
somehow need to communicate with
different technologies and you might
have a dot net core application that
communicates with the go api
node.js the third party api and
you might have a swift app and so on and
so forth
and you need to integrate and you need
to find common ground between all these
technologies
and you might say hey we already have a
common
ground we have a common language that
every technology understands json
for that means uh we have rest for
everything
right let's face it when we say we have
an api
we kind of tend to say that we have rest
apis
but if we dig deeper into our apis
we might find out that rest as a concept
is not there
in our apis and we simply have json over
http
or something like that so
nowadays we have clients and we have
servers
and every time these two entities talk
with each other
and they talk talk with each other a lot
there is a process that is called
content negotiation that
takes place and this content negotiation
happens absolutely every time when you
issue a request um it's some
somehow behind the scenes web api does
this for us
but content negotiation is about format
of the request
what is the payload how do you handle uh
retries
or errors how do you handle
authentication
and first what happens if the model
changes
if the clients expect something from the
server then
it's not sent or if the server expects
a specific format of the request from
the client side
what happens if you have the client
application and the server app in the
same team
or in your house then it's easier uh you
go and talk with the devs and
say hey add this field or hey remove
this field or change the format or the
the data type but what if you do not
have something like this
and you you're not able to talk with the
team that integrates with your back end
so the client the client app is
developed somewhere else
and now we might say okay what's the
point with this what's wrong with rest
because it works it does the job we have
so many projects so many apps and
businesses
that have rest or restful or rest-ish
apis now i might say that
the problem with the rest
is that there is a constant chit chat
between the teams
okay you'll say that we have processes
we have agile and business analysts and
all kind of
jobs and tools that help us with this
but having
rest apis um kind of forced us to
communicate
and i'm not against communication in the
teams but sometimes that communication
it's a hustle and it makes our work very
tedious
because maybe we do not have modern
tools to to make checks or maybe we do
not have tests
and then i want you to have a short look
at
what a remote procedure called might
look
or might be so rpc
it's there for a long time i think from
the 60s
or 70s or something like that
it's not something new but as i already
told you
some concepts tend to reappear in our
lives periodically
they disappear and then reappear so rpc
if we were to talk about a remote
procedure call in
its uh in entirety as a term
i want you to look at this code i hope
it's big enough
um we we have an order
uh we have a call from a service
somewhere
create order and it's passed on a
request
and then we need to interrogate the
payment status
and then we check if the payment state
was a success as fast
sorry about what happened with members
is successful
and then uh we need to arrange the
shipping for it
if you look at this code it pretty much
looks like it's in the same context it's
in the same app
it's service these are services that are
in the same application or belong to the
same abstraction
even if they're in different bounded
contexts
but if you look at this it's very easy
to
to see that there is no network involved
there is no network call at least at the
first glance this is what you'll see
okay this just cold calls method calls
and that's it
there is no traveling over the network
to get something
and if we were to look at this specific
code
over the network might look like this
so we have the payment status and the
processing of the payment
it does nothing else then to call a
method that lives
in another system over the network
somewhere
and the deal is that
our pc will make the code look local and
when it does that it will be prone to
errors
uh for a junior developer for example
when it starts with rpc remote procedure
calls
in this in the code he won't think about
performance or how much data he brings
over the network
or passes over to the the calling party
it's code there it looks like
programmatic and they will use the
methods there
so the goal of the rpc
is to make network communication
transparent so
pretty much it's like you have a
distributed system that behaves like
monolith when you look at it
when you're in the code it will behave
like monolith
and it won't be that obvious to you that
you're doing with each method called
you're doing a network call
so what's the deal with grpc
okay we understood the concept of rpc
but grpc
uh started in 2001 as being the google
stubby project
a few years uh after it uh grpc
has been opus open sourced and then
10 11 years after that grpc had
its first version and since 2019
are enjoying working with grpc with.net
core
so basically grpc is the newer version
of rpc or the most modern
implementation and it's nothing more
than a contract
it has a contract based you'll do the
contract
and you'll implement the contract and
you'll use that and using grpc will
basically force you not to have cold
references
i've seen a lot of projects where people
are trying to
pass data from one service to another
service by doing http requests
and using http clients and they usually
pass
those http clients in nugget packages
and the problem with that is that they
tend to grow
they tend to shove logic in there that
logic is also distributed into those
nugget packages
and it tends to be like a spaghetti
there
with nugget package references but
with grpc you'll have no code references
the only thing that you'll
uh you'll pass around will be that that
file that we're going to talk about
another thing that is very cool about
grpc is that
is inherently faster because it uses
http 2
so it's modern and it has a
super efficient protobuf serialization
which
ends uh as having a smaller payload and
another
cool thing is that it's available in
many languages so it will allow you the
to integrate with
all these technologies like go node.js
or c plus plus why not
and we'll do some code generation for
you
we sometimes are lazy and we rely on
code generation
so grpc will do nothing
more than to introduce something in
between your
client and your server and in this
context when i'm saying client i'm
seeing
another server app api
and the common ground between them is
this dot protofile
that has a specific format and with this
format allows us to do a lot of things
for example the protofile niche needs to
have a look at in detail uh how it looks
first of all it's a dot protofile it's
up to you how you name that
at at the top you need to say what is
the
syntax that you are using proto syntax
is
something specific and from google i
will
hand you over some references to that um
you will define here the option the
packages
that they will generate and then you'll
have to go
and define so this is the interface
definition
you say hey my service is called fibo
uh i'm hoping to get the mouse over
to this my service is called fibo
and inside it i have a method or an
endpoint somehow that is called compute
fibonacci that has
an input and also returns a fibonacci
result
and this is the rpc service that we are
um
we're trying to expose somehow
and further down below we have the
request
request and the response format which
are nothing then
message definitions so in here we're
going
to have request number as being the
quote unquote request of our grpc call
and inside it will have a property name
number and
of type in 32. don't be
uh surprised that one is not an
assignment
uh it's actually the order of the field
in that specific
message it has a binary representation
and a binary serialization
so one two three will be the the order
of your properties in there
so pretty much this is what you'll need
to do in order to
define like an interface in c sharp you
have the interface this is
the contract that you'll need to
implement so you expose this and
pass this around so grpc
as as types has a lot of
let's say a ways of communicating
out of the box some call them modes or
method types or
you choose what you use modes or method
types or
there might be also other ways of naming
this so
we have unary which is pretty much the
request response that we
somehow know from http we have server
streaming
client streaming and bi-directional
stream
and i will take uh them independently
and talk about each other
so unary what means to have a urinary
call
urinary call in grpc is like what we
already know in
http client server request response
so there is a client that issues a
request
the server receives that request and
sends a response
and depending on what it's expecting
in the response there will also be a
status code in there but i will show you
in the demo more
about this how it looks in terms of
definition
uh in the proto file it looks something
like this
you have um like what is the input and
you have what is the return
uh and in here uh it's basically a
mistake
this shouldn't have been here so you
have one thing in
one thing out this is the urinary colon
that's why it's called
urinary server streaming
it's on the same principle you have the
client
that issues the request the server
receives the requests
and in turn doesn't answer with one
thing
it answers with many things as response
so it's one thing in several out
client streaming it's pretty much the
the reverse you you will have the client
that issues a request so
you cannot have uh the server sending
something uh to the client without
previously uh the clients issuing a
communication
so the client will issue communication
with several things in
and the server will process those and
answer with
just one thing okay so many in
just one out bidirectional well it's a
combination of those two
you'll have several things in and
several things out
and when it comes to implementation in
the in c sharp
the important things are the the stream
keywords
that you're adding near the the input
fields or the
return fields so you'll have something
like this
um if you add stream
as an input you'll have client so the
client sends a stream of things
and if you add stream
in the return part you have returning
a stream of things in this case
fibonacci fibonacci result so
pretty much this is it you'll need to go
to create something
uh and to expose that something using a
different a system
so let's see a bit about
uh code so
uh let me maximize this
hoping this will be just big enough
so how do you create a grpc project so
first of all
you go to new new project
and you'll see there is already a
template
it's grpc service that when you go ahead
give it a name and so on
and if you click create and everything
goes smooth
it will ask you hey what do you want you
want a
drpc service and what are the frameworks
that you have available and clicking
next
will lead you to the project
so what you'll find is that is nothing
else nothing more than
a project that has the startup cs
program cs and the app settings json
that we already know of
but compared to web api it will have no
controllers or
something like that but instead it will
have a pro tools folder
and a services folder in these
if we were to look at these in the
protos part
you'll have grid photo proto which is
the default one so
dummy code that to get you started to uh
to help you uh
understand what what's going on in here
so the service is called greater
and it's unary because it doesn't have
the stream
in here the keyword or in here so it's a
simple request
and another thing that you have is the
greater service
which is nothing else nothing more than
the implementation of that interface
that you
you specified in the protofile uh of
course the greater service
or whatever service you will add in here
it can be used with dependency injection
you can inject things in there like
loggers or contacts or repositories or
whatever you
need but
in the actual functionality part of the
service
you'll have these
with the name that is specified in the
file
so the logic that you add in here it's
up to you
you'll see i have very simple examples
but the most important part that i want
you to have a look at
is this greater greater base this
greater base
if we were to inspect it it's something
that is very strange
and it's co-generated uh we didn't do
pretty much anything to implement this
it just exposes some um definitions
you see these are hello requests hello
reply the messages that we're specifying
in the proto files
and methods names and so on you do not
need to
to look at those because every other
aspect of the project
you already know if you work with web
api and dot net
or sp and vc core you'll know how to
handle things
because you'll have the middleware
already added for you
and the rest is it's kind of history we
we're familiar with
but let's have a look at the some actual
code
so uh a closed visual studio yay
so i will need to open it again
we're we will play in the console pretty
much but i will show you code
my computer decides to actually load the
solution
so what i have in here i'm gonna zoom it
a little bit
come on zoom a bit okay so what i have
in here is a suit of um
console apps i have the unary part
i have server streaming client streaming
and the bi-directional
these are nothing more than console apps
and i also have the server that
implements the grpc port and the
the the console apps will be the clients
so let's have a look at the server and
first of all
i'm going to show you the produce files
file because it's only one in this case
okay open i hope i'm not
lucky enough to have my computer crash
right now okay so using the same
the same approach i have the gritter
service i have the same
hello request that is default in there
is the unary one
but what you'll see is the other three
methods implemented
server stream with the hello request
will return stream of hello reply
client stream streams uh several things
in
hello request and you'll get one thing
back bi-directional adding the stream uh
keyword
in near the input and near the return
part
uh here nothing fancy it's a name it's a
message
as a property but in the service part i
want you to
show you
line by line to say hello you're already
familiar with
i'm receiving something in so
the deal is like okay you have those
methods that you're defining in the rpc
service
the protofile and then when you go ahead
and implement them
you'll have one parameter that is
already known
and exposed by you but the second
parameter is mandatory
and it will be the server called context
and the server call context will be
is very similar to http context that we
already know from
classical http web api this will
allow you to extract things from the
call and from the context
just exactly as we used to in web api
um so if you want to extract something
from the context this is your
go to place you have the context in
there and you can
extract things from there another thing
for example in the server stream i'm
going to expand that
this is when the server streams
it means that it receives one thing so
it receives the hello request
and then you'll have two additional
parameters
you have the server streamwriter that
will represent the response stream
that it will be sent back and also
the the context parameter this
you cannot get rid of it's very
important
and in terms of um actual demo
what i will show you is that a simple i
i have a for loop that goes from zero to
a specific number
and it does nothing more than either to
send replies either to send
and receive input somehow
and on the server side this is the
implementation right
and i'm going to go ahead and show you
the the unary part
that is the console app and i'm going to
tell you that this console app has no
reference
uh to the server app as you would do
with http clients you have
a reference or pass along and now get
packaged
and if you do not believe me i'm going
to show you this so
under the packages you'll see the grpc
and the protobuf and the grpc tools
which are needed but that's it no other
reference to
no other projects in here and what
you'll do
in order to instantiate and call the
grpc server
it will be to create a channel because
this is how it works
first you have the concept of the
channel where you pass the address
pretty much of the server that it lives
there and then you will have some
credential related stuff
but i do not want to add any
authentication in here and i added this
channel credentials insecure after that
um you will have available
a greater client that is already there
for you
and you'll pass on the channel and so
far this is very familiar
http clients if you have a work with
them it's pretty much the same
and what will happen is that you will
need to instantiate a request
and that request comes from the
protofile
and what you'll do is just call the
method client say hello
pass on the request and if you have
options
to pass along with that call you'll
instantiate that and
add it in here so say hello there is no
reference
to any to the server or in any package
that contains the actual implementation
what happens
is that you know the
the where you know where to call and
also
you have the protofile that is available
to you in the project this is very
important
if you look at the project file you'll
see that
there is a specific thing added in here
so i added an item group
that points to the grid protofile so the
protofile
is the common ground between my server
and my client app
the unary console app and in here
this is location that is accessible at
the project level and
that profile maybe can be passed through
a ci cd
mechanism or so on but you need to make
sure that you have access to this
because that is your way of sharing data
and sharing
the contract and what i also specified
in here
is that uh this is a client so grpc
services
this is the client so it behaves like a
client
on the other way around on server side
if we were to edit the project file
we'll have somehow similar thing
an item group but this time grpc
services
has the server as value of the grpc
property so this is uh this is the major
difference between the two
and the grid proto is accessible because
it is in the same
the same folder
also you'll need to make sure that you
copy the protofile when you
deploy or something like that so um
i have in here like this in the left
hand side
you'll have the server that gonna wait
and it's gonna run we're gonna start
this over
it's gonna build a bit and on the right
hand side
we're gonna have the unary part what
you'll see
here is that it's simply uh an
app that listens on a specific port that
i overridden
and the uni report will issue calls one
call
and we'll get something back and what it
sent
so in the request it sent ndc man
manchester
the call was received here on the server
side
you'll see that there is an application
grpc
mime type and it took that many
milliseconds
and the request type is post
over http 2. so
uh request was received and in turn
we received a hello ndc manchester as a
response
so this is a classic way hello uh
request response okay
we're gonna leave the the server running
and i'm gonna show you the
client streaming part let's see client
streaming
okay the server listen it's up
remember remember that it's still an end
point it still needs to be up in order
to
for it to receive holes
as on the left left hand side you see a
lot of things
getting in that are coming from the
client
and the client wait send stuff
what's the number oh okay and in return
as a response it got that number because
that's the
max value for my i that i added the loop
for
so what what it called is another method
called greater greater client stream
and it took that many milliseconds
so this is imagine how cool it is to
upload uh images or i don't know big
chunks of data
into splitting it and separate things
and
just getting a confirmation back hey i
got all your
chunks of data for uploads for example
server streaming it's somehow similar
because it will
send one thing but you'll get will get a
lot of things back
so you you have
a smaller number as an i value hello
okay but on the the server side
it's one thing that got in uh instead
for the client the servers um part it
was streamed a lot of things
and also uh i will show you that there
is no concept of like
headers headers as we know but we have
something that is called
trailers that we can mimic headers with
and the last part is the bi-directional
one
okay so i'm gonna run this
bidirectional
what happened is on the server side
we're seeing like just
one thing in and and the client part
you see it sent nine things ten things
in fact and received back the same
ten things so it's bi-directional but
uh you need to keep in mind that someone
the client needs to initiate the
communication you cannot
like a signal or you cannot just push
something to the client without the
client ever wanting
that so let's have a look a bit
on the the project part
so unit is very simple request response
but on the server streaming somehow
things are
getting uh complicated maybe
so the same things you have the channel
you create the client and then use that
client to call the method that you
expose
uh you'll have one request in um
and then you're gonna await a wait for
each reply
so when you're replying you'll read from
the
response stream because those are the
many things that you need to read
um and then you need to write those into
the console or whatever you need to do
and another thing that i want to show
you
is that you have the possibility of
using a parameter that is called
deadline
i mean if you do not get a response in a
specific
time or something like that you just say
hey this time down
you cannot wait anymore so you add the
parameter
deadline and specify milliseconds or
cancellation token or whatever
but you'll be able to like abort that
okay trailers
get trailers it's a mentor that it's
already there
the three alert part is a dictionary
that you'll be able to add
with your replies and requests
so you have no header the traditional
one to add but you can add
uh my value pairs
in there in order to help you i don't
know distinguish different things
okay let's see in the client streaming
is the other way around you have to
your client stream and then you write in
the request stream so you send many
things in
and you wait for it to complete and then
you wait
the one response that you know that
you'll
get back another thing that is worth
mentioning is that you can work with
exceptions
in rpc but that those exceptions
will be rpc exceptions and you'll be
able to filter them by status codes
but that status code it's not the same
as
http status codes these are
more related to to rpc
and you'll you'll see here if i will be
able to
zoom in and i'm not so you'll see
aborted
already exists cancelled data lost and
so on
um which is are specific to grpc and
that's it
not the traditional that we know from
http so you'll be able to distinguish
different things by using specific
status codes
and bi-directional it's a combination of
those two
okay so you open at the the channel
communication
and then you will write into the
response stream
and then read into the request stream
and the same you can catch exception and
filter them by
specific status codes that are grpc
related
um okay what i also wanted to show
you is the trailer part so the trailer
or the fake headers basically are
nothing else than metadata that
comes along with the request uh the grpc
call
it subtype metadata entry and you add
just
value a key and value and it's up to you
what you add in here and you add it in
the context because
the context is the one that knows a lot
of things about the calls
and you simply can add it in there but
it's not the traditional way of
using headers as we know in http api
and coming back to the slides uh
grpc has a lot of strengths and
we need to look at this i know that it's
a comparison
with rest and not with wcf as
it usually does rest is restaurant
focused and rpc is action based it's
more programmatic and also being more
programmatic it embraces
its semantic and also in rest if you
we tend to have loose coupling
as much as the loose coupling that we
can have
in our pc you definitely have a tighter
coupling you have that protofile and
with that profile you are coupling your
application
and in terms of serializations one is
text based and one is binary based
so right now having the grpc stub
it will just allow you to have different
technologies because grpc is
universal when it comes to performance
uh grpc is like 80 and something
smaller than the rest response
this is on an example that i i had
it's a lot of improvement in here and as
developers we need to take care of our
users and the data that we're passing
over the network
and it's very fast and it's super
performant
polyglot environments if you have such a
scenario
in your business it's very suitable for
it
it's super lightweight and it's easy to
work with as long as you
uh get to know it it's super super
useful for point-to-point communication
so i would advise you to try it when you
have
http clients go ahead and use grpc
because
it's much easier and much
faster being contract based
having smaller payloads and using http 2
out of the box
and also supporting different streaming
types i think is very powerful
because it it can allow you
a lot it can open a lot of worlds for
you
but also we need to mention a few
downsides
uh you'll have temporal coupling it's
not like in messaging
you'll have the need of the systems both
to be up
maybe it's not obvious but if you need
to call a server
that server needs to be up in order to
respond to your grpc goals
also because it's so programmatic and
it's so cool
as an approach as in programmatic style
you might forget that there's a network
involved
and the data and the calls that you're
making are traveling over the network
and another downside is that the payload
is not human readable and you cannot
like just
use postman and look at what you get
back and understand what's wrong
you can uh you need to use different
tools and also you'll need to
do better testing because
we better testing will prevent you from
doing mistakes
in terms of what you add in the payloads
and so on
also it will force you to focus on ci cd
or
on a mechanism that you'll automate your
sharing
of the protofiles you cannot copy those
by hand on the server
you need to make sure that the profile
that is the contract
is available to the apps that are using
it
and in server in summary it has
four modes the couple's code because the
couple's codes
code in terms of not having so many
nugget packages to share and to
reference
and it's a good part but also
having another tool in our tool belt uh
makes us think about the future of web
apis
if it's programmatic uh there will be no
more accounting
for documentation there will be no
swaggers and everything to understand
how an api works
you will just have to look at the
profile and look at the code to
understand things
and there also will be no
misinterpretation of status codes
we have 63 of them and i bet we kind of
use i don't know maybe
ten or okay seven of them
uh and also using the protofiles there
will be no
more data parse errors if you do not
have testing and take care of those
when the contract change changes uh all
the other apps that are using the
protofiles
are forced to change and this way the
errors are
minimized so
we need to uh bear in mind that
distributed systems are about trade-offs
and even though we have if we have all
kinds of modern tools
in our tool belt we need to pick right
and pick the right ones for business and
for our project
not just pick the most modern ones
because maybe the
most modern ones it's not suitable for
you
as next steps i would strongly suggest
you to
have a look at grpc web it works like a
charm
with with laser also
and it's uh one year since it is very
stable
http 2 it has a lot of differences uh
compared to http one
it's way faster and the data
transmission is way different
and you also need to have a look at that
and if you're interested in protocol
buffers
and the syntax and the types that
they're they're exposing have a look at
developers.google.com and
if you love grpc if you love curl
there is a grpc curl and you'll be able
to do
a curl request for grpc
and also mike randall
book grpc for wcf developers
if you have if you need to dig deep or
deeper into grpc you'll find it very
useful
i know that i did and i know that the
comparison is usually
with wcf but
i want people to to have a look at their
apis
and to understand that hey if i'm not
doing rest properly
maybe grpc is the solution for me so
thanks for listening
and for uh being here
hey irina thank you right we're just
trying out some slightly different audio
folks on the stream while arena was uh
espousing the benefits of grpc
i've rewired a couple of things you
should now have two people talking
and no crackling we may have the
technology um
erin that was excellent and uh grpc is
such an exciting technology particularly
the
um you know being able to plug different
languages and platforms into one another
and do all that kind of stuff
uh we have a couple of questions have
come through in
uh slido while while you were talking
there so we've got uh let me just take a
little look over here and see what we
got here
uh so the top voted one is uh actually
one was from me but i'm gonna ask my own
question because it got voted up um
when you talk about the message
structure where you have to put the
positions of the the
elements uh what happens if you remove
something what happens to the numbers
oh um if you
want i i might say bad things right now
but
if you it's very easy to make it
backwards compatible and forward
compatible
grpc but there is a lot of theory around
that and that's why i
advise my mike randall's uh book okay
he talks about that in there um and
it's supposedly i've never done it in
production yet
uh but if you remove that i think it
will break so you have two
three and you skip a number i bet it
will break
any any question where the answer is
read mark rundle's book that's a pretty
good answer
right
um so dan asks does grpc typically
replace rest in an existing system or
can
it be used in tandem with existing
rest requests uh it can be
it can be used in tandem with rest
requests but what i'm trying to
um to advise people is that if you're
not doing rest properly and maybe rest
is not suitable for you maybe grpc is
and you can have a look and try it it
can work in parallel
i mean system to system for sure grpc
can work
rest should be like more for public
facing apis
this is public this is the client app
and that's it but
api to api cool it would work like a
charm
so uh grpc would you say that's a good
idea if you control both ends of the
pipe
then it's a good idea but if the client
is somebody else's software
somebody else's company then rest is
better for
supporting public apis because yeah yeah
and that actually ties down to another
question about
security and authentication what are the
the options in grpc for
securing and authenticating your your
apis
um i don't know how to answer to this
because i haven't looked at it i know
it has but yet again the book it has
it has a section in it i was playing
more uh with it because
i really found uh that is beneficial i
mean okay you have
uh client up javascript apps and uh
an api is good i mean red won't
disappear
but a server to server calls i think it
can be replaced
you have pretty much no reason to do i
don't know
excellent um vincent says could you
replace a server-to-client signalr
stream with a grpc stream
uh it depends not necessarily
[Laughter]
because um in grpc uh the client is the
one that usually initiates
the request i mean you cannot say hey
whatever the clients are
connected to me just here's the message
like you're doing signalr
in grpc you need that those clients
contact you first and then you'll be
able to
uh to reply to them cool thank you
um chris says can you keep connections
open using bidirectional to get periodic
information like
progress on long-running tasks that's
that's very good uh yes you can can keep
the
uh the connection open but i don't
really know for how long
i will try this after the call because
it's very
it never crossed my mind
and uh so dan says when you're streaming
in grpc
with multiple requests made from either
server or client
does it leverage network sockets or are
they individual requests
similar kind of question i guess about
keeping connections open
uh yeah so it doesn't work uh it doesn't
use it uses http 2 and because of
how http 2 is it's uh it's done it's one
request
cool all right uh just knowing we've got
a couple of comments on
the audio so milo says we're mixing two
streams uh we'll fix that up there's a
whole bunch of different mics and there
were isolated audio systems we switched
to a different one
uh if it's still crackling i genuinely
have no idea why it would be doing that
but uh let's let's keep going
um so we've answered that one uh do you
have any developmental production
examples on how proto files are shared
or could be shared between applications
oh that's a very good question um maybe
with
i know the simplest thing that i can
think about is just copying when
deploying
you know and with ci cd adding a
different step in your uh
team simcity build or something like
that
you just need to take that file and to
make sure it's
near the client the server app that
you're
using cool all right proto files are
there for a long
period it weren't for that but they're
there
you said uh grpc was um open sourced in
uh what 2004 and in 2015 or something so
it's like 11 years
between open source and actually going
no we think 1.0
now do you think i think this is fine um
uh final final question uh grpc uses
less bandwidth than json but what about
latency would you also expect a lower
latency
not necessarily i don't think the
network latency has a lot of things to
do with how many data you are
transporting
it's just network so you just need to
bear in mind that if you transfer a lot
of data
the network latency might be there but
if you transport a small
piece of data also the networking
lattice might be there
so it's about consuming the customer's
data imagine what happens if you are in
the u.s
on a mobile network presumably also you
know a consideration there is is
if you need something to happen quickly
it's the data format you're using
optimized for being able to do that
yeah um you know zero latency or very
very low latency is no good if you're
sending 100 megabyte payload files
those kinds of things so uh we have one
more question
um which is uh dennis i mentioned i've
seen a previous presentation
where you mentioned messaging is ideal
for microservice communication
uh where would you use one over the
other so i guess this is a messaging
versus grpc question
yeah yeah yeah um in a lot of
technologies that
we're currently seeing or developing
with
uh we're seeing the versus part it
shouldn't be like
versus it should be like more case by
case approach
and we know that we have all these tools
we need to pick
the right tool for the job i mean in
some cases
grpc might work better even than http
client calls classical requests
but in bigger apps go to uh
to messaging because the messaging part
it comes with a lot of benefits
not one or the other it's taking and
improving the architecture
step by step i mean okay http clients
replace them maybe with grpc and as next
step maybe go to uh to messaging
let's do it gradually
cool um we have i think a question and
then an answer so how she said in the
youtube chat how many client connections
grpc
can handle and dustin said depends on
your web server stack otherwise it's
just normal http 2.
would you agree with that is that
versus go i do not know i think the go
question is a different question um
but uh yeah compare performance why did
you get any experience comparing
grpc and.net to go uh no
no i know kestrel is very very nice
sorry go ahead and detect benchmarks
and the latest ones i think yet again uh
dotnet is
up and running with gastrel on
serialization and text and everything
what i'd say to that is it's so easy to
build uh clients in dotnet and
in go just by running the protocol
buffer compiler try it
for yourself try it out see what happens
and then you don't have to take anyone's
word for it
so okay we are going to bring on
our next speaker thank you very much
irina for being part of nbc manchester
uh up next in a few minutes we are gonna
have steve sanderson
is joining us to talk about blazer let
me
just uh click the buttons and change the
layouts
and hello steve can you hear us
yes i can hear you magic and we can hear
you which is always a very promising
sign
um how are you doing i'm very good thank
you how are you
yeah all right we've been uh juggling
technology and streams and quizzes and
talks and prizes and generally having
the most fun you can have on a live
youtube stream
sounds great so you're uh talking to us
about blazer today i believe
i am yes yes it's the thing that i've
been mostly talking about for
quite some time now um yes a lot of
people seem to be interested in this
and there's lots of cool stuff to say so
yeah and something that blazes
something you were kind of instrumental
in making it happen i believe as well
yeah that's right way back in 2017 or
something i think it was um
yeah it did come out of a demo for an
ndc talk
way back then um is it true that it was
uh i wonder if i can compile c-sharp to
webassembly
and it sort of snowballed from there a
little bit that's absolutely yeah
yeah well i mean i i could see that web
assembly was a
looming on the horizon as a significant
force in the
in the way that web development would
evolve and so i of course as a
net developer very much wanted.net to be
part of that from the beginning
and um so yeah we were able to be one of
the first to build
a really substantial uh application
stack on webassembly
fantastic we have a couple of minutes
before the schedule time what else have
you been working on recently what's uh
what's interesting that's happening in
in your world now we all have all this
time on our hands
oh yeah there's the time yeah um no i've
mostly been working on asp.net stuff for
quite some time so
um yeah i've been there's lots of um new
features that come into play so in dot
net six that i've been
involved in uh doing lots of prototypes
and designs for
and there's also a demand from uh
developers to be able to target native
applications as well
so i've been looking at ways that we can
extend the ui
rendering to windows and mac and maybe
to ios and android
as well with a variety of different
rendering mechanisms
so yeah those have been my main my main
work focuses lately
and yeah hopefully i'll be able to show
some of that stuff
in the talk fantastic today all right
well let's order
a little ahead of schedule but it's
youtube we're live people are missing
can watch it back tomorrow
let's get started we will uh if you want
to start sharing your screen we'll
switch the preset across
which i believe will also clean up the
audio it looks like it's just this one
camera angle which is causing the chop
why that's happening i have no idea but
it will go away
in a second so let's put the focus on
you
uh welcome to nbc manchester blazer in
steve sanderson thank you all right then
so
yeah let's kick this thing off so if
anybody um for anybody who didn't see
the intro just now and if you're joining
us um
my name is steve and i i do work at
microsoft i'm on the asp.net
team and i have a particular focus on
blazer i have done for the last
few years and that's what i'll be
talking to you about today
now i know that many of the people who
are watching this will already know in
some detail what blazer is
and good news for you is this talk is
not an absolute beginner's talk i'm
going to largely assume that
most of the viewers know some of the
basic ideas
of what blazer is and we'll focus more
on what's coming
next and more advanced things but just
for anyone who's
absolutely new to this you should
probably watch a different video but hey
um that blizzard is a ui framework for
net that mainly targets web-based
rendering so it allows you to build the
kind of rich
interactive uis that you would
historically have built with
a javascript framework like react or
angular and allows you to write that
with net code and it follows a similar
sort of component oriented
programming model that is common in most
web application development
these days and we'll be looking at some
of the code uh that
illustrates that later in this talk but
the main focus of this talk is not to
introduce those basic concepts
it's to tell you about the overall state
of where we are with blazer on dot net
five
and where we're going in dot net six
i'll be demonstrating some features
that we will be shipping in dot net six
some of them are quite early prototypes
and um and i'll show you some cool stuff
that you can do on.net five
as well so the overall state for blazer
is that things are going very well
uh as a as a technology as a project um
blazer is
one of the fastest growing parts of net
at the moment
and we've got lots of uh a large
community that's given us lots of
feedback and it's that feedback that's
largely guiding
our plans for net six so most of the
stuff i'm going to show you today
is stuff that's directly come out of
things that people
have requested so let's have a look
at some of those things now i'm going to
start by um
turning off my video just because i want
to maximize the performance of my
machine here to make sure these demos go
better
and let's think about what's going to be
in this talk so as i've mentioned
uh i will be talking about some of the
things that you can do
in blazer on net 5 already some of the
slightly more advanced things that not
everybody knows about but another major
focus will be
talking about things that are in the
pipeline for dot net six
and uh like i said some of those will be
just
prototypes and in fact we will start
with one of those things just now so the
first thing i want to
be able to demonstrate to you is a
feature of
net six called hot reload and this is
something that
developers have asked us for a lot and
we are very excited to be able to
include
so you may know this from other
technology stacks the idea is that
this is about making your developer
experience more pleasant and more fluid
the idea is that when you make changes
to your application and you save those
changes
you just want to see them show up in
your browser straight away
you don't want to wait to recompile your
application you don't want to alt tab to
the browser you don't want to reload the
page
you don't want to do any of that stuff
you just want your changes to show up
by some magic and that is something that
we put a huge amount of work in
uh for donna 6 and this is not specific
to blazer this is a general.net 6
feature that will target various
different ui stacks
but the blazer team has been very
heavily involved in designing how this
should work
to make sure that it works really well
with blazer and i'm going to show you
that just now
but just to warn you what i'm showing
you is not the real implementation it's
actually going to be a prototype
and the prototype will almost certainly
crash probably several times
and when that happens we'll just not
worry about it we'll pretend it didn't
happen and carry on
um but the good news is that the real
implementation for hot reload is really
close
to being ready to show to our community
uh it's just not quite ready enough for
me to show you today so we will use the
prototype
and it's gonna crash probably all right
so let's have a look at this and i'm
going to show you this
in the context of two different
applications the first one may be a
little boring if you know
net if you know blazer already excuse me
um but just for anyone who's totally new
to blazer this is the thing that happens
when you create a new blazer project you
get this standard
starting point application that you see
over here on the right it's a kind of
dashboard kind of application it's got a
few different pages
it's got this page with a counter that
counts how many times you click a button
and it's got this page that demonstrates
how you can fetch some data
from a database or a back-end server and
render it in your page okay
so that's pretty familiar if you've seen
any blazer stuff before i will show you
a different application in a few minutes
but let's just start with this one so uh
let's see some of the code
that's in there we'll start with this
index component because like i said
blazer is a way of writing your rich
application uiwith.net code
rather than having to use javascript for
everything and so actually probably a
better example would be this counter
component here
remember it counts the number of times
you click and it does that by having a
mixture of some html markup
and some c-sharp logic here so the
c-sharp logic is just
incrementing a variable every time you
click and then that gets rendered into
the ui so pretty simple stuff
um the home page here index is another
example of that
now let's have a go at editing this and
we'll see if the hot reload
thing does something good so let's
change this to ndc manchester okay and
i'm going to hit the
save button up here in the ide and
because of hot reload i did not have to
recompile my application
didn't have to switch back to my browser
it just showed up in the browser within
about a second
so i'm going to hit save again on that
and you'll see it just
shows up and that's pretty nice now i'm
not limited to
making changes to html markup i can
change other things too for example
i will change this parameter that i'm
passing to a blazer component
like that and when i save that you'll
see that will of course just show up
and i can do more advanced things still
so let's say i want to add a new
component to this page
you'll remember the counter that i had
earlier um i can use that as a component
like this and i'm going to hit save now
and that will just pop up into my ui
straight away and it's not just static
markup
it's the real live thing so i can click
that and the count actually increases
and here's the best bit watch what
happens when i add another counter to
the page i'm going to hit save on that
now and of course another counter shows
up but the important thing is
we didn't lose the state in the first
counter this this in-memory state is
retained we're not throwing away your
application and restarting yet
we're patching your changes into the
existing running application
while it's there so that they just apply
uh while you're coding without you
losing the state
and that's really valuable and powerful
for reasons that you will see
later in this talk and also
we're not limited to just making changes
to a single file i could switch over to
this counter
component here and start changing some
stuff here so let's change some markup
i'm going to put
another copy of the current count just
because i can not for any good reason
really i'll hit save on that and of
course that's going to show up
and it will start working in the way you
expect i could also make changes to the
procedural
logic that i've got inside my code block
here so let's say i want it to go
up by units of 100
instead of just one okay so now next
time i click this button
you'll see that did i save that um it
will increase
by hundreds instead of single units like
that again retaining the state
of the application that we had
okay so that's working very nicely
you might be thinking okay that's good
as long as all the code that you enter
is valid what happens when i make a
mistake i'm just going to lose
everything presumably
well let's see what happens i'm going to
deliberately introduce a mistake into my
code
let's say i didn't realize what this
variable is actually called i think it's
called count even though it's not it's
called currentcount
so what happens when i hit save on that
invalid code now well what happens is i
get a nice little message just showing
up in the browser telling me what the
problem is
exactly which line and column it is and
of course that's consistent with what
the ide is telling me with the red
squigglies in the same place
so i can then fix my code and hit save
and the error will go away
and my application is still running it's
been running the whole time we didn't
lose any state
it's still there even when i make
mistakes and
correct them so that is pretty nice as a
developer experience
now there are some kind of changes that
we can't patch into the live application
and so we have a certain bit of fallback
logic that occurs in that case
so with the prototype one type of change
that i can't make
is class initializers like this so if i
hit save on that
the prototype doesn't know how to patch
that in so you see the screen has been
grayed out it's doing a fast rebuild and
then it's going to
restart my application automatically so
you'll see that the change has been
applied
but we did lose the state on this
occasion
so this particular limitation and not
being able to make this change
is actually a specific limitation of the
prototype the real thing can make that
change
but even with the real thing there are
certain types of changes that can't be
patched in and in those cases
we'll go through this fastapp restart
process
okay so that is the beginnings
of hot reload support but like i said i
want to show you
this in the context of a more
interesting application because
i know that many people have seen this
boring project template like a million
times by now
and you probably well if you're still
awake well done
we will switch over to uh a more
interesting application just now
so let me show you what i want the end
result of this application to be
and then we will build some parts of it
step by step so this is the end point
the kind of one i prepared earlier
target here which i'm just going to
bring up
in this separate little window it's
called blazer recording studios and you
see that it's a kind of booking
application for a fictional recording
studio
so we can see which artists are booked
in on which day and the idea is that
something like a receptionist would use
this so they can see who's booked in
and when people phone up to book a slot
they can add a new entry in or they can
edit the existing entries so for example
they can click on an entry they can
delete stuff and you'll see we've got
validation
and they can even do nice things like
drag and drop so they can just move
around
the bookings like that okay so that's
what we want to build
but we haven't got that yet or we'll
pretend that we haven't got it and we
will build some of that
making use of some of the hot reload
functionality
so the starting point we'll take is what
we've got here where it just says to do
we've got a header but we haven't really
got anything else so let's start adding
some stuff
into our application and i'm going to do
the rest of the demos in vs code
so i did the first demo in visual studio
and you saw that hot reload worked
really well there
and i want you to see that the
experience is also very good in vs code
now like i said i'm sure that it's going
to crash many times
but we just won't worry about that okay
so let's make sense of what the code of
this application looks like
i want to start by showing you the main
layout here you can see that the main
layout of the application
is it's got a header bar component at
the top which has got the title and the
buttons and so on and then it's got a
body and the contents of the body varies
according to which page you're on
so if i switch onto the about page i get
a different contents and if i come back
i'll get this to do message again
and the main page here is what comes
from a file called
index dot razer or actually i think i
called it mind
what did i call it completely forgotten
let's have a look at my pages
oh it's called home.razer okay great so
here's my home page
all right and you can see the contents
of that should hopefully look
recognizable down here it's just html
and it's got that message in it i've
also got this stuff up at the top where
i'm displaying this date picker button
that's this little thing here but don't
worry about that for now we'll come back
to that later
first let's just check that our hot
reload is working
correctly so if i change this text
then hopefully
that's going to just show up straight
away in my browser as i do it
so i want to build that list of bookings
grids do you remember what i just showed
you a minute ago we've got that long
list of dates
and for each one we'll display the
bookings that are on that date
and i'm going to do that using a for
each loop so i'm going to say for each
date in no var date in
dates okay so the dates is an array
that i've set up here of the next 200
days starting from today
okay so we're going to loop over the
next 200 days and i'm just going to
start by printing out the current date
so
assuming that hot reload works then
that's just going to drop all this
hideous stuff into the ui there it's
hard to make sense of so let's put
a paragraph tag in so we can see that a
little bit more
clearly all right so we've got our list
of dates
in there okay and now i i can use some
usual c sharp code to change how that
looks um oh
i've killed the intellisense so i'm just
going to bring that back up right so
let's have too long
date string okay hit save on that
and we'll get the dates coming up very
good
but i don't just want to display the
names of the days i want to display a
grid
that contains all of the bookings and
i've actually started creating a
component for that already
which is called bookings grid okay so
let's just
put in a copy of that right there so
when i save that
my pre prototype crashes which is not
surprising i warned you that this was
going to happen
so i'm just going to restart it and then
hopefully we will be able to make
slightly better progress so i apologize
for this and
you can just trust me that the real
implementation is this is not just going
to crash
every two minutes like it probably will
in this demo
okay so when that comes back up
hopefully we'll see the bookings grid
being displayed
come on back i know you're there
okay it's back all right so you can see
that for every single one it's just
saying january the first and that is
because i haven't passed the date into
it yet so we'll say
we'll pass the current date as a
parameter into the bookings grid
and then all being well that is going to
update
in the ui when the hot reload thing
finally wakes up
there we go all right so it's uh now
passing a separate date into each
instance
and in fact while we're here i'm just
going to pass the other parameters that
i need to pass
into my um bookings grid so i'm passing
a list of rooms that you can book which
i fetch from a database
and a callback that can occur when you
make an
edit okay so now let's go and have a
look at the contents of this bookings
grid
so another cool thing that you might not
know if you do if you hover
and do a control click on a tag name it
will take you
directly to that particular component
and you can see that the contents
of my bookings grid are basically we're
just displaying the current date so
that's what's there
and i could add more stuff to that like
that and then hopefully
that little message is going to start
showing up in the ui
and it does okay so let's now display
a list of the dates and time of the
times and slots that are available for
booking
on a given date and of course you don't
want to wait for me to type this stuff
out so i am just going to put in
the um initial bookings grid
like this all right so i'm looping over
all the rooms that are available for
booking
and for each one of them once again it's
crashed we won't worry about it
um for each one of them we are going to
display the name of the room that you
can book
and then underneath that we're going to
display the rows for each of the things
for each of the bookings okay so
just so that we don't have to keep
waiting for this to restart each time it
crashes
i'm going to perhaps uh skip this little
bit ahead slightly
and i'm going to just quickly drop in
all of the code
that's going to display um for each of
the days so you can see we're displaying
um the rooms that are available for
booking
and then underneath that we're going to
have a loop over all the hours that are
available
and we'll display the the
the name of the hour so let's see what's
going on here
and hopefully that will update
maybe i shouldn't be demonstrating
prototype stuff this early it's
not going super well right now um i'm
just going to drop in a bit more code
that finishes this section of the demo
off so that we can move on
to some bit that won't continually fail
like this so what i'm doing
now is i'm saying that for each of
the
rooms i'm going to find any bookings
that are available in that room
and then i'm going to display all the
slots
that are available and the bookings that
are in there i'm just going to restart
this because i'm tired of
waiting for this to fail
okay all right so hopefully
this makes sense to you we're looping
over all of the hours and for each hour
we'll loop over all the rooms
and then within that we'll find any
bookings that are available in the
current slot
and we'll display the entry for that and
if this thing comes back up then we will
be able to see that
showing up in the browser so here it
comes
about now there we go all right finally
right i think we're through the the
worst of the random crashing and
hopefully the rest of the
the demos are going to work fine now all
right so we
have been able to build this bit of the
ui using what would have been a very
fluid experience
if the hot reload prototype had been
working correctly but let's move on and
talk about
a slightly different feature which is
scoped css and it ties in with hot
reload a little bit
so how do we create the styling for our
blazer
components well the way that you would
have done it traditionally on.net 3 is
basically just create one giant css file
and dump all of your stuff in there and
that's not such a friendly
developer experience so a thing that we
added as an improvement in dot net 5
is the ability to create separate css
files for each one
of your components and i can show you
that uh
in here if we have a look you'll see
that for each one of
my components i can optionally add a
razer.css file
which will contain the styles that are
specific to that component
so that's good in that one you've got an
ability to distribute your styles over
multiple files
but the other good thing about it is
that these are isolated styles
so the framework guarantees to ensure
that the styles from each file
only affect that component they don't
affect any other even if
they've got the same css class names in
them so as an example of that if i look
at the
bookings grid file you'll see that the
css in there
has got really simple class names like
name reason and slot and so on
and i don't have to worry about those
clashing with other css files
because like i said these are isolated
css files the framework guarantees to
make them not clash
by means of a fancy rewriting thing that
it does at compile time
so let's have a go at editing this a
little bit shall we i'm going to have a
look at the
style file for my main layout which is
quite simple you'll see that it defines
some properties that apply to all the
other css files
and let's try changing this theme color
shall we let's see
how about we have a nice red theme and
i'm going to press save
and because of hot reload instantly
those changes will just show up in the
browser and i can see that
the red theme looks absolutely
disgusting so let's try something else
um purple that's kind of rock and roll
isn't it so let's try that
and that also looks hideous so i'm going
to switch back to the yellow that we had
before
but anyway the point of this is just to
show you that i can make these changes
and they will be applied live via hot
reload
now another example of why this is
valuable is
uh to do with the state preservation so
let me show you an example of why this
matters
let's say i want to work on the
validation feature
in my application so i'm going to create
a validation error
like this okay so i'm glad that's good
i'm glad that the validation error has
come up
but what's bad about this is that the
styling is kind of disgusting like
i hate this horrible red box it looks
completely wrong this is just the
default styling that blazer uses for
invalid text boxes
now if i wanted to fix that
traditionally i would go to my css and
change it but then i would also have to
recompile my application
switch back to the browser reload the
page find the item that i was editing
click on it open the editor
recreate the validation error and only
then would i see whether my css change
had actually
worked in the right way that's highly
inefficient
but thankfully with hot reload we don't
have to go through all that anymore
so i can now have this validation error
on the screen here
i can go to my scoped css file that
affects
the form fields and i'll add a little
bit of css to it so i'm going to create
some css that applies to invalid things
and i'm just going to say i want the
outline to be none and then when i hit
save on that
you'll see the outline instantly
disappears i didn't have to click
through the ui to get back into this
state again
let's say i do want the border color
to be red to highlight the fact that
it's invalid but you know that border is
only on the bottom so that looks a lot
better
and because this is such a fluid
experience i can now incrementally try
out like different
sizings for things step by step until
i'm exactly happy with it
and um and i didn't have to wait through
any recompile processes
while i was doing that so that's scoped
css
and how it can be tied in with the hot
reload system
okay so let's move on and talk about
another thing
and i'm going to show you another thing
that's in.5 that not everyone has
started using yet
and it's a performance feature called
virtualization
and this is ui virtualization where we
only render certain parts of the ui that
are actually visible to the user
so why would this make a difference
let's have a look
at what's going on in the application as
it is
already so as you can hopefully see
there's quite a lot of stuff
on the screen as i scroll there's
absolutely
tons of stuff that's there in the
browser
so how much data have we sent to the
browser and how many database queries
did we have to do
in order to do that well let's have a
look at the initial html that's in this
page right now
um the html is absolutely giant it goes
on for
thousands of lines and the browser
struggles to even render
that much html source code and it seems
to have just kind of hung at the moment
i'm slightly concerned the browser is
going to crash
because there's just so much stuff in
there and another way to visualize how
much stuff is in there is to count the
number
of dom elements so if i do that i'm
going to
do a query selector to count all of the
elements in the page and you'll see
there's nearly 10
000 elements in there and that's really
pushing up
against the limits of what's going to
perform well in a browser so why is that
why is it sending so much stuff to the
browser well let's go back to this home
page
and look at the logic that we created
there earlier okay
so you will see that what it's doing
because we did this ourselves is it
loops over all the dates in the next 200
days and for every single one of them
it creates a booking grid and each one
of those bookings grids
itself does a separate call to get data
from the database
and then it's just going to send all of
that stuff down to the client so we're
basically querying the entire database
and sending it all into the browser
which is just outrageously inefficient i
don't like that
at all so what can we do about that well
in dot net 3 you had to write your own
application logic
if you wanted to do something more
efficient than that but with net five we
have
a feature called virtualization which
i'm going to use right now
i'm going to go into my bookings grid
and i'm going to add a reference
to the virtualization component in fact
i'm just going to drop in
the one that i've already got in my
snippets because i've got a few
parameters
that i want to pass to that um so
waiting for vs code to catch up here
just being strangely slow all right i'll
type it out myself
um the fiest code has got super confused
and almost completely died right now
and my hot reload prototype has tied one
more time
so let's restart that
seem to have pretty much lost
this completely i'm going to restart vs
code completely because
the prototype that i'm doing looks like
it's
utterly killed it which is fun love
showing prototypes
let's bring that back up
okay get that going again
right then so where were we okay so we
want to wrap our bookings grid
in the virtualized component
which is going to be around here
somewhere
come on vs code you can do this
this is really abnormal
might be that sheer overhead of running
screen share or something but i don't
think i've ever seen
actually failed to even load the
snippets i will copy them manually
this is um cool so all right so this is
what i wanted
uh vs code to insert a copy of the
virtualized component which is wired up
to loop over all the dates that are
available in the next 200 days
and for each one of them it's going to
render the bookings grid
but only the ones that are actually on
the screen at the moment
instead of all of them so let's see what
the effect of doing that
actually is so when my application comes
up
now hopefully it behaves exactly the
same
as far as the end user is concerned they
can still see all the stuff they can
still scroll as far as they want
but if we look at the initial markup
that we're sending down to the browser
it's still the same because it didn't
apply the changes yet
cool what it's going to do is it's going
to
only render the specific stuff that is
available that is visible on the screen
at the moment
and then we will not have to do database
queries for all the other stuff
they will just be fetched on demand
while we are walking
through the ui okay so let's see
if this is ready to appear yet
should be about now
okay so if we look at the initial markup
now you'll see it's way smaller than
before it's only 40 lines rather than
many thousands of lines if we look at
the number of dom elements that's in the
page it's now only 408
compared with the like 10 000 that we
had before but the end user experience
is still just
indistinguishable you know i can still
scroll to any point that i want
it will just fetch render and display
all of this stuff
on demand as the user is scrolling
okay so that's the virtualization
feature all right
next thing that we will look at we will
have a look at
the ability to dynamically load
javascript so why would you do that
the whole point of blazer is to be able
to write as much of your application to
uilogic
in net code and try not to have to use
so much javascript
but if you are rendering stuff into a
browser inevitably there will still be
times when you want to make calls into
javascript
it might be because you're using native
browser javascript apis that aren't
available in.net or it might be because
you're using third-party
javascript components and i'm going to
show you examples of both of those
just now so if we go back to the
application
i'm going to show you an example of
using a native browser api
and it's this date picker up here so
you'll see if i pick a specific date
from here like may the first
um it will jump directly to may the
first as you'd expect
okay and the way it actually did that is
it moved the browser scroll bar for me
to the correct position
and then the virtualization component
kicks in to fetch and render the right
data
but how do we move the browser scroll
bar from netcode there isn't a dotnet
api for that
we need to call javascript well the way
you would do that traditionally on
net three is that you would have to load
all the javascript libraries you want to
use
upfront by adding script tags into the
host page
and then you would have to make all of
them available in the global scope
like as global variables and then you
would be able to call them from.net and
that's fine it works
but we've got a better way of doing it
with net5 where we can load javascript
dynamically on demand
and we don't have to pollute the global
scope i can show you that
down here so here is the what happens
when you pick a date
from that date picker we call this.net
method scroll to date
and it's going to find out which entry
it is that you wanted to go to
and then it's going to dynamically load
some javascript that it can use to get
there it only actually has to load it
once up front because
at one time because it gets cached after
that but it is dynamic on the first time
so it's kind of like lazy loading
and what we're doing is we're saying to
the dot net code we want you to invoke
some javascript asynchronously
and get back a reference to a javascript
object the javascript object is will be
the result of doing a dynamic import
for a file called scroller.js now if you
didn't know
javascript has had the ability for
several years now to do these dynamic
imports using the import keyword
where it fetches modules and modules can
export specific functions and they can
import other modules and so on and the
browser resolves all that
and that's what we're doing here so what
is this scroller.js file well i'll show
you
it's very simple all it does is it
exports a simple javascript function
which takes the element that we want to
scroll and what proportion of the way
through
we want it to scroll and then it just
does javascript stuff
and we can call that export here when
we've loaded the module
we can call the scroll to we can pass a
reference to the dom element we want it
to scroll and then how far we want it to
scroll
and that's exactly how this thing worked
just now
so now we know about this technique
let's have a go at using it ourselves
to implement drag and drop all right so
drag and drop sounds kind of advanced
but
it's not really it's quite easy to do so
let's see what's the scenario
let's change this a little bit i want my
name to be in here because i like to be
involved in things
so let's say that i've got a booking at
9am today
and i phone up the studio and say hey
i've got a booking today but i really
want to be in the new studio too because
it's way cooler can you please move me
the receptionist will look and say well
we do have jz booked in at that time but
but honestly steve you're a way more
important customer so obviously we're
going to bump jay-z out and let you move
in
and they want you to they want to be
able to just kind of drag and drop this
thing across there but they can't yeah
because we haven't got
drag and drop implemented now let's use
a little bit of javascript to get drag
and drop support
and we're going to do that using the
same technique that we did before
where we'll dynamically load a
javascript library
and i'm going to do that by dropping in
a little bit
of stuff i've prepared so we will use
the same technique
to import a file called calendardrag.js
and then we're going to call this method
enable drag drop on it now we as well as
passing a reference to a dom element we
also need to pass a reference
to a javascript to a net object on this
occasion
because after the user has dropped we
need javascript to make a call back into
net and say hey you need to do something
because the user's just done a drag job
so how can javascript call.net well we
can do that
by passing a reference to this object we
can use
net object reference create to get a
reference to this
and then i can send that into javascript
okay now you're probably wondering
what's in this calendar drag js file
so let's have a look in that and it's
slightly more involved than the other
one that we just had a minute ago
but it uses this third-party library
called draggable to make things
draggable and droppable
so we configure it in a few ways we say
these kinds of things can be dragged
they can be dropped into these kinds of
elements
we configure it in various other ways
and when the user
finishes dropping we'll check did we get
past a component instance that's the dot
net object
if we did we'll make a method call to it
in order to have it actually
perform the drop okay so let's see if
that actually works
so i need my changes to be applied and i
do not trust this prototype one little
bit anymore
because it's been going wrong all the
time today
let's see is it working yet it is not
i'm gonna have to restart it
one more time all right so once that
is back we will be able to move our
objects around
and and hopefully they will actually get
saved in the database
when they are dropped there so hopefully
you can see that it's quite convenient
to be able to import
javascript modules like this and the
javascript module can export whatever
functions they want
and then we can easily invoke them
from.net
code all right so here that comes back
up and now i can move jay-z down there i
can move steve across there
and hopefully that change has really
taken effect so if i reload the page you
can see
that the state is correct it's really
over there
all right so what else should we talk
about let's talk about another
net six feature error boundaries so what
happens
when there is an unhandled exception in
your application
well the way things work on dot net five
is that if there's an unhandled
exception
then we automatically shut down the
connection for that particular user and
that's quite important for
stability and security uh because if an
unhandled error has occurred
then we don't know what state your
application has been left in we don't
know what state the framework itself has
been left in
and so we in order to protect the
security of your server have to stop
that user
doing any further interactions within
the context of that connection
and that's fine it's fairly similar to
how say mvc deals with errors
but some developers have said they
really want a more
fine-grained way of dealing with errors
they want a way of localizing
uh errors to a particular part of the ui
so that they can provide a more of a
custom
experience for responding to errors and
i'm going to show you an example of how
we can do this
right now so i want to have an unhandled
error
so to do that i'm going to find a
particular data item i'm going to
pretend it causes a problem
so if we look along then we can see that
okay so there's a booking here on april
5th by madonna
and i'm going to say that whenever we
see this record by madonna let's just
imagine it triggers an exception for
some reason like i don't know why
but we'll just pretend there's something
bad about that data and it causes a
problem
and to simulate that i will drop in a
little bit of code
to my rendering logic here so um i'll
say
if there's a booking with the name of
madonna
then we are going to trigger an
unhandled
exception okay so i've saved that and
you'll see an unhandled exception has
occurred
all right now uh if i come back and
reload
then when i'm at the top of the page
you'll see there's no exception
because of virtualization we haven't
loaded madonna yet but as we start
scrolling
eventually we'll have to load the
madonna record and at that point the
unhandled exception occurs
all right and when the unhandled
exception occurs uh we can't interact
with this
application anymore i'm clicking on
these things and nothing happens
i'm clicking on this hamburger menu
nothing happens
just because the whole connection has
been shut down in order to protect the
server's
stability okay but using error
boundaries
we can change how this works so i'm
going to go to my home screen here
and i'm going to put an error boundary
around this whole page
okay so let's put error boundary around
this
and i'll drop the end point in there
okay so i'll save that change
and then i'll come back and i will hit
reload
and we will just take a gamble on
whether the hot really
reload prototype has actually done that
properly it
looks like it maybe has
all right good it has right so now when
i'm at the top of the page there's no
error but as i start scrolling down
then at some point we'll load the
madonna record and at that point instead
of shutting down the entire connection
we just shut down this part of the ui so
this sub tree within the ui
is now gone there is no bookings list
anymore but the rest of the application
is still there
this button works i can navigate away i
can navigate back
and everything continues working except
if we see the bad data at which point we
shut down that part of the ui
so we can change this to do even more
fine-grained error handling if we want
to
for example let's say i'll remove the
error boundary from here
and i'll have a different error boundary
inside my virtualized component so all
this stuff composes together nicely
so now every single bookings grid is its
own separate
error boundary so when that reloads then
i will be able to uh see a slight change
of behavior
in the application right so now this
time when i scroll down
instead of shutting down the whole page
hopefully we'll just see
a single entry in the list has been
replaced with this error message
okay so that particular day can't be
seen anymore but the rest of the day
are all there and everything is still
fully functional
so what's the point of all this and how
should you use error boundaries well
should you put an error boundary around
every single component in your
application so that every single thing
can fail
independently will that make it more
robust well i would say that's probably
not something you should do what you as
a developer need to do
is design a user experience that makes
sense in some way
it doesn't really make sense for an
individual button to shut down on its
own um
because it might be that the user can't
productively use the rest of the page
when that button's gone so as a
developer you need to design
a system where things shut down in a way
that makes sense to the user so maybe
you should have per page error handling
maybe there's a certain type of
component that like it's a third-party
component and
and you know it fails sometimes and you
can't stop that so you're just going to
put a boundary around that one thing
it's up to you the point of it is that
you as a developer get to control that
now
and you control the exact granularity of
error handling
within your application okay so there's
many other things that we're planning
for.net six that i won't have time to
talk to you about
the biggest one is probably ahead of
time compilation so
that is another performance feature and
that's specifically for running on
web assembly so with dotnet 5 when
you're running on webassembly
your.net code is running on an
interpreter within the webassembly world
and that is fast enough for many kinds
of applications
it's fast enough to build very large
sophisticated uis you can have grids
with thousands of rows or whatever the
interpreters fast enough for that
that's great but it's not fast enough
for intense cpu
specific code so if you were trying to
do something like
image processing or machine learning or
something like that
that wouldn't really be a very good idea
on the interpreter
but with aot compilation we can
translate your.net code
ahead of time into pure native uh
webassembly bytecode which then gets jit
compiled by the browser
and it can run at something much closer
to native speed
within the browser and at that point you
genuinely can do
image processing or machine learning or
whatever you like inside the browser so
that's a really exciting feature
and we're very close to being able to
show that that's
we're going to have the first version of
that that you can use in the dot net 6
preview 3 release
which is coming in a few weeks i just
couldn't show you today
because it's not quite ready enough okay
the other biggest feature that we're
including in
net six is support for desktop
applications and we're particularly
focused on
windows and mac for that because that's
what most of
our developers have told us they're
interested in doing and i've actually
shown you that already
although i didn't mention it so when i
started up this application from my
taskbar before and it popped up in a
little window on its own
that's actually a native windows
application it's using web-based
rendering and it's obviously sharing
code
with the rest of my blazer recording
studios application
uh the point of this is that if you need
to create a windows or mac
application and reuse your existing
blazer and web development skills
then you can do that it's quite a lot
like building an electron application
but without having to bundle a browser
or node into your application
so that's something a lot of customers
have told us that they want to be able
to do
and it's not running on webassembly it's
not running on server
it is running natively on the operating
system so you can access the local file
system and
do whatever else you want to with the
operating system there
okay so last few things we've got some
advantages to the improvements to the
component programming model
such as the ability to do pause and
resume and transfer state
between server and client i can't really
get into too much details about that
because i'm running out of time
and we've got various improvements to
the component programming model so for
example
you can define your own custom events
and custom event arguments now that's a
new thing
you can mark parameters as being
required on certain components
and we've got this advanced feature
where child components can automatically
inherit generic types from their parents
and that's useful when you're creating a
suite of related components for example
if you've got a grid with columns inside
it or tabs
or like a tab set with tabs inside them
and you want to
have generic types flowing down there
it's a bit more of an advanced feature
but
the overall point is that the
programming model is getting more
sophisticated in dot net six
and specifically that we're filling in
the gaps that developers have told us
that they must care about so that's all
i'm going to have time
to show you just now if you want to get
started with blazer
and you're new to this then go to
blazer.net you'll find guides on what to
download
you'll see some introductory tutorials
and all kinds of useful information
and if you want the code from this talk
the
blazer recording studio app then you can
go to the url that you can see there
and you can try it out yourself now the
download there does not include the hot
reload prototype which
given how it's performed today you
probably uh aren't going to feel too
much of a loss off
but if you are very excited about hot
reload then the great news is that the
real implementation of that is extremely
close
to being ready and we are planning to
include the first version of that
in the 0.86 preview release which is
coming in just a few weeks so that's
very exciting
i'm looking forward to being able to
show that for real
so that's all i have time to show you
now and i'm gonna
hand back over to dylan and we'll see if
we've got any questions and i'll
put my face back up on the screen now
okay so back to you done
fantastic thank you steve um
there are comments in the youtube chat
saying that you just won nbc
there was some some really really
excellent stuff in that really really
great talk there are a couple of
questions
um there is now a flurry of questions we
have a couple in slider that have been
upvoted so uh
um neil barnwell wants to know is it a
possible slash practical attachment
to take an mvvm style approach to blazer
apps
for those things that aren't purely
about rendering the ui
um yeah so um with mvvm one of the
the core ideas is being able to trigger
uh updates of things from your
from your view models so you you would
create a set of new models that have got
things
like i notified property changed and
things like that on them you can
absolutely wire that
into blazer you can it's not very
difficult i keep thinking i should write
a blog post about this
um you can absolutely um just subscribe
to the notified property
changed events and and use that to
trigger updates
inside blazer and in terms of how you
distribute the
logic of your application across models
and view models and
and your ui components that's completely
up to you blazer has no opinion about
that
you can structure your code in any way
you want for that kind of thing
so yeah fantastic um question which just
says thanks for doing this we appreciate
seeing the prototype
cool it didn't crash as much before when
i was
when i practiced this it crashed like
twice or something it is
um but seeing you know work in progress
from someone who's actually working on
the next iteration of blazer
is a really really interesting insight
into the sort of you know don't touch
that that's a rough edge this doesn't
work this will be different but
yeah um but the real hot reloading is so
awesome now i genuinely saw the
i got the kind of like full end-to-end
experience of it from
um some of the other engineers in our
group last night about
like about 7pm that was the first time
that i've like experienced the full end
to end
of it and so that's why it was too late
for me to show you that today
and it is so fast i could not believe
how fast it was
that you press the save button and
before your finger even starts moving
back up it's already
updated in the ui now i've seen hot
reload on other technologies like
fluttering in webpack and so on
and they tend to take about one second
two seconds to update
the one we've got coming is so fast it's
so fast we're thinking of doing it in
real time while you're typing
i'm really impressed with that fantastic
uh
question can you deploy blazer apps to
android and ios
um so yeah so if you want to use the um
there's so many different ways you could
do that right so one way you could do it
is you could create a pwa which is going
to run
inside the normal browser and you can
be installed onto the home screen and
can run on webassembly
another way you could do it is you could
take a web assembly app and wrap it up
in something like cordova
and you could drop that into the google
play store or the ios app store
if you want to another way you can do it
is you could
use the technologies that are coming
in.net 6
which would i just showed you a native
windows app
just now now that's built on something
called.net maui which is the
multi-platform application user
interface stack which is new
in dotnet six and that supports windows
mac ios
and android so um although we're not
massively focused on ios and android for
web
rendering scenarios we're not doing
anything to stop you so
you could absolutely deploy to the app
store that way
and then finally if you didn't want to
do web based running at all you wanted
to render native
um android ui elements with not html
using the blazer programming model we
have an experimental project called
blazer mobile bindings or mobile blazer
bindings no one knows because
it's such a terrible name we can't
remember what order the word's going
if you look that up then you will see a
way of creating native ui elements
for ios and android and other ui
platforms but that's just experimental
fantastic um question from uh ivan
will sas and less be supported in scoped
css
sas unless yes so you can already do sas
unless for scope css
as long as you do the work to make it
work yourself so now that's a bit of a
terror client so like
yes you can do it just write the code
yourself draw the rest of the owl you
know that
so um it's not that bad though so
imagine that you add a little bit
of ms build stuff that says each time
the application builds
i'm going to shell out to whatever it is
that converts
less into css or sas into css and as
long as that happens before the dot-net
compile happens
then the whole thing is just going to
work like because as far as dot-net is
concerned we see that there's a css file
we'll bundle it with the normal scoped
stuff so yeah you can absolutely
do it yourself you have to write a
little bit of build logic we're not
really planning to to
create a feature for that ourselves
because the state of
um javascript build systems is
constantly churning and
you know we've been burned with that in
the past we kind of would rather have
tutorials and blog posts and
documentation on how to do it
then making it a native feature i gotta
say i might get some uh some shade for
saying this on the internet
but sass and less are now too important
to be entrusted to javascript build
systems
yeah um no i love them i think they're
fantastic and i've used them in various
ways
in.net um the question in the the
youtube chat
uh can we manipulate i think the
question's saying can we manipulate the
dom in c-sharp so that we can eliminate
javascript completely
um right so blazers programming model is
not
oriented around the idea that you're
just going to do like get element by id
and set text content and things like
that you can we're not stopping you from
doing it but
blazer is like other spa frameworks in
that in order to do
efficient ui updates it needs to be in
control of the ui it needs to know what
the state of the ui was before
in order that the diffing algorithm
knows how to update stuff
so if you just start messing with the
dom directly then blazer won't know that
you've done that and the different
algorithm may not be able to update your
ui anymore
that's not a limitation specific to
blazer the same thing happens in react
in vue in angular in all of these kind
of diff based
ui frameworks they all want you to not
mess with the dom directly
but still we're not stopping you from
doing it you can use javascript
interrupt to do that directly
if you want to you can create your own
library of c-sharp
helper functions that contain all
wrappers for all the javascript things
like get element by id
and set css class name and all that kind
of stuff
you can do it i don't particularly
recommend it because then you'll lose
some of the benefits
of the the diff based update system but
you know
have fun if you want to do it it is i
think worth saying the
the front-end web development community
as a whole has spent a lot of time
trying to get away from things like get
element by id
and react is a is another very good
example of the declarative model you
don't tell the browser how to do it you
tell it what you want and you let the
other claims figure
fantastic stuff uh yes thank you so much
uh steve
for joining us there's some really
really exciting interesting stuff i'm
looking at going i have to host a
conference for the rest of the day and i
want to go
ahead and start playing with that stuff
now so that was really really
cool thank you so much for joining us uh
we are going to take a short break
here from some of our sponsors now let
me switch back
there we go right that's it that's nice
that's lovely
hello hello hello uh yeah there are some
some
3d transformation filters in obs
which we've used to set up some of the
virtual studio angles um
and it appears that some of them make
the audio go choppy if two people are
talking
uh which is one and they only do it on
youtube they don't do it on the
monitoring loop uh there are so many
just fascinating things about the whole
streaming setup you know the amount of
technology that has to work for this is
is phenomenal let's get our next speaker
in
so i'm gonna welcome here uh to the ndc
studio um
[Laughter]
just looking at the comments in the chat
the most used term of 2020 you're on
mute
you're on mute can you hear me let's do
this i'm not a cat can we do this for
real um
hello heather how are you doing hello
i'm doing very well it's so nice to be
back in an ndc
event nice to see you welcome let me
just
uh sort out the the things and the
things and switch the angle here
and there we go we are live
live on the internet um
so in a few moments you are going to be
talking to us about the
the care and feeding of developers
um which is cool it's a it's a talk that
i've seen before it's one that i like
very much
uh what else is going on in your world
heather
oh goodness well yeah i'm here in kansas
city as you can see by the skyline
behind me
and um i've been doing so many
different kinds of things for my work
because you know i work for octa
and on my own i actually
just bought a house here so it's a
really big deal
to finally have my own big studio
kind of area so i'm looking forward to
everybody giving me suggestions of how
they built out their studio in the
comments section somewhere
or you can always ping me on twitter but
i am very excited
about finally being a first-time
homeowner i never thought it would
happen
but luckily being in tech allowed it to
happen so if you if you'd said to me two
years ago that the main reason i wanted
to own a house is so i could actually
paint the walls green
i would have thought you were joking but
now i'm like if i owned this place i
literally would be painting the walls
and that would be my green screen set up
so
oh absolutely because i i don't know if
anybody knows this but i'm an
avid beat saber player and i kind of
want to do the green screen of me
playing while you watch what i'm
actually hitting behind me
and in order to do that kind of setup
you really need like a
full wall to floor experience for that
uh so i see a lot of painting in my
future
uh lee says in the chat of the chief's
going to get to the super bowl this year
are they going to get the super bowl
back you know
i have a lot of faith in our in our
hometown teams i mean who wouldn't
i'm actually not a sportsball person at
all so but
when you live here it is impossible not
to want to root
for the people who are coming from
behind we've had
lots of ups and downs as a team in the
city
but i have faith because that's that
thing is like even if you don't care
about sports
if the hometown team are winning
everyone's happy and it's just a nice
place to be
so yeah yeah i've noticed this a couple
of times
uh right we have about five minutes we
are going to hear very quickly from some
of our sponsors while we get heather's
stream set up and ready to go and
everything
i i just want to give a shout out to
insight investments some of our sponsors
are
over on the the expo some of our
sponsors
are gonna be hearing from them in a
second when we run the reel
inside investments big supporters of ndc
lovely people and they said no it's fine
just give us a shout out so thank you
insight investments
we really really appreciate your support
thank you for being part of it
uh here's a quick word from our sponsors
we will be back in a few minutes
right
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
at ivendi we build technology that makes
it easier for dealers to sell
and consumers to buy vehicles
so what ibendy does is we build a
platform that facilitates online
retailing
this means that we basically make it
easier for people to buy cars and for
dealers to sell them
we do this from end to end
so the full journey from people
consumers coming to the site
right through to the finance
applications that go through so to
facilitate that we have really important
relationships with banks
with vehicle manufacturers and with
vehicle retailers themselves the tech
stack we use is mainly aws and we use
csharp.net as our predominant backend
language
and we use a little bit of azure as well
we deploy most of the stuff
in containers using kubernetes on eks
and we're a big fan of event sourcing
here that helps us to separate the
domains
out into separate areas which allows us
to
keep those domains nice and segregated
and also facilitates the auditing which
is a big part of us working in a
regulated environment
i chose ivendi mainly because of the
people they're very welcoming they're
really knowledgeable and seem really
passionate about the technology and the
quality of the products that they're
[Applause]
[Music]
creating
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to my go we're an
airport-centric travel company owned by
mark the country's largest airport group
most importantly we're a globally unique
digital tech business based right here
in manchester
we operate as an innovation hub a truly
agile e-commerce business driven by
data and the latest tech to provide
airports across the world with a unique
blend of products
technologies and services for their
passengers we have become synonymous
with airport customer ecommerce
platforms which were constantly evolving
if you plan to fly again in the near
future you may well use our system
without realizing that it's actually a
mago product
we're a business for someone who wants
to create and do something a bit
different
for the techies we have a fail fast cicd
approach using.net core at the back
view and react to the front and aws
cloud hosting expect to grow our team
over the coming year so please keep an
eye on our mago linkedin page for the
latest jobs thank you
[Music]
so we're going to talk a little bit
about what it's like
to take care of our
engineers now i know it's not something
that everybody is necessarily
used to bringing up but if you
ever have any sort of aspirations
for becoming a lead a manager
or even a cto this is stuff that
everybody needs to talk about
and know
so the first thing i want you to think
about is how you got here
let's say you are at the top of your
game you know code just flows through
you
as if by breathing you know and you've
climbed
your way up in the programming world so
it starts to somewhat make sense now
after the
long journey you've had that you are
happy and tranquil in
what you can provide but do you actually
remember how you felt when it all began
let's talk about you i can safely assume
that you
are competent and worthy of being here
you have paid your dues and worked your
way up
through your skill set so
when i first started down this road i i
think
i didn't really have an appreciation
at least at the five-year mark for how
far i'd actually come
in the beginning i was fairly frustrated
do you remember that frustration of
trying to figure out
a new concept without any context to
build on whatsoever the hours that
you would spend trying to decipher what
programming even was
and sometimes i personally began to
wonder if i had enough space in my brain
to figure it all out a very
wise woman once told me heather darling
not one of us was born to this world
naturally coding
and sometimes i think we forget that
when we talk about natural talent in the
space
please remember that you were the person
on your team that you struggle with
at every stage of your growth so before
you become
a little bit too impatient on stack
overflow with somebody asking a stupid
question
consider that you asked a lot of stupid
questions in the beginning
do you remember how you felt when you
figured it out i remember the first time
that i i
did anything with a console app
right i think it was a magic 8 ball
program
it was the first thing that we got to
build in our boot camp and
i remember when i got it working i felt
like i was a wizard and that's not
an exaggeration i literally jumped up
and i was like yes
and everybody in the class kind of
turned and looked at me
and i'm still kind of the weirdo in the
group now
um but i want you to try and think back
to that first day it's usually
a lasting impression on why we even
started programming in the first place
so now you're a junior developer and you
are excited because
you figure something out and you think
this career could be for you
so after you work for a little while
just discovering the new
things let's say you become a co-worker
on a team of software engineers right
now that's a little different because
before your coping skills
was all about how you personally learned
things and how you personally
produced things but once you're on a
team you have to learn how to
communicate
to others and you instantaneously
started discovering that hey you know
maybe i know a little bit more than this
one
to my left a little less than this one
to my right
and you have to learn how to
become valuable this is kind of when
you're in that
oh middle ground of
figuring out how much value you can
really provide a company
this is the middle lever level developer
the mid-level developer
now some of the things that you thought
your life
would be like um is not at all
resembling
uh some of the movies that you've
watched i remember i
thought you know that i want to be a lot
more like neo in the matrix
than you know somebody who feels like
they were stranded on the island trying
to figure out how to make fire
but this is a good chunk of your
valuable years to companies
because you aren't paid a whole lot
yet but you provide a lot more value
than somebody who's completely learning
so you've done this for a little while
and now you're starting to feel pretty
good about some things you got some
opinions
you like to chime in on social media
about
how you feel about certain frameworks
coming out or
certain ways apps are built and you're
feeling pretty good
you don't have to wonder if somebody is
a senior developer because
it's like a vegan or a crossfit person
they will tell you
unfortunately a lot of people in this
space uh
like to talk about themselves that way
to kind of prove themselves sometimes
the way they will prove themselves
is to kind of bully others sometimes
without knowing it
but mostly um it's just to justify
you know their job or where they are
and their value in the community all of
this
is due to insecurity and as a leader
and somebody who's an aspiring leader
it's important for you to understand
that seniors may
feel or senior level developers may feel
like they are your peers
and in certain instances they could have
some knowledge
that might be on par with you but where
they are
in their career is very different from
where you are
and it's important to understand that
this is kind of where a lot of
separation
occurs some
seniors are the ones who seem overly
confident
and are not afraid to say that you're
wrong and they are right
but that again is a lot due to
insecurity
that's how they experience it other
seniors
may feel completely differently
they may have been given this role as a
senior
but they feel like they don't deserve it
and that's a little bit more on par with
my experience going up through the ranks
into being becoming a senior developer
so for me i didn't actually feel senior
and i was just given that title because
i didn't feel i had
worked 20 years in the industry but that
isn't always the way that it works when
it comes to
how companies decide to hire people
some of it is due to just a specific
area of knowledge that you have a lot of
and some of it has to do with how much
you dealt with
different kinds of scenarios for their
company specifically
so they are just more familiar with you
than other developers therefore they
give you that senior title
every background of a senior developer
is a little bit different but i want to
get us all on the same
footing okay i felt a little bit like an
imposter before
and maybe you do too i didn't feel like
i did i deserved that and some people
felt they absolutely deserved that
something to just keep in mind is that
success is a lousy teacher and it
seduces smart people into thinking that
they can't lose at this
kind of like the stock market over the
last year a lot of people felt
like oh i just kind of show up for a job
and occasionally sound really
opinionated in a team meeting
and sometimes just slam a bunch of pull
requests
i must be a great senior
developer but the fact is
that results are the only thing that
matters
in your career but in order for results
to even happen
that requires specific behavior on your
part as the dev
so humans are not robots and we cannot
be programmed very easily
humans have a lot of emotions which
dictate their behavior and while i was
very
proud to say that oh i'm a logical
person
uh because you know i'm a technology and
i believe in science
and deduction and the scientific method
it doesn't mean that i don't have
any emotion that controls the way that i
behave
in the way that i receive information
depending on my mindset of time
so what we're going to do today
is get a handle on how to recognize
what motivates people on your team
but also kind of what blocks their
ability to deliver results
and understand how to actually be
productive with your team
in order to get the best people together
the best team members
you have to kind of ironically get
farther away
from what makes them a good developer
and closer to what makes them a very
unique human
and that is the way that you win
so congratulations after being a senior
for many years you are promoted
you are now the team lead you are now
the team manager you are now the
director of software engineering or cto
congratulations but remember
that people buy into the leader before
they buy into
the vision and leadership is a muscle
i have to tell you um a little bit of a
story here
when it comes to building muscle um i
don't really have anything right now
um cobit has not been kind to my gym
going tactics
but i will tell you a story about when i
started going to the gym
so i had lots of aspirations and my
heart is in the right place and so i
decided instead of doing things myself
i would go to a gym instructor
and so they started me off in the
beginning
gave me some weights to do i started
doing that
and they warned me you're gonna be sore
the next day maybe the next two or three
because your muscles are learning so i
did that
felt good the first day i was really
excited to get started
and there was pain almost immediately
like the next day
i like people tell you that it's gonna
hurt later but until you experience it
you really don't have an idea how much
it will
and so especially if you're using them
somewhat properly you're going to feel a
soreness it shouldn't be pain
but it should be a soreness uh then
you know i went back and a day or two
later to get started i'm like i'm still
sore and like i know
but we got to continue to work a little
bit
so that eventually it becomes not sore
well
fast forward to two months later
it was still sore for me every single
time that i went to go do some
weightlifting with him
now i was using a barbell which is like
um
just kind of like what uh this kid has
like right over here
right and
i i
started kind of arguing with my
instructor and i said you know i feel
like this is not for me
because i don't feel like i'm stronger i
feel
like i'm always weak and i'm always sore
the next day
and i don't feel like i'm getting
anywhere and
unbeknownst to me on this barb
he had over time
put on a little more weight each time he
he added the weight to my bar
but he didn't tell me that because they
were you know on the floor and i was
sitting there waiting so he had changed
it
to what i lifted in the beginning but it
still looks the same right it still kind
of looked the same because he was just
sliding weights on
and he's like try it again and so i sat
down
and i lifted it again and it was pretty
easy it was a lot lighter and he said
come talk to me tomorrow so i came back
the next day and i wasn't sore
and to me this was just kind of a silly
thing to show me but it proved a point
that i had come really far
but i didn't know it because i was
always taking on a little bit
more weight a little bit more than my
muscles could handle
and because of that i never saw the
growth
that i had and
it's pretty much the same thing when you
start becoming a leader in tech
if um you know as you start you might be
able to master a couple of things but
they're always adding another thing
always another crisis always another
person
always another situation always another
thing breaking in your code
for that your team has to handle um but
if you were to take all that away
and just do some basic things that you
did in the first month or two you were
a leader i bet it wouldn't feel so bad
so keep in mind
that leadership is a muscle and you have
to exercise it
when you feel safe the natural reaction
is trust and cooperation but when we
don't fear our leaders then we will
combine our talents to face the
challenges coming from
outside of our team what do developers
want from leaders i asked
my friend group and then i started
asking at conferences what do you want
from your leaders
they want leaders that make them feel
safe
and they may not use the word safe but
that is exactly what they meant
they wanted to feel like they weren't
going to be worried they used phrases
like i don't want to be worried about
my job i don't want to be worried about
how my whether or not i'm going to be
included i don't want to worry about
whether or not my work is going to
understand if i have family obligations
i don't want to worry worrying makes
people feel unsafe
so they want leaders that make them feel
safer you don't need to baby people
but you do need to not make seem like
the threat
they want somebody who's safe who makes
it safe for them to fail let's say if
they
if they do something new that they've
never done or just a little bit of a
stretch goal
right uh let's say that something
happens that you have to turn something
in in 24 hours and the stakes are high
but you don't have the person who knows
how to do that particular thing
there however you do have the person
that they normally work with so that
person
just gives it a go they need to feel
like even if they fail at that that
they're not going to lose
their job that you understand where they
are with it
part of that requires both of you to
communicate but it's important
that they feel that it's safe to fail
and they can confide in you
and that you believe in them and it's
important that
their perspective is that you
believe in them it is important that you
reiterate
or you come up with new ways of
communicating that to them
they also want leaders that have vision
and a higher purpose for their work
um you know so make sure that that you
provide educational opportunities
um people want to have
a purpose for being you know above and
beyond
what they they punch in and do in their
everyday work
um so they want a leader who can inspire
others to the calling
and find a part in it so we want to grow
beyond ourselves a good example of this
is somebody who's just dealing with
being the leader for a project or a
company that they don't really believe
in
they probably should find something
someplace else however
it's possible that where you work and
live you might not have
options for a whole lot of companies to
work for so
it's important as a leader that if the
work is not cool
in other words it might be boring to you
that you find another mission
and i worked for somebody who found the
mission to be
how clean their code could be or how
much we could
automate away from the team or finding
more elegant solutions for looking ahead
to version changes
on different uh ecosystems different
libraries
and it became kind of a fun mission for
us to always just have excellence in
what we were doing
even if what we were building wasn't
inventing a brand new type of
application or industry
and developers want flexibility and
people who are empathetic during their
personal challenges
my gosh haven't we had a very
challenging past 12 months if you have
hard times in your family
would you consider firing your family
members i mean
maybe that sounds like a personal
problem
think twice about what's really going on
with your developers
and never sacrifice people to save the
numbers
i hate that term sacrifice the numbers
to save the people
they will notice and they will
reciprocate
i want you to ask yourself if you're a
leader and you're watching this right
now
does anything that you have stand out
as a weakness or strength on the list of
things that i've gone over so far
about what developers want from their
leaders
make it a personal goal to
fix that and
please understand that no matter how
cool it is
at the company you work for a good
leader
is worth a gold to a team and if you
leave that company
a lot of times people will follow you
and go to wherever you go next
because they know that they felt uh like
you believed in them they felt safe to
make mistakes and learn from them
uh that you're flexible and empathetic
and that you give them something
to to strive for regardless of whatever
you guys are building
it's the way you're building it and how
you communicate as a team
and how you challenge each other to keep
going
consider this list when
reflecting on how much
you're bringing to your own team as a
leader
there's no hard and fast rules you need
to put people before profits and that is
uh the my end statement there i know
it's difficult especially if you run
a tight ship where you are a startup or
you are a business that's just very
tight
let's say you work for a government
agency that just has the money that they
have
but if you put the people before the
prophets nine times out of ten
the leaders above you uh will respect
that
that leadership ability and we'll work
with you on it
first thing i want you to do is think
about how you need
to listen a leader doesn't need to have
the first word
the last word or even most of the words
the state of the team
will often be made very clear to you
when you listen
and digest what each of your developers
have to say
and not necessarily always jump to take
action on it
many times developers just need to vent
and do not necessarily expect you
to fix all of their problems they just
need to be heard
always let the employee go first in a
one-on-one meeting and after processing
what they have said
if an action is required then do it last
demonstrate active listening by
repeating what you heard
so they have an opportunity to correct
it if it was misunderstood
for example you can say all right so
what i'm hearing from you
is that you need
x y z and is that cr did i
did i hear you did i
did words other yeah did i understand
what
the the the thoughts that you have to
share with me today
it sounds a little strange to just
repeat
but it really helps because then i feel
like i was listened to it's a very easy
thing to just
add into your bag of skills
as a leader respect
you will have differences and that is
okay this one
needs to be emphasized it's awesome that
your team is different than you
start with respecting those differences
instead of the temptation of telling
them
they are wrong there is a reason
a developer thinks the way they think
and do what they do
if you start with with respecting what
they bring to the table
and it's a lot easier to work through
those
issues this of course extends
to things that they cannot help like
uh the way they were born this the
country or city that they live in um
the perhaps the
the wealth class that they are in
there's a lot
that they can't necessarily help that
absolutely impacts
the way that they process information so
just because you came to a conclusion in
a different way
doesn't make them wrong it just means
that they've thought through things
differently
so please respect that and it's instead
of saying no no
you wouldn't do that because xyz just
say oh that's interesting
and ask them maybe how they would solve
this problem to get to a goal
encourage this one is a tough one
because not everyone is a natural-born
cheerleader
i'm a natural-born cheerleader but
that's just because
i kind of didn't have a lot of that
growing up so
i i want to make sure that i encourage
people a lot more than what i got
but remember you don't have to be a
natural encourager
this is a muscle you're building
remember you're building muscles right
being in being a successful encourager
means
believing in the ability that the
developer has to overcome
especially when they don't believe that
themselves
so that means you have to see the
potential in them
and share it often in order for them to
push through the hard stuff you
have to have someone in your court i
this is huge i would not be where i am
today if it weren't for
a leader in my life in my working life
encouraging me to go for things that
i felt was beyond reach some of it was
public speaking
but some of it was just going into a
sector i had no experience in
and being afraid that my failure was the
failure of not only myself but all women
because of just how i was born and i was
it just kind of terrified me out of even
trying and that might be something that
you've experienced in your own life that
hey you know just because i'm a minority
maybe
by race or by gender it could be that
you're a minority
of the people in your family to think
the way you do
that i'm certainly that way uh so
it's possible that you you already have
all this
history with your family and your
friends where nobody is a developer
nobody's doing what you're doing
that's that is a huge
like a huge thing for a developer to
experience
constantly pushing through their home
life
please don't be part of making it
difficult for them be the encourager be
the not just oh i'm sure you're going to
do better encourage them in a very
specific way
um if you notice that they don't need
encouragement in one way but maybe in
another
try focusing on it it just shows that
you
are paying attention to their specific
needs
recognition ah recognize this is a big
part for
a leader ranked higher in importance on
the list than even compensation
employees in every single field are
often starved of recognition
that they did a good job at something
even if they know internally that they
did
if nobody talks about it at all in your
company it can make you feel like you're
just kind of floating
there and you'll probably be the first
one asked if they have a budget cut
so we spend on average as much time with
our co-workers as our family
and that can be exhausting if you don't
feel that your effort is being
appreciated or acknowledged when
you have gone above and beyond
especially so
find something often weekly daily if
possible to tell your dev team members
individually what you appreci what you
appreciate
about what they did even if it's just
how fast they did a pull request
it's not just about thanking them for
doing something to help you out it's
about just recognizing their
the value that they bring
empower apparently i wasn't very good
with that slide
delegation is key here to make sure that
your team steps up to the plate and
truly feels like you trust them to do
the right thing
every person will have a different level
of confidence here and
many need continuous reminders that they
have permission
to go with their guts and solve a
problem or create an idea
so this puts them on a more level
playing field with you
and gives them a glimpse into what it
kind of feels like
to make a decision which is part of your
job
so the next step is where you identify
your leaders that are going to come up
after you
or alongside you this is where you
identify them empower them and let them
shine and to where it just becomes very
natural for them to move into that
promotion or that position
so just to recap a technical leader will
listen respect encourage
recognize and empower don't you feel
like you're at a ted talk now
i actually watched a lot of those when i
was trying to learn
how to do this with a dev team
let's talk about the parthenon i had the
privilege
of being able to go to greece and see
this in person
but let's talk about what this is as an
architectural marvel
that has fascinated villagers for
centuries
so when you look at it even in its
state of disrepair it appears to have
perfectly straight identical columns
that hold it up
but this is an optical illusion in order
for it to appear straight at a distance
each disc that stacks upon one another
tapers ever so slightly inward and gets
slightly smaller towards the top making
the order that they are stacked in very
important to reach that appearance
not only is each column disk section
tapering smaller and slanted they are
also compensating
for where they are placed on the very
slightly irregular foundation
which we they didn't have as nice
ways of making everything straight with
them
there are four each one of these columns
requires millimeters of difference to
make all of them
join the roof at the exact same height
that makes every single column disc in
the parthenon
completely unique what appears to be a
section that you can easily swap
out becomes a particular challenge to
find the right
fit and this is how
amazing development teams are actually
built
you cannot just swap out a mid-level
developer for another mid-level
developer
and expect it to fit just perfectly
there is unique attention required for
that individual
in order to give them a place that is
right for their talents
and their mindset so celebrate their
differences and notice how
they each can support the overall team
goal
for what you've built in the area that
needs a little more this or a little
more that
a great leader to me is someone who
almost becomes unnecessary they help
each person wake up the
aspects of themselves that they already
naturally had as children
which brings me to the care of junior
developers
everything you need to know you used to
know when you were a kid
it's important that you show them how to
do things by demonstrating tasks and
staying
nearby to guide them as they begin let
them make mistakes and remind them that
it happens and encourage them to get up
and try again
the care of mid-level developers of
course is going to be different in how
you approach them
support co-worker pairing as they now
contribute more to projects
with consistent results and generate
confidence in your mid-level developers
by
encouraging vocalizing ideas and asking
them what they think first before you
ask the senior developers that's how you
grow them
that's how you awaken that spark
so let's talk about the care of senior
developers you know
senior level developers allow
time for experimentation and autonomous
tasks
and then ask them to bring new ideas
they've been there and done that and
they've seen a lot of things and they
have a lot of experience
so part of what keeps them just
awake and in in the moment is not doing
the same thing over and over
let them do a little bit of exploration
have them teaching the concepts that
they learned to the other developers
regularly
and showcasing the research that they
discovered that could change
some of the dynamics of what you're
building
let's talk about personality types so
it's not just about
understanding how to approach somebody
where they are in their career
it's who they are in their career
so let's talk about the feeding of the
introvert
that's me i'm an introvert and the way
that i
was definitely nurtured and fed into
being able to talk to you
is that i needed to have some alone time
to recharge
i don't do really well on on in a lot of
team things
all the time i sometimes just kind of
need to go off on my own
and be able to think individually
this personality perhaps
you know doesn't thrive as much
by being around lots of people all the
time
and but they have often a lot of value
to add when it comes to
really ruminating on the why of things
introverts tend to really think a lot
about that
the extrovert of course is different
an extrovert might need
that interaction with people right now
my my extroverts i feel bad for you
because a lot of us are just away from
people and sometimes
doing zoom calls does help
but often times they feel the most alive
when they get to be around
other human beings that's where they
they get their energy from
so keep in mind for their developers
that you have that are
extroverts because they do exist it's
important that
you also do some some team
you know outings and things away
but it's also important to them that
perhaps they go into an office or they
they get to travel as part of their job
and see lots of people
how to take care of an optimist well
these are the fun ones
right their personality is great you
always know who they are on the team
because they're like yeah we can totally
do this in two weeks when it really is
four weeks worth of work it's like but
i know we can yeah we can totally do
this and they're always
happier about whatever it is
they have to conquer and it's good to
have somebody like this on your dev team
in terms of personality because
oftentimes we get bogged down
by how much work we've got to do but
this person always kind of
kind of makes us feel like we got this
and
they're always welcome in a dev team
and but you know it's important to have
a pessimist too
[Music]
they find the blind spots in the
situation that others did not notice
that's pretty important a pessimist
needs to make sure that we have done
all of our due diligence that we haven't
missed something
so part of how you feed them is making
sure that they are part
of vetting out the process about how it
could
how it could fail just instead of um
taking a deep breath and
wondering uh when is this person going
to just shoot down this new library that
we want to to add or this new way we
want to
do our team why don't you just ask them
to
provide feedback ahead of time
then that means they feel that their
opinions are valuable
the feeding of the sensitive developer
so this is often people that you might
not even
be aware of are sensitive sometimes you
might be a combination of a couple of
these
the sensitive developer is is definitely
a personality type
that pays a lot of attention to how
everybody
is doing and how everybody's feeling
they tend to be
just a little bit more aware and so this
is the person on the team who might come
to you saying hey
i think the team is kind of feeling this
way maybe we can do something
about it or might
it might be about a specific individual
this is not a complaint this is truly
a somebody who has cause or concern um
or they may come to you not with any
specific person in mind
but just a direction in which the team
is going they're probably the ones who
who mention hey maybe we should send
you know care package is somebody who's
out sick
they're the ones who are thinking about
the human aspect
of the team how do you feed
a bold person ah you don't need to feed
a bold person
they feed themselves they're just like
here i am this is what i want
this is what i'm going to do and it's
breathtaking to watch them work
we need bold people without bold people
we would be milling around
not making decisions and uh not really
having a strong direction to go so bold
people
are the great ones for helping
execute a really good vision that you
have for your team
um getting their buy-in is really
important because they often have a very
loud voice
not necessarily with decibels although
it could be that but they have
a very opinionated voice that definitely
strikes out so it's good to get their
buy-in
for some of the things you are doing
again bringing them in early
ah but the visionary
these dev team members are so valuable
somebody who sees the big picture and
not just
the individual lines of code that you're
doing someone who truly understands
where you're going with it and asks
really big picture questions
this a visionary developer is somebody
who allows your team to dream
a little bit about how much better
things can be and it's important to have
a little bit of infusion in this
because this is somebody who will bring
up things that you probably
never thought were possible because they
aren't constrained
necessarily by the status quo they're
always looking at
brand new ways of doing things
of course i'd be remiss without
mentioning the down-hearted
types of developers on your team
this is not a personality type and i
tricked you a little bit with that
it could be any one of us and it could
be any any one of us
at any point in our lives so whether
it's a moment
in in time that happens to every person
or this is someone who chronically
suffers
from a medical diagnosis this is
something
that a development leader will run into
it
you will run into this it's important to
take the time
to acknowledge mental health challenges
this person might have a different name
every day of the week
and it might be you
you know there's a lot of things that um
i have personally
struggled with and not just this year
but many many times over the years
just because of where i'm coming from in
life but also just the way my mind works
so the the most valuable leaders i've
had in my life
were the ones that allowed me to take
the time
that i needed for things they didn't try
to diagnose me they didn't try to tell
me what to do
they respected and supported you respect
and support
um if they come to you with a lot of
information that
you are not educated and equipped to
handle
please reach out to your
you know that your hr person about maybe
getting them
in contact with just some resources for
them
so they can go in front of somebody who
can who is educated about
how they can maybe change how they're
feeling
or how they can at least cope with what
they're doing
remember you are not a doctor so don't
pretend to be one and don't tell them oh
i just did this to get over my slump
it doesn't work like that for some of us
so it's important
that you understand that your job is to
support them
and to to get them in touch with the
person who can get them resources
so let's talk about how to treat your
team as a whole
the way to hack a human being is to
notice and study their humanity
so pay attention and listen
one of the most common desires among
developers
is a manager who will recognize their
abilities and trust that they'll get
their work done
let them do their job allow developers
to do their jobs please
do not as tempting as it is micromanage
your team
if you don't feel like things are going
to get done unless you're inserted in
the middle of it constantly
you need to really take a good look in
the mirror and ask yourself is it
because
i need to feel necessary and like i
affected this
or is it because i have the wrong team
members that i cannot trust
is that something you can change maybe
oftentimes most of us can do this job
we either aren't properly motivated or
we aren't equipped with the right kind
of processes
put in place and both of those things
are things you can affect
allow to developers to write code they
love doing it
you just need to find a way for
developers to do this in a way that
benefits the company
make sure that you handle the
non-development work needs yes you're
the one who should handle the meetings
and the
and the demands from the top down
you should be a filter and not just a
pass through
for for all of the demands that your
company has for your team
be moderately responsive to your
developers
and be reachable this one i didn't think
i'd have to mention
but now that it's happened to me a
couple times in the past i feel like
i probably should throw it up here if
somebody is really stuck
and they have a deadline which i have
not met one developer
professionally that doesn't have a
deadline they timely responses are
important
give them guidelines and boundaries of
like hey after five o'clock
nobody works or after this time i don't
work um
but you can always do an emergency
scenario saying hey if
if the entire website goes down you have
permission to pick up the phone and call
me
and things like that make sure you just
kind of outline you know
an escalation level of uh any sort
of communication and follow up with it
make regular one-on-ones a priority this
is hard
have you ever sat across from a
developer and you're just not like a
people person but
you're the lead or you're the manager
and you're like hey so uh what's up
so what's going on hey i just need you
to be faster
at um at the pull request you do
um thanks good talk and that was the
extent of your meeting
that uh that's not a great one-on-one
and then they oftentimes don't want to
come back to it so
make sure that one-on-ones are quality
but also priority so if you have to
leave let's say you're sick
or you have a meeting that you cannot
get out of it's very very important
then cancel the one-on-one but
immediately reschedule it or just
move it to a time when you know that you
can do it
if you just cancel it and you never
create another meeting
then the developer thinks the one-on-one
is not important to you
and that speaks volumes emphasize
quality code over quantity or velocity i
promise you that
if people are doing the right things
they will get faster at it
or you will learn ways to automate it to
make to make it be faster
if you tell people no it doesn't matter
we just need to throw this up there you
will get burned every single time
i've never had that go well in history
especially when it comes to client
expectations so it's important that you
do quality over quantity and you
communicate that all the way up the
chain
if you need to to get deadlines moved or
to get the
list of the minimum
features of of a piece of software out
within a reasonable time and avoid
asking them to task switch so like being
on multiple projects and too many
interruptive meetings
in fact um really effective ways i've
seen this happen is i only do meetings
on mondays and thursdays
um or hey we do we do meetings only
after four
or before 10 or whatever it is you can
decide to block things off on your
on your calendar and do that on behalf
of your team
and saying hey this is what my my team
will do just so that they have more time
to allow their mind to solve the
problems that they're given as part of
their job
and not have to constantly jump into
meetings
and be that shield for your team when
challenges arise do not throw an
individual developer under the bus
you will regret it because not only will
that person feel
like they can't really trust you anymore
even if they did do it even if they were
the ones who did
break the thing not only will
they feel a severance because you said
oh well this person made the mistake
you should take responsibility for the
entire thing as a development leader
full stop if you throw someone else
under the bus not only does that person
feel
like they can't trust you the rest of
the development team sees you doing that
and they know that you won't have their
back either
so please avoid that trust your team's
judgment
you may need to step into make decisions
or priority calls but this will be
on the information provided by your team
if you get this
right you should have a good autonomous
and self-directed team
and my friend stephen hotz said that and
i just
loved it
so some takeaways for those of us who
are learning how to
take care of our engineers developers
are
self-sacrificial they're not good at
making sure they're okay before
throwing themselves head first into
problem solving and the exhaustion
attention that follows
but you still need to give away control
of every single little thing
and create opportunities for others to
grow it is a balance
it's your job now to make sure that the
people behind the programming
have what they need to be successful and
balanced
drive for autonomy and mastery and
purpose
allow your team to fail through failure
we learn and we learn pretty well and
it's quite a memorable experience
teach others and emphasize that you are
learning as well so don't feel like you
have to be the one with the answer and
you have to come up with one if you
don't know
for the love of all things please say
i don't know let's figure it out or
i guess i'm gonna have to research that
nobody will lose respect for you
because none of us were born coding and
we all had to learn and google is our
friend
it's okay to not know everything it's
also okay to be a new leader and say hey
i'm new at this i'd love feedback
from you um and people will they'll open
up to you about what they personally
need
be a gate opener not a gate keeper
go forth today and learn about new tech
and better ways to code those skills are
necessary but take care
to learn how to truly nurture a team by
adding
human skills to your agenda as well with
a group of confident
cohesive developers and a box of legos
you can accomplish literally anything
together
now go build your parthenon and stay
curious
thank you very much for sharing that um
so we have uh you are muted dylan
i'm i'm i'm muted for you i'm not muted
for youtube but you can't hear me that's
all right there we go
the joys of so many mute buttons
um so it's been really interesting i
don't know if you're keeping an eye on
the youtube chat while you're talking
there because uh
like you said at the beginning it's not
the kind of talk that people have
questions but it's a kind of talk that
inspires people to share things um
and uh you know we've gotta somebody's
just sat in the chat
dave wong says he's just been fired for
not coding fast enough
um what would your reaction to that be i
mean everyone else in the chat is like
yeah you're better off without them good
companies don't
fire people for doing that but uh you
know what have you come across a
situation
like that oh of course i personally got
fired for the same thing so like don't
worry about it
it happened um remember
not all companies are just and fair
and it it's very important to be
involved
with friends outside of your workplace
because that way you
get a wider sense of
what is acceptable at large in the
industry
um therefore these people are already
giving you feedback that saying oh you
shouldn't
probably be there there's something
wrong with that that means that
you know if you don't feel like you're
coding fast enough you have to ask
yourself
do you want quality or do you want
quantity now if you're not giving either
then maybe you pick one right i would
suggest picking quality because your
brain
like once you do cert some things a
certain amount of time it creates those
neural pathways
that will automatically go faster as
you're doing something so just pick a
thing that you want to be really good at
or let's pretend it's just a library
that you want to kind of be known for
um and within your team anyway and just
learn a lot about that
and then you'll be faster about the
decision making and getting a code
sample and stuff like that
um don't it's not really about sitting
here with a timer i know that
there are competitions for that kind of
thing
um but those are not the people i want
working on my project because
we i'd rather have somebody who's
thoughtful about what they're building
uh lena has a question in the chat uh
says my manager is doing tech decisions
for the developers
um how can i calm him down oh my
goodness really
uh well it depends right so that's a
trust
issue right they think that oh my
developers aren't smart enough i'm just
gonna decide things
um it could be that that person was a
developer once
and they were never taught how to be a
good leader
that is often the case and they don't
mean anything by it they just
don't know the right thing to do so it's
important that since you have this
knowledge
you go to them and say hey i think your
team wants to be involved with this
and that's part of how you know
we want to grow as a team so please
include us in this because we have some
thoughts
and i don't know a lot of people out
there who wouldn't be like
oh yes please help me with all the work
i have to do all the decisions i have to
make
if they still push back again i would
question
whether that person just has never had
any
training on how to be a manager which is
okay if it's you
you know or if they really are just kind
of jerks and if that's the case then you
need to find somewhere else to be
and that and you're probably not the
only one that feels this way so
instead of just complaining be proactive
you ever hear the thing that
uh even the worst job in the world can
teach you one very valuable lesson
which is what a bad job looks like
yes and what a good one looks like i'd
be interested to hear
people express what is
an attribute of like the best manager
they've ever had or maybe they've always
had bad ones
but think uh if you have had a good
manager
why were they good what was it about
them that was good is it because that
they were
a protege of elon musk like what was it
it's leadership often has nothing to do
with technical ability
so you have to understand that guess
what you are
pivoting to a completely different skill
set yeah sometimes you can get paid more
but that's because you have
you have more headaches and you it's
more delicate because you're dealing
with humans
watching some more conversation in the
chat uh um
elena says what do you do and your
manager makes a decision says the team
can make it independently as long as
it's the same as the rest of the company
you know again might not be the right
place but you can always say hey this is
how it makes us feel
and i think we need to get on on the
same page somehow or you're going to
lose people
i mean that's what i would say it's
really really difficult
especially when they think they know
more than their team
i don't think that's the job of a leader
at all you need to be a servant leader
you need to be one who's like willing to
get in the trenches with your team but
also
don't tell don't tell them like this
it's
it's really difficult uh it's a skill
and not everybody who's gone from being
a dev to a manager has
it and it's also you know i've always
found a leadership and management if
you're
a coder and you're not as good as you
think you are you can practice by
yourself
the compiler is infinitely patient and
you don't have to put it on github until
it's right
it comes to managing people you can't do
that the only way to get better at it is
to mess up in public until you work out
what you did wrong
and that's hard yeah and that's but
intent matters in that
whereas as a developer your intent
doesn't matter at all
it's just did you produce or not did you
check the code in or not
when you're a manager your intention
matters even if you screw up
be like it's obvious if you if you care
about your team
because you behave that way and even if
you made the wrong decision you you own
up to it people forgive very quickly
they're like okay but i know this sounds
terrible but you know they say oh
leaders are not just nice people
but they start that's true but they also
don't blame others for their own
mistakes and and try to pretend like oh
i don't want to show weakness
there's two different leaders that i
think about i think about
steve jobs and and you know i
i think about the difference between him
and what
elon is doing now is he doesn't put down
members of his team if they make
a mistake in public like he's not like
oh they were stupid and they did this
thing
he's never done that whereas steve jobs
has absolutely done that to everybody on
his team before
so you don't feel it's different they're
both brilliant they were
brilliant people with vision but it's
just a little bit different and they're
all kind of quirky you know
um you don't have to be like a sweet
angel you just need to
be respectful and and realize you're
probably actually taking on more
responsibility than you need you can
probably
allow other people on your team to take
it on and it shows that you have faith
in them
fantastic let's get so we're going to
get our next speaker in then i'm going
to run another
quiz prize draw uh thanks very much for
for taking the time to talk to us today
heather let me
click that button there the layouts are
gonna go a little weird for a few
seconds here
because that's how the internet works um
so there we go uh genie is in the call
let me just switch that back
to uh there it is and i can add another
pin
and there we go hey janine how you doing
hello so uh we're gonna have a very
brief
interlude now before we we hand over
your uh what is it you're gonna be
talking to us about today
uh today i'm gonna be talking about
building friendliness into server-side
applications
applications which is a topic very close
to my heart because uh there's there's
not enough friendliness and a lot of
back-end code
but before we do that we are gonna give
away some
more fabulous prizes so
everybody who is watching on the stream
head over to slido.com
put in the registration code ndcmcr
in dc manchester we are gonna run
another quiz
this quiz same as last time five
questions multiple choice
watch your screens because that's where
the
the fast things are gonna happen that's
the thing that we need to be
we need to be looking at here um and i'm
gonna kick this one off
we are gonna do a quiz here about a
technology
by the numbers so uh
you know the wonderful world of tech
that we all work in is full of
statistics and figures and measurements
and metrics and all these kinds of
things
and uh we are gonna see now this is one
of those fun quizzes where i'm not
expecting anyone to know the exact
answers
it's a bad kinda it's multiple choice
and we've we've put in a couple that are
deliberately deliberately wrong
in each case um and again we are giving
away the first prize winner
is gonna get a ticket to uh nbc
manchester
2020 or to an ndc conference near you if
is not uh geographically convenient or
you can tune in and watch online because
the future of conferences
is very definitely hybrid it is people
in person and it's content being
streamed so that everybody
can be part of that and the runners-up
are going to win
a uh special limited edition ndc
manchester hoodie so uh
we're looking good i see 50 57 people
we're i'm gonna keep talking
as long as that number keeps going up um
don't forget by the way to uh
to like the stream and subscribe to the
ntc conference's youtube channel
we are always putting up videos from our
events
and promos and all kinds of other stuff
uh one of the the things all these
events we do all the talks get recorded
and they are put up on
youtube for free if you subscribe you
get notified when new stuff goes up
great speakers great content really good
insights
all right 61 63 64 we're going to keep
going
till we get to 65 got two more any two
two more two more takers
can we get 65 people we got 63 on the
stream now
there's someone out there going
frantically i need to get into this i
need to register in this
looks like r64 we got we got one more
um austin says how many of you use
macbooks at work 66 all right that is
enough we are gonna start
the quiz so
let's kick things off here what is one
ether worth
in british pounds as of
today uh ether is of course the currency
unit of the ethereum
uh cryptocurrency which has got a lot of
press lately for
reasons that i shan't go into
what is one eat worth in british pounds
it is uh most of you think it's 1150
it is
1150 give or take a little bit of a
fluctuation let's have a look at the
winners
after that question dan scott in the
lead five seconds to get that right
simon rob s ben chris let's have a look
at the next
question how many websites are there
there's a company called netcraft and
every month netcraft run a massive
survey where they do http
probes for basically every dns record
and see how many of them are responding
to an http get request
how many websites did they find as of
the beginning of march 2021
how many websites do you think there are
the correct answer
is 1.2
billion which is quite a lot of websites
and most of them are still running php
and jquery
which is nice uh let's have a look at
the leaderboard see how that's changed
dan scott is holding on to the lead
there vincent
john thomas s ben let's have a look at
another question here
in what year did the number of mobile
devices so we're talking devices with a
data connection
exceed the number of people on earth
as of today there's about eight and a
half million people on planet earth
and there's something like 10.8 million
data connected
devices
chewbacca rampage says the answer is
always c two data points is a trend
uh i am sorry chewbacca rampage the
answer is not
always see it is 2015.
was the year when according to the
international telecoms union
there were more data connected devices
than people now of course that doesn't
mean
that everybody has a smartphone it means
that some people don't have any
smartphones at all and some people have
a lot of smartphones
and people who do front-end user
experience design have a box
in their house with about 25 different
irs and android devices
just so they can make sure things work
properly but yeah it's 2015 we had more
connected mobile devices than human
beings on this planet
which is just mind-blowing uh dan is is
holding on to the lead here which is
pretty impressive let's see if we can
unseat dan with uh the next two
questions
how many submarine cables are in service
worldwide events like the one we're
running now all of you who are watching
from outside the the
mainland united kingdom all of you
are watching this thanks to the wonder
of submarine telegraph cables which
carry
data and media and video under the sea
and connect the whole planet together
but how many of those
cables are there and at the moment the
correct answer is
there are 426 about 1.2
million kilometers of cable connecting
all of the continents
on the world let's take a look at our
leaderboard here uh
where's the change at the top dan has
knocked down a third place
uh thomas and mila are up in first
john's still there andy is a new entry
on the leaderboard we have one question
left to go
now then what i want to know is
when the linux kernel was first released
october 5th
1991 linux version 0.0.1
how many lines of code was it
how many lines of code were in the first
public release
of the linux kernel just under 20 years
ago
twelve hundred ten thousand twenty five
thousand or seventy four thousand
the correct answer is ten thousand
two hundred and thirty nine
and let's have a look at the leaderboard
so the top of this leaderboard wins an
ndc conference's ticket it is uh thomas
pissula
thomas congratulations we will be in
touch by email to get you a ticket to an
ndc event of your choice in the next
year
andy milash vincent dan you will be
getting limited edition
nbc hoodies we are gonna get those uh
we'll be in touch to sort out shipping
details
um mark got five out of five wrong and
is in 66th
place out of 66 people that is
impressive
we might need to get a limited edition
hoodie for the zeroth player as well
so we're gonna have one more quiz this
afternoon we got a couple more prizes to
be
be giving away uh don't forget to like
and subscribe to our channel here
and now we are going to welcome back
to the studio uh jana nisubia so uh
janani you are gonna be talking to us
about building friendliness into
server-side applications
that's right cool you want to start
sharing your screen i'll push the magic
button that makes the magic happen
please everybody give a big warm ndc
manchester welcome
janani subia hello
all right um
[Music]
cool can everybody see my screen okay
sounds great thanks
all right hello and welcome to my talk
my name is
janani subaya and uh today we're going
to be talking about
building friendliness into server-side
applications
a little bit about me before we get
started my name is
uh johnny and i currently work as a
product architect for a company called
detroit labs based in
detroit michigan usa most of my
experience in the software industry
comes from
working on some android apps and mostly
building backend services
i love to read and travel given how last
year went a lot
more reading than traveling happened i'm
hoping
that there can be a balance between the
two of them in the near future
i'm also a new balcony gardener uh again
given how last year went i spent a lot
of time at home so i
started experimenting with growing uh
fruits vegetables and herbs from
store-bought produce
uh just trying to figure out what seeds
i can germinate at home without having
to go to
a nursery or a garden center and
it started out as a wonderful experiment
and it continues so i cannot
wait for this year's growing season
uh all right as far as today's talk goes
i'm going to start us off with
why the friendliness why i'm here giving
this talk
um then we'll talk about my top friendly
feature picks
uh and finally there'll be conclusion so
on that note
why the friendliness why am i here
giving this talk today
um as mentioned most of my experience in
the software industry comes from
building backend services
and that includes building apis and
services for
other teams and developers to use while
at the same time also consuming
uh apis and services built by other
developers
um in the process you know evaluating
and using frameworks that help with
back-end services development
during the course of all this there have
been a lot of times when
i felt like a certain feature that's
exposed by other
service teams have been very useful for
me you know as the consumer of such
services
i find it uh very useful that that
feature is available it makes my life
very easy
uh and other times you know certain
frameworks provide uh certain things out
of the box
might seem very basic at first but you
know uh they might be things that are
easily overlooked
and they make just building services so
much more easy
and other times i've wanted to flip the
table because
something is very obvious and basic but
not available
or is very hard to implement so a
combination of
all these three feelings is why i'm here
today and that is the motivation for my
talk
so long story short today we'll be
talking about back-end friendly features
that help with making a service fun to
use so this is for your consumers if you
are develop if you're a developer who's
building a backend service
um this talk will be helpful in
understanding how
some features that could be incorporated
into your service might help
people who are using this service we'll
also talk about
how some of these some of these features
help with
uh making life easy when it comes to
building and
maintaining uh backend services this is
for teams that are actually building
those backend services
and um the hope is also that these
features can be used as evaluation uh
criteria when you're looking at
frameworks out there uh that help with
building back-end services
and finally if this is a feature that
you think is friendly
and useful but not provided by anybody
uh then figuring out if that feature is
worth investing time in you know if uh
your developers are the ones who are
going to have to build them ground
so uh in today's talk this is the
structure that
i have we'll be talking about backend
friendly features and because a lot of
these features
are not necessarily baked into the back
end instead they're things
uh which could be other services or
tools that help with
developing these backend features um
these features could be provided by
different things they could be baked
into the backend they could be
provided by a framework or another tool
that sits
uh you know right next to the back end
and helps with backend services
development
so we'll also talk about considerations
for such tools
especially if it is not something that's
baked into the back end itself
and i also want to talk about why i
think
uh that particular feature is a back-end
friendly feature
so on that note the first and i think
this is one of the most important ones
especially for backend services
is to have consistent apis and
api is here i'm just talking about you
know rest or http apis that are going to
be exposed to your consumers
are not really going to get into the
code uh as much just because i feel like
we could dedicate an entire talk about
having consistent apis in code
so this is just going to be all the http
apis
or restful apis that your consumers will
be saying and at the core of this in my
opinion
is definitely consistent naming
consistent naming of
everything that makes up apis and some
of the first
few things that come to mind are urls
query path variables headers
responses cookies requests and anything
else that
may make up some of these components um
making sure to have everything named
consistently helps consumers
uh and you know also the folks who are
actually developing the backend service
uh because consistency is great you know
it sets up a pattern
uh that's easier to follow and it makes
using these services very easy
uh for example if we were to consider
urls making sure that you pick a naming
strategy
and stick to it for all your urls uh
maybe it's camel casing maybe it's
hyphenated
uh irrespective of which one it is
picking one and sticking to it
is very helpful similarly for query and
path variables making sure that you know
you have them named consistently
and also ensuring that if there is a
similar query or path variable across
apis all of them have the same name so
that somebody who's looking at a certain
query or a path variable immediately
know what it's there for
and that applies to everything that
makes up requests and responses
uh and everything that makes up apis in
general but these are some of the first
things that
come to mind so next let's talk about
why i think this is important the first
reason why is because it makes the the
use of such
are consistently named apis more
predictable
uh there is a pattern there it makes
building them and
using them very very uh predictable and
that in turn will make coding uh almost
second nature you know somebody who's
coding to
a certain api uh in a backend service
that has already exposed other apis
is going to find it very easy to go to
that api if it's consistently named
versus getting frustrated because
somebody decided to change the casing
all of a sudden and uh things are now
named differently
so that's one of the big wins of having
consistent naming in your apis
the next one is it makes it very easy to
follow and this
is applicable to any documentation of
the apis you might have
and the actual code itself that actually
exposes those apis
just taking a look at the documentation
and the code again becomes
almost second nature because there are
fewer things between those apis to keep
track of
uh because you know most of the things
that are common to them is more
predictable there is a pattern there
and that makes it very easy to follow
documentation and uh
code stuff relating to apis and finally
uh no code is set in stone so is no team
you might have folks join the team and
lead the team uh and especially if
you're on a team where you have people
joining the team all the time
uh having consistent naming of apis is
uh
makes onboarding very easy this is
especially for developers who might be
joining the backend team itself it's
again easier for them to follow what's
going on
maybe they look at the documentation and
they immediately know what to expect in
the code
and if everything is named consistently
the code also becomes very easy to
follow
so that is consistent naming of apis
next let's talk about consistent error
structures um
consistent error structures in my
opinion are absolutely
very very basic to any api but they're
so
easy to miss and the consequences of
missing something like this can be very
frustrating
especially for folks who are using your
backend service
which is why i think uh this particular
topic deserves its own section
so again as mentioned earlier i'll be
talking about api errors in particular
and not necessarily errors or exceptions
that might be thrown within the code
base itself so this
is any api error that might be passed
back to consumers from your backend
service
so it's more consumer-facing the first
thing
about making sure that your error
structures are consistent is to make
sure that all the errors from your api
are uh conveyed consistently and uh
the code here is to make sure that the
errors are driven by the errors itself
or the error responses are driven by the
errors itself and not the api
say you're building an application that
requires valid credentials before
somebody can access a certain api
and say you have a request coming in
that either has invalid credentials or
no credentials at
all and what you're going to pass back
to the service is basically a 401 that
stands for unauthorized
making sure that the message that is
passed back
is consistent across all apis meaning
doesn't matter which api
is being accessed currently it's always
a 401 and it's always the same 401
that's passed back to the consumers is
helpful
again because consuming those errors on
the consumer side becomes really easy
the next one can be a little hard
sometimes is to have the same structure
for
all your errors across all apis uh
and this can be hard because maybe you
don't want to have the same
things conveyed for all your errors and
i think um
uh an easy approach to you know
achieving this is
probably you take a step back from the
code figure out you know what different
types of errors you want handled
and come up with a structure that works
for most of them um
again this is helpful because you know
it makes
using these uh errors or rather
consuming them very easy
and finally really important to make
sure that you don't
have any duplication especially among
your uh response components
uh a good example here is say when
something goes wrong you want something
conveyed in the response body
as well as in the headers making sure to
avoid things like that
because um everything goes well so as
far as both those values are the same
and you know maybe
uh you know can be the same message but
having the same information in two
different places always opens the door
to
you know them diverging and when that
happens it can be really hard to figure
out the source of truth
so uh the best solution there is to just
avoid duplication
unless you absolutely need to have it
and if you need to have some form of
duplication making sure that it's always
the same
that's just going to be some additional
work for the service developers to do
so now why do i think consistent error
structures makes backend services
friendly
the first and kind of obvious reason is
it makes returning errors very
easy and this is more for the folks on
the back in team itself
uh it's possible to dedicate you know a
centralized section of the code base to
error handling that could be used by
all apis and basically that's the single
place in the code that's going to pass
back errors to uh consumers
becomes easy to test and it's this you
know centralized place so
uh chances of diverging is very less
on the flip side it also becomes easy
for consumers to consume errors you know
for all past
uh current and future apis again if they
can dedicate a section of the code base
to consuming these errors
uh they know that error handling is
taken care of for all future consumers
if the back end keeps up its promise to
make sure that
that error structure is going to be
consistent across apis
and finally similar to consistent naming
this also adds to predictability of the
service itself
uh and you know especially when things
go wrong and there is an error
it makes it almost second nature to code
to those errors and really figure out
what needs to be displayed to the end
user or what needs to be passed to other
services that
may be using our consumers uh so
consistent data structures also adds to
predictability
the next one is logging logging is
probably one of those things that's
always available not just for backend
services but also for
uh also on any software application uh
it's very core to all software
applications
and i think it's one of those features
that makes backend services
very easy to use for anybody using it
including the folks actually working on
the service
so today we'll talk about uh
considerations for logging tools
and uh our considerations here are going
to be a combination of things that could
be provided by
frameworks uh and you know maybe these
are things provided by
logging aggregation tools uh so it's
going to be a combination of all those
things
the first consideration for a logging
tool and this applies to
uh tools that may be aggregating logs
and
uh maybe they have them like stored in a
certain place is the
ability to search through these logs um
and this can be over
different criteria it could be based on
an exception it could be based on a
certain time period
it could based on several other things
depending on the needs of your
application
so but having searchability helps with
looking through the logs a lot more easy
the next one again depending on what
kind of application you're building
and what kind of data your app is
dealing with the option to mask
sensitive information uh so this could
include things like credentials or
any other uh you know sensitive
information that shouldn't be exposed to
the outside world
having an option to mask those uh masks
that information from the logs can be
another
important consideration of blogging too
the next one
is having the option to set different
log levels based on the environment
so say you have a development beta and a
production environment you probably
don't want the same
logging level across all of those three
environments you know just having the
option to set different levels for those
environments
um and this can be something that is
provided by the backend itself doesn't
necessarily
have to come from the logging tool but
if it does
and even if it doesn't it's probably an
important consideration
while just building the backend service
as a whole
the next one is very similar to the
masking sensitive information except
here you
completely want to remove it so when you
mask something you know
the field or you know what came in you
just don't know the value that it held
but when it comes to removing sensitive
information you don't even know what
came in again this depends on what kind
of application you're building or what
kind of data your app is dealing with
uh based on that you know this could be
really helpful
and the last consideration for logging
tools which is also one of my favorites
is to have good formatting options it
can be very hard to go through logs
especially if everything is going to be
printed out the same way
uh sometimes just using the same color i
like to have log formatting so i like to
see all my edit logs in red because
i want to stop everything i'm doing and
look at what's going on similarly you
know all my debug and info logs can be
in green because
technically everything's going well i
guess i can make that assumption when
everything is in green
um you know having log formatting can be
very helpful and adds to search ability
of logs you know just easier to consume
another consideration here especially if
you have your logs aggregated in a
certain place
uh figuring out how you want those logs
to be aggregated
do you want them all in plain text do
you want them in json and you know
options for actually
uh sending them over to the logs
aggregation tool in whatever format you
pick can be very helpful
so next why do i think logging is
important
again very obvious it becomes very very
easy to debug
your application especially when
something goes wrong depending on how
uh how much of the searchability
functionality is provided by the
aggregation tool
figuring out you know um if you can
search over a period of time
figuring out if you can search over a
certain exception or based off of a
certain request that came in maybe from
a particular consumer
all of those things become very easy uh
if you have searching
enabled the next one is uh you know
similar to debugging it also makes it
very easy to search uh maybe you just
want to search through your logs for
certain things
you want to see periodically what's been
happening it doesn't necessarily have to
be
an error that is obvious to consumers
for cases like that you know
searching becomes very easy and finally
i think this is really important
something doesn't have to go wrong for
the logs to be important
uh and i think security logs are a big
example of that
maybe someone's been trying to access
your application in a suspicious way
and nothing has really gone wrong but
having those
logs still aggregated helps with finding
patterns
of such uh suspicious you know activity
and it helps to be
you know proactive and fix things that
need to be fixed
um before things actually go wrong so it
helps with faster feedback
even before hell has broken loose and
that's logging the fourth one we're
gonna be talking about today is
tracing uh tracing is the ability to
look at what happens to a request as
soon as it's it originates on
say a consumer side and uh comes to your
service maybe it gets transformed into
multiple downstream requests
or maybe there's a response sent back
immediately just knowing what happens to
a request
from the time it originates on the
consumer side all the way till
you know our response being passed back
to the consumer irrespective of whether
that's an error or a success response
so uh today we're going to be talking
about as far as racing goes
about considerations for the tracing
tool
well the tool needs to do what it says
it does it needs to be able to trace a
request so
uh you know starting with the consumer
it needs to be able to tell us where
that request travels to next
how that request gets transformed if it
gets transformed how is data collected
from multiple sources
how are they combined who combines them
and how it is passed back to
the calling consumer uh the next one is
i think most tracing tools do this
provide
some form of latency information so this
is basically information about how much
time or request spend on a given service
this can be very helpful especially if
you're looking to improve response times
or improve the performance of your
entire application in general
tracing tools are maybe optional when
you have
two or maybe a single service that's
serving all requests
when it comes to distributed systems or
you know microservices architecture
tracing tools also uh i'm sorry almost
become a necessity
um it becomes really hard to figure out
what's going on
and where things are going wrong so
having a tracing tool especially when
you have multiple systems in play
can be very very helpful and almost
necessary having multiple systems or
having a microservices architecture
adds the necessary abstraction uh so
that consumers don't have to know about
exactly what's going on under the hood
every time they make a request and this
can be great
when everything works well but when
everything doesn't
um having a tracing tool can add the
necessary amount of transparency to help
with
figuring out what's going on and finally
again one of those features that's
mostly provided by most tracing tools
is some form of visual representation
and the hope here is that this visual
representation is provided out of the
box
and can be used alongside your uh
back-end service itself
again based on you know what your
architecture looks like
or what the how many systems are in play
having
some form of visual representation makes
consuming this information
very easy so uh that's why visual
representations are very helpful for
increasing tools
so next let's get into the whys of
having a good tracing tool
it helps pinpoint failures especially
when you have multiple systems in play
and uh there isn't enough transparency
around what's going on
exactly where uh and when things fail
it's important to know
what failure has occurred and which
services failed
this can be a little easy if it's a
single team that's responsible for
you know all these services but if you
have multiple teams responsible for
different services uh getting everybody
in the same room can be harder than
having a tracing tool
that has a good visual representation
where one look at the tracing tool will
tell you exactly
what has failed and where it has failed
the next one
is related to latency information again
you know if the tracing tool provides
latency information
you can be proactive about fixing slower
response times and in general you can
make performance improvements
based on uh which service is currently
the slowest in the link
and as mentioned several times
transparency is probably one of the
biggest wins of having a tracing tool
especially true if you have a micro
services or a distributed architecture
where uh the abstraction of not knowing
exactly how a request gets transformed
works great
so as far as everything goes well but
when hell breaks loose it can be
helpful to have some amount of
transparency which the tracing tool
usually provides
so that's tracing and next we'll talk
about secret storage
unless you're building an application
that all it does is prints hello world
chances are you're going to have at
least one secret in your app
uh and by secrets you know i'm referring
to anything that should not be exposed
to the outside world
anything that's needed by your app for
proper functioning so api keys
credentials any other keys that might be
required by your application
um you know come under the umbrella of
secrets
so today we'll talk about considerations
for the secret store
uh or considerations for whatever secret
management strategy that you're going to
pick
and this also could be baked into your
application or
it could be mostly a service that lives
alongside your application
uh that you know stores secrets that
might be required by your
project or app the first one is to make
sure that the secret storage tool
provides for good encryption options uh
this is almost a no-brainer
you know your secrets are not going to
be stored in plain text they should not
be stored in plain text
so figuring out what kind of encryption
options are available
um and you know uh also looking at uh
considerations
uh you know put forth by owasp or other
security chapters
um making sure that you have options for
different key lens
and different algorithms is very helpful
um and a lot of this also depends on
what kind of app you're building you
know maybe it's very sensitive maybe
it's not as sensitive so figuring out
what encryption strategy works for your
project is also useful when considering
encryption
the next one is security and when i say
security i'm talking about security
around the tool
itself especially if this is another
service that lives you know alongside
your back end
so reviewing things like who can access
those secrets
and uh how can developers on the team
access those secrets if
that is a requirement and figuring out
if there is an option to provide some
kind of access-based control rules
around uh just managing and accessing
secrets
uh can be another big one the next one
which is also one of my favorites is an
option to
uh rotate the keys and um by
keys rotation i'm talking about changing
the secrets periodically
uh so changing the key that encrypts
them and making sure you know figure out
what the definition key looks like
um and this is especially useful because
a lot of times this removes developer or
any manual intervention
so say you have multiple services in
your application and both of them need
certain keys to talk to each other
and uh say all of those keys are stored
in the secret storage tool
uh developers don't have to go in to
update the tool every once in a while or
update it when it's compromised
instead the secret store itself takes
care of changing those values
and because both those services are
going to pull that value from the secret
store tool
uh you know stuff should not break and
there should be no downtime technically
again because this is uh you know a
layer of automation this can be very
helpful
uh just make sure to pick an optimal
amount of time for keys rotation if it's
as long as 10 years it kind of beats the
purpose uh again you know it can't be
too short because it's changing
constantly just figuring out what that
balance looks for
looks like for your team can be helpful
here and finally
everything works great only if your app
can actually access those secrets so
making sure that
your application your backend service or
if you have multiple services making
sure that all of them can access
the secret store is also very important
and next we're going to talk about why
this is important and this is one of my
favorite reasons why because it's
important to stay out of the news
for all the wrong reasons recently the
news has been flooded with um
you know uh stories of our data breaches
and hacks
and uh you know with compute times
becoming faster
uh it becomes all the more important to
build security into applications and
doing that the right way and i think
evaluating and picking a good secret
storage tool
takes you a step away from being on news
next uh which is why i think this is
really really important it's almost a
feature that's necessary versus friendly
uh but i think it helps people sleep
better at night so
uh in my opinion it comes under the
category of friendly
all right next we're going to be talking
about support for
api documentation again this doesn't
refer to code documentation i'm
specifically talking about
a place to document uh just the is
exposed by your packet
and um again one of those features that
could be baked into the backend itself
uh depending on what tools are available
or what language or framework you've
picked
or it could be a standalone tool that
stands that sits next to your back end
and uh helps you know with documenting
apis
the first consideration i like to think
about while evaluating documentation
tools
is making sure that the tool is open api
compliant
open api is a standard interface that
provides a good means to
document restful and http apis so the
words used there
and you know all the options provided
there are standard
understood not just by developers but
also by computers
and because it's understood by computers
there can be some cool automation on top
of
uh documentation that is open api
compliant uh
and you know again because it's a
standard interface it's also mostly
understood by most developers so having
a documentation tool that complies to
open api
uh can be very useful the next one is
the tool needs to do what it says it
does it needs to be able to document
apis and this can look different for
different teams
you know i think a good uh evaluation
strategy here is taking a step back from
your code figuring out what apis you
want documented and figuring out
what within those apis you want
documented maybe you have a bunch of
custom things maybe you have a lot of
custom headers
maybe you want to document the schemas
of your request and response bodies
including specifying what's required and
what's not required
those are just a few examples some apps
can have very basic requirements maybe
crud is all they want documented
some others can the documentation for
some other apps can be more involved so
figuring out what that looks like
and figuring out if the documentation
tool provides those options
can be very helpful and will definitely
save you a lot of time
down the line the next one is a very
very nice to have
and i love this as a developer is the
ability to
have the documentation automatically
regenerated every time there's a code
change
so every time there's a code change
especially with regard to apis
uh the documentation tool automatically
picks it up you know regenerates the
documentation and
you have a brand new documentation
that's exactly up to date with your code
um saves a lot of developer time and
there's always confidence that what's
the documentation tool is exactly what's
in the app at all times
so this can be very useful for the
back-end developers as well as for
consumers or anybody else in the team
so now we'll talk about why having a
good documentation tool is important
the first and again a little obvious one
is it is a central source of truth it
acts as a reference it acts as a source
of truth
uh that you know uh people can use to
understand what your backend does
maybe folks don't understand uh or don't
know yet
the code that you've coded your backend
and maybe they're not familiar with the
framework
they don't have to know any of those
things to actually be able to read this
uh documentation because technically
this is code and frameworks agnostic so
it becomes very very helpful to have
this upfront
and it makes your service very easy to
use say somebody is evaluating different
services and
your service is one of the things
they're looking at it becomes very easy
for them to actually understand if your
service does what they're looking for
just by looking at the documentation
and say they pick your service it also
becomes very easy for developers on
their site to start coding to your
service
without having to look at the code of
your actual service
they just have to look at the
documentation and so as far as there is
an understood promise that the
documentation does exactly what it says
it does
developers can just use that as the
source of truth to
start using your service and if your
team's not going to be the one that's
going to see
a project on its end or you know if you
have multiple teams working on something
documentation handoff also becomes easy
this also stems from the fact that
the only other option to really
understanding what your service does in
a more structured way is to look at the
code
um having documentation that's agnostic
of the code can help with
a handoff and uh if you have good
documentation set up this is probably
one of the first things that
any team that looks to use your service
or you know start
developing on top of what you already
have is going to look at
and finally this uh specifically or
rather this is more easy
when you have open api compliance
services
it becomes easy to spin up mock services
because open api
compliant services could be understood
or documentation by
documentation that's compliant with open
api could be understood by
computers too so you can have automation
tools on top of such documentation that
spins up mock services
which could be used by your consumers in
place of your service
similar to proxying tools proxying tools
can proxy requests between
consumers and your service itself and
it's easier to
pass back responses from the proxying
tool if there is a solid documentation
available
this helps with ensuring that uh so as
far as far as there is a contract
available and it's documented well
and uh you know the promise is going to
be kept up
uh development on the backend services
side and the consumer site can actually
happen parallely
because you can spin up marked services
or you can use proxying tools
for uh proxying those requests again
mock services and proxying tools also
could help with better scenarios
maybe your service is actually not down
and you don't want to take down your
service so that consumers can test
uh what happens on their side when your
service goes down having a
mock service or a proxy tool in this
case probably more the proxying tool
can be helpful in testing those error
scenarios
so that's documentation um the last one
we'll talk about today
is using the rfc which stands for
request for comment
um which is a running document of
everything
uh http apis related including
everything that makes up http apis
and in the section we'll talk about how
following the rfc and using the rfc as a
true source of reference is very helpful
in building friendliness in tobacco
services
so as mentioned the rfc contains a lot
of information
about everything http api is related
uh there are several things in there
everything's pretty useful
but uh some of the first things or
rather there are three first things that
come to mind when i think about the rfc
and how the rfc is most useful
so those are the three things i want to
focus on today uh but this is not an
exhaustive list so i would definitely
recommend using the rfc as a source of
reference for
everything uh http and restful apis
related
the first one is headers say you've
identified the need for a custom header
uh and say you know what that custom
header is going to contain or you know
what it is
supposed to be there for it's a good
idea to go through the rfc
to find out one if there is a predefined
header already available
uh because chances are other services
that you might be talking to
would understand those headers better
than a custom header that you come up
with
and number two also figuring out if
there is a particular naming strategy
around headers again
useful for other services unless yours
is going to be a completely standalone
service
um even in that case i definitely
recommend sticking to the rfc
so uh that's using the rfc as a
reference specifically for headers
the next one is status codes um again
status codes are probably a little
obvious
especially the ones that come from the
rfc 400s for all error scenarios 500s
for all
um i'm sorry 400 for all the client
error scenarios 500s for all the server
error scenarios
um and you know mostly 200 for the
surface scenarios the consequences of
getting the
status codes mixed up when there is a
success is probably lesser
uh because no one's going to try retry
uh you know making calls to your service
when everything is going well uh
but the chances of getting the error
scenarios can be you know much
uh worse um and even within those error
scenarios say you've identified a need
to have custom status codes
so it is a 400 bad request but you
want to tell the client exactly what
went wrong and say you want to do that
actually using custom status codes um
personally i like it when uh one
i guess having no custom status quo is
always helpful
and finding you know other means to
actually have that extra information
conveyed
but if you absolutely need it making
sure that those
don't overlap with pre-defined rfc
status quotes can be helpful so for
example you know uh say there's a 400
that's going to be passed back by your
service it is a bad request that came in
from the client
um and you want to convey something more
using add custom status codes
or other custom error status codes
making sure to not pick something like a
is very helpful because 200 is
predefined by the rfc and
actually stands for something in this
case even worse it actually stands for a
success
so it can be very consuming for
developers on the consumer side to see a
in the response status but a 200 in say
the response body
um of course you know this can be fixed
with documentation but i don't think it
has to be that hard
so picking something that's completely
different from the predefined ones can
be more helpful and less
jarring and the next one is to make sure
to pick the right http verb so figure
out you know what your api is doing
uh and figuring out what http word
closely conveys what it does
uh again one of the big uses of the rfc
so let's talk about why the rfc is very
helpful and why
we should use it the first one is it's a
central source of truth
uh it contains all the information that
one might need uh when it comes to
building http apis or consuming them
and it's been around for a really long
time so making use of that central
source of truth makes it easier to
build more friendly services because
chances are consumers
are used to using services which follow
the rfc
and because the rfc is very well
documented if somebody has questions
around you know what something
means and say you're sticking to the rfc
you can just link them out to the rfc
and they can go read you know what it
means or they can get any additional
information from them
the next one is predictability again
chances are people are more used to
using
services that actually use the rfc as a
good source of reference
so your service if it does this as well
is going to be more easy to use for
consumers as well as
for people building it and finally it
leads to consistency
and this is consistency across the
industry because the rfc is you being
used by
developers all around the world who are
uh building apis and consuming apis
this will ensure that your service is
consistent with most of them so
it makes it easier to use as well and
with that
i have reached the end of all my
back-end friendly feature picks
i want to quickly conclude and talk
about all the things we talked about
today
we start off with consistent apis and
and the core of it we talked about
consistent naming we talked about all
the different things
uh that need to be named consistently
and we also went into why that's
important
next we talked about consistent error
structures and how having them
uh is very helpful especially for
consumers also a little bit for the
backend service developers itself
in uh making sure that it's easy to use
fun
uh to build and maintain then we talked
about logging and tracing
uh tracing more for distributed systems
uh which currently seems to be the trend
uh so it almost becomes a necessity and
finally we talked about why it's good to
have evaluate and have a good secret
storage tool
uh to stay out of the news for all the
wrong reasons and we went into
uh api documentation as well one of the
big considerations that i like to look
at when looking at a documentation tool
is
uh open api compliance because it's a
standard it's understood by developers
and computers alike
uh and auto generation of the api you
know as well as the code changes it's
also
uh something that can be very helpful
and finally we touched on the rfc
and uh we just talked about three things
that i like to
especially use the rfc for definitely
not just those three things
uh but those three things would be a
good place to start
and on that note i have reached the end
of my talk
uh thanks a lot for being here thanks a
lot for your attention
if you have any questions um feel free
to ask away if you have any questions or
feedback
come up after my talk uh i am genuinely
underscore super on twitter
so please don't hesitate to reach out
and have a wonderful day ahead
fantastic thank you let me just uh
thank you you can stop sharing your
screen
we have a handful of questions actually
some interesting discussion going on in
the
in the youtube chat there while we've
been uh let me just
tweak there we go uh yeah we got some
interesting chat going on about um
sharing data structures so you talked
about the importance of you know
consistency with error formats and stuff
um how do you share those data
structures between
microservices like you've got
microservice style architecture
um how do you share an arrow structure
between your projects
so i think uh again like i said you know
it's
sometimes it can be hard but uh one of
the things i like to do is you know take
a step back from the code
figure out what kind of error structures
are possible between
most microservices again if they're all
http based
uh chances are they're going to be in
the 400s and 500s
and trying to come up with a structure
that mostly works for
all of them uh i think can be can be the
first step
uh and i think if that is not possible
also looking at who the consumers are if
you have different consumers for your
different micro services architecture
uh and you know it's taking longer to
actually come up with a standard
structure
maybe it makes more sense to not have a
standard structure there
um you know again depending on the
trade-off in terms of time and
difficulty
yeah how often have you seen something
that i've seen is
when people reinvent the wheel like they
don't know that something exists in the
the rfc or the spec and so they come up
with their own way of doing it
um how often have you sort of come
across that happening in
systems you've worked on i probably
should not put a number to it
but more often than i would like to
count you know i
um i think it's just uh
mostly it's been good you know i also
have to say that mostly it's been you
know using the right uh
especially with http words it's mostly
been good it can be hard with
apis that do more than one thing where
you know you're trying to create
something but at the same time you're
trying to
get everything back uh that can be hard
but uh yeah more more often than i would
like to count
great stuff so uh we are gonna take a
very short
break uh head over to our expo
expo.nbcmanchester.com
uh fill out your details we're gonna be
running the prize draws from those uh
giving away
we got some some airpods we got some
lego sets thanks to our friends at black
marble
the airpods are from our friends over at
synopsis
and we got some ndc workshop tickets to
be given away um uh johnny said any
questions or anything uh
go find her on twitter thank you very
much jeremy for being part of it i hope
to see you
back at ndc in person uh in the not too
distant future we all hope
and next up we have and i believe that
he is on the call with us now let me do
the thing with the buttons and the
layouts and the gallery views
and say can you hear us mark randall
i can can you hear me we can hear you
it's like that's an excellent start it's
the eurovision song conference
oh god that one's bright help
there we go the eurovision song
conference and it is working beautifully
uh right check out the expo folks we are
gonna
have a quick word from our sponsors and
partners thank you all of them for
making nbc conferences happen
while we get set up backstage we will be
back in a few minutes
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
at ivendi we build technology that makes
it easier for dealers to sell
and consumers to buy vehicles
so what ibendy does is we build a
platform that facilitates online
retailing
this means that we basically make it
easier for people to buy cars and for
dealers to sell them
we do this from end to end
so the full journey from people
consumers coming to the site
right through to the finance
applications that go through so to
facilitate that we have really important
relationships with banks
with vehicle manufacturers and with
vehicle retailers themselves the tech
stack we use is mainly aws and we use
csharp.net as our predominant backend
language
and we use a little bit of azure as well
we deploy most of the stuff in
containers using kubernetes on eks
and we're a big fan of event sourcing
here that helps us to separate the
domains
out into separate areas which allows us
to
keep those domains nice and segregated
and also facilitates the auditing which
is a big part of us working in a
regulated environment
i chose ivendi mainly because of the
people they're very welcoming they're
really knowledgeable and seem really
passionate about the technology and the
quality of the products that they're
[Applause]
creating
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to margo we're an
airport-centric travel company owned by
mark
the country's largest airport group most
importantly
we're a globally unique digital tech
business based right here in manchester
we operate as an innovation hub a truly
agile e-commerce business driven by
data and the latest tech to provide
airports across the world with a unique
blend of products
technologies and services for their
passengers we have become synonymous
with airport customer ecommerce
platforms which were constantly evolving
if you plan to fly again in the near
future you may well use our system
without realizing that it's actually a
mango product we are a business for
someone who wants to create
and do something a bit different for the
techies
we have a fail fast ci cd approach
using.net core at the back
view and react to the front and aws
cloud hosting expect to grow our team
over the coming year so please keep an
eye on our mango linkedin page for the
latest jobs thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello internet and uh we are back
live here with uh my my good friend and
occasional comedy collaborator and and
all sorts of things uh
mr mark rundle how are you doing mark
i'm doing very well thank you what have
you been there so
you're going to be talking to us very
shortly about a a subject i
i know is very close to your heart which
is yes
migrating things tell us a bit more
about that i'm all about migrating
things
um yeah since microsoft
announced net five so back in
uh early 2019 i think and they said the
version of
net core after 3.1 is going to be net
five
um and sort of officially going please
please stop using.net four point
anything at all
because we don't want to keep supporting
it and i think you know currently the
end of life
dot net four point everything is 20 2029
um and so that'd be a very keen
that is a worryingly futuristic sounding
year for something which is only two
olympics away
always yes don't even
and the thing is the older you get the
more the faster
time goes past and so you know you go oh
that's not for
eight years yet and then that eight
years is going to go by in a couple of
weeks yeah when you realize that movies
like blade runner and back to the future
2 are now set in the past
you were talking about.net yeah um and
so
i've i've become very interested in
helping people to get themselves off
of.net foreign.net5.net six and all the
exciting new stuff
and so i've got my my commercial product
visual recode
which is a visual studio plugin that
helps you so it migrates wcf services to
grpc
it helps you just upgrade your projects
so
if you've got a class library you can
upgrade it to the new sdk
cs proj format and then um
and dual target it with like net
standard 2.0 or 2.1 or whatever
um but there's a big
and hopefully i'm going to get it to do
asp.net web api
and possibly even a bit of asp.net mvc
it'll help it won't do it automatically
because there's a lot of complexity in
there
but there's this one kind of big scary
thing sitting there in the middle of all
of this which is web forms
um and um
yeah there's there's no sort of
automated way
to migrate your web forms applications
and
and you could make one if somebody had
built an application
using just what was in the box
with asb net web forms then you could
probably do it
but nobody did that um everybody used
infrasticks or component one
or dev express you know these
complicated control suites
um and so yeah there's there's no way
you can do it and so
yeah what i'm talking about today is um
is there a way that you can do it
manually that your business is going to
let you do
um because yeah you've got
hundreds of thousands of lines of blah
in your so i was actually i i was uh i
was in romania yesterday
in the afternoon um i was in i was in
london at lunchtime and then i was in
romania for the afternoon and then i was
home for the evening and today i'm in
manchester
because marvelous we can beam now we
don't need to fly we just push a button
and there you go
um no i was i was at code camp romania
and i caught some of scott hanselman's
presentation there and he's he's talking
about some uh
um you know migration tools for
different apis that uh
you know one of the interesting things
that he was saying is you know the tool
it doesn't just you give it your code
and it spits out a bunch of files and a
bunch of errors
it kind of goes through step by step and
it says okay this is fine this is fine
this thing here needs to be replaced
with that thing
this thing we don't have a fix for so
we're going to put it on your to-do list
and yeah you know i i love that idea of
a tool that is both a migration
assistant but also it kind of
shows you the the old way the new way um
yeah
there was a i was talking to some folks
yesterday the other event i did
yesterday was city js which was
javascripty and i
i made the the mistake of saying in a
conference talk that jquery is dead
and uh two things you can guarantee
about jquery if you
if you say we're using jquery everybody
on twitter immediately goes but jquery's
dead
and if you say jquery's dead everybody
on twitter immediately goes no it's not
there's a new release
yes but you know that that was to me a
really interesting uh
a compelling framework that was
incredibly popular because it fixed a
lot of
important problems and now a lot of
those problems kind of the browsers have
fixed them behind the scenes and under
the hood and stuff
yeah yeah and so looking at the feature
parity there's a bunch of stuff in you
know reading the browser specs now
you're like i don't really understand
what that does
but if you see the side by side like
this is how you did it in jquery and now
this is how you do it
um and you know dotnet.net framework web
forms winforms whatever it is
to you know something's like hey this i
do it in winforms is how you do it in
maui that kind of thing i think could be
really
really interesting yeah um and when i
started out with
with recode with the with the product um
i was aiming for just tell me the
service contract
and i will just generate the entire
thing for you
but experience over the last year
has taught me that it that's just
too complicated and and you can't
guarantee that you're going to do it out
of the box and if you can't guarantee
that you're going to be able to just do
it
out of the box it's better to go down
that route
of i'm i'm an assistant
i'm going to sit here and i'm going to
say right so
tell me which service contract you would
like to migrate to grbc all right let's
look at what you need to do
so that references these projects or it
uses these types in these projects
and so these projects need to be
upgraded so let's let's upgrade these
projects
one at a time to support net standard
2.0 or net 5.0 or whatever it is you're
migrating to
and then as we're going along with that
we can say
oh no you're using ionic.zip is one of
my favorites
everybody used ionic.zip
and there is no net standard version of
ionic.zip there you go everybody
watching on the stream there is your
opportunity we need a net standard
api compatible replacement for ionic.zip
come on and actually do this all it
needs to be is a shim
around the zip library that is now built
into net
um but was not there when ionic.zip was
released
but yeah and you know almost be i i
really have to resist the temptation to
turn it into a clippy
yeah and and just where in visual studio
if you've got the plug-in installed and
you open a wcf application and go
it looks like you're editing a wcf
application would you like to migrate it
to grpc
surely there's an opportunity there to
kind of standardize all of the you know
the static analysis tools and the
migration tools and everything we just
need to come up with a standard format
for how they communicate their
recommendations and then you can build
your own clients
so we can have we could have a clippy
client and we could have you know uh
something that that does it using lego
mindstorms and one that do
does it using google home and all this
kind of stuff yes
we do actually have a question in the
chat before we've even started mark tell
us about the posters
in the background the posters in the
background
are um they were they were commissioned
by nasa
quite a few years ago and they are um
imaginary travel agents photos for
destinations throughout the solar system
and so there's europa and titan
um and and enceladus which are my three
favorite moons in the whole solar system
uh team ganymede ganon middle or get out
ganymede's good
io is also brilliant the most volcanic
moon in the solar system you know do you
know the remarkable thing about
enceladus
uh no it is the most
spherical object in astronomy
really is it more more spherical than
europa
yeah enceladus is basically the surface
is ice
and it is ice that occasionally melts
because of
gravitationally induced heat and then
refreezes very quickly
so if you put a mountain on enceladus
it'll be gone in the morning
that's brilliant and it is the most
spherical object that astronomers have
found anywhere which i i think is
brilliant
that is cool and it's got a little
hexagon on the bottom that looks like an
engine but we won't go into that
yes um but no europa's quite rough got
lots of crags and stuff because it's so
close to jupiter and it gets ripped
apart and
freezes back together so often um titan
uh actually it was on this day in 1655
that christian huygens discovered
titan there you go um and and titan is a
brilliant moon because
um it's it's 2.5 times smaller than
earth
which means that gravity is only 13
percent
so if you were on titan you could
probably jump 10 meters straight up into
the air
and you wouldn't hurt yourself when you
came down but also even better
the atmosphere is three to four times
thicker than the atmosphere on earth
which means if you just made yourself a
pair of cardboard wings
you could fly on titan just by flapping
your arms
that's fantastic except uh you would
also freeze because it's minus 150
celsius
looks like water is actually methane
you'd need a suit
obviously you would but you could paint
it in cool colors and fly around did you
ever see the xkcd thing about getting
into orbit from the moons of mars um
yes on phobos you can jump into orbit
and on damascus you need a bmx
yes oh i learned
so much about the solar system from xkc
for those of you not seen it xkcd.com
randall monroe does these
wonderful little cartoons about science
and mathematics and
machines and information theory and
they're absolutely brilliant but
anyway i make it a quarter past the hour
which means the agenda says
it is time to learn all about migrating
things from uh
net.net old versions to net new versions
so i am going to queue up the uh layout
if you want to start sharing your screen
share my screen i will punch them
the stage is yours mr randall thank you
very much um
it is fantastic to be here in manchester
thank you very much for hosting it's a
it's a beautiful city
i did actually live in manchester for 18
months um when i was
18 or 19. um back when the hacienda was
still open
well it's not uh i didn't live in
manchester i lived in salford which is
in the middle of manchester but isn't in
manchester it's in
uh lancashire um and it's surrounded by
manchester and then there's more
lancashire it's weird
it's like a little donut but yes i'm
going to talk to you about migrating
your web apps to asp.net core one page
at a time
um i am mark rendell you can uh
follow me on twitter mark rendall
and you can watch me on twitch on
tuesdays and thursdays
at twitch.tv slash mark rendell so why
why do you want to migrate your web apps
and and specifically your asp.net web
forms apps
to net5 and dotnet six and
beyond uh basically because this
um asp.net web forms in 2021
uh is is a dumpster fire on so many
levels
um it's
it's a really shonky model for building
web applications that was designed
to hide the fact that you were building
a web application so you didn't have to
worry about things like http
and browsers and and even html to a
certain extent
um it's not going to be supported um
in any meaningful way from now on um
microsoft will continue to
sort of issue security patches and
things
but also because if you have an asp.net
web forms
application that you are maintaining in
um i would in a sort of
um large spread spread betting hedging
kind of way
i would bet good money that it is an
absolute dumpster fired just
in terms of the code that's inside it
yes not all web forms and that's why i
would do a spread bet
because there are web forms applications
out there
that are beautifully coded beautifully
architected well structured using best
practices i've never seen one
but there are they are out there
what i have seen would just turn your
hair white
like that that's why his hair was white
in the movie because he'd seen things
you people wouldn't believe
um i've seen if statements on fire
off the shoulder of orion i saw an if
statement
in a web forms application recently
that had over 400 or clauses
in a single if statement and
they were comparing a string to a
pre-defined
is it one of these strings and so all
the strings they were comparing against
were lowercase
and in every single one of those or
clauses
they called dot trim dot to lower
on the string so potentially if it
matched the last one
they created um 800
strings by the time they got to the end
of that
which is just a garbage collection
nightmare
web forms made it very very easy for bad
programmers
to create applications and that meant
that a lot of bad programmers created
applications using web forms
which means that there is a lot of bad
code
out there hiding in web forms
applications
so i've convinced you what do we want to
move to where we want to move to asp.net
core
because asp net core is brilliant why is
it brilliant well
it runs on linux for a start which means
you're not paying
licenses for your hosting environment
and you can run in containers
in kubernetes clusters and docker
containers and
azure container instances and whatever
google
and amazon's equivalent of azure
container instances are
which is just uh that's that's what you
want to be doing in this day and age
it's stupid fast um it is ridiculously
fast
there's a thing called the tech in power
benchmarks an asb net core
when it started out was not doing
particularly well but
it has been optimized the kestrel web
server has been optimized
um beyond all belief it does amazing
things
scary scary code in there so it is
stupid fast
and um the the key thing about that
is that if your web server is fast if
your the framework you're running on is
fast it means you can serve more
requests per second
on a single machine and if you conserve
more requests per second on a single
machine
then you can run fewer or smaller
machines
which actually saves you money in terms
of your hosting costs so
that's good too and asb net core is
actively developed there are a bunch of
microsoft's best people working on asb
net core
and there's a bunch of highly motivated
open source contributors from the wider
community who are putting stuff in there
and so asp net core continues to grow
continues to improve
so you want to move your web forms code
into asp.net core but there is a problem
web forms is not supported in.net core
or dotnet 5.0 so you can't
start running on that and then gradually
migrate over
but more importantly asp.net core
since version 2.1 was released i think
doesn't run on.net 4 anymore
certainly the currently supported uh the
lts version netcore 3.1
um and later do not run
on.net 4. so you can't do a gradual
migration
and i don't know if you've ever gone to
your business
and said hey you know the half a million
lines of code in our
application well the the the thing
that those half a million lines of code
are written in
isn't very good anymore and isn't
supported anymore so what we'd like to
do
is stop working on on new features and
supporting our customers
and just rewrite the whole thing um in
in in the new thing that's much better
um and the business says how long will
that take
and you say well if you give me a team
of six people it'll take
a year and a half and they say what if
we give you a team of 12 people
and you say then it will never get done
because
man months
so you want a gradual migration process
so one existing solution to this there
is a
an open source ish thing out there but
also
not um with pricing on its website
called vvm um which is a kind of
it's like a modernized version of web
forms um
that uses the mvvm pattern
and that runs in both.net 4 and
net core 3.1 and net 5.0 and so
you can migrate gradually across and
they do actually talk about this on
their website they say you can modernize
on the fly
so you can while you're still running in
asp.net
4 you can start you can migrate
your pages one page at a time to
vvm and then once they're all done you
can just take your
vvm code and say now it runs on.net five
and we can throw away half of our
servers because it's so much faster and
better
so that is is one option um
which i'm not going to be talking about
because i have another
solution um so
i was bumbling my way around the
internet
a few months ago and i came across
a project from microsoft called yarp
which stands for yet another reverse
proxy
and this is it's a reverse proxy like
nginx or traffic or h a proxy or any of
those things
but this one is written in
net and it's an asp.net core application
and actually it's not even an asp.net
core application it's an asp.net core
nuget package that you drag into your
asp.net core application
and then you just add it to your uh to
your pipeline
um so you can drag that in there and i
was looking at this
and i had one of those moments i thought
hang on a minute lads
i've got a great idea
what if you put that proxy
package into an actual asp.net core
application
that had pages and controllers
and views and and all that sort of stuff
and then if the new application
had the address that the browser was
looking for
then it would serve it from within
itself and if it didn't
it would just proxy it back through to a
web forms application running behind it
so yeah in this
powerpoint clip art smart text whatever
the hell this
is slide that i've made because i don't
do
pictures i find pictures on google
images
and and i use built-in things in
powerpoint
but yeah um and i thought i wonder if
this would work
and so i started looking into it and
then it turned out
that this actually has this is a pattern
um
an official pattern and it's only an
official pattern
if martin fowler has written about it on
his blicky everybody knows that
um and martin fowler
coined this as a pattern and called it
strangler fig
actually he initially called it
strangler um and then people went
great pattern kind of not good on the
name though martin call it something
else and so he called it strangler fig
because
his inspiration was the strangler fig
plants banyan trees and things like that
these
are seeds that actually
they take root and germinate in the
branches of other trees
and then their roots grow down into the
ground and then
they throttle and kill the tree that
they were growing around
so yes that's where that comes from and
so i decided i was going to have a go at
building this and
at the same time i decided that i'm so
important and fascinating that people
will surely want to just watch me do
things on the internet
and so i started twitch streaming um and
so i combined the two things and i'm
going to build this on
um my twitch channel and people can come
along and watch and and that's been
happening and it's been quite good fun
so let's do a quick demo does anybody
remember
wingtip toys
wingtip toys was a demo application i'm
going to run wingtip toys here
it was an asp.net forms demo application
from years and years and years back and
as soon as this page loads you'll go
wow that really was years and years back
come on page load see i told you web
forms was slow
this is this is a very powerful pc i'm
using here
um so yes this is wingtip toys and this
is an asp.net web forms application
and it's it to sort of date it for you
it's using bootstrap three um and i
think we're currently on bootstrap
five so yes it's it's a few years old
but um wingtip toys it's got
cars and planes and boats and it's got a
shopping cart and i can add that to my
cart and then
we've got a one thing in the cart and
various other things are going on there
and so i thought i'm going to use this
and i'm going to try and replace
one thing at a time and we'll see if we
can get that to work
and so i started out
with mvc and razer why have you got
missing dependencies don't do that to me
microsoft dot reverse proxy needs
upgrading
no it doesn't let's just go into here
and i'm going to
take that out and then we should be okay
so yes what i'm showing you is is kind
of the end result here because i'm not
going to do live coding
we've only got 45 minutes for this talk
and that is not enough time
but this is an mvc
application and so my wing tip toys
um example page here
um we have a site.master and site.master
is our sort of
it's what asp.net web forms used to have
instead
of um
instead of a layout.cshtml and so this
is our kind of base site here
where we've got script references and
lots of run-out servers
and all that sort of stuff there and so
in my um
my cocoon application i went with cocoon
as a name
because strangler is just nasty
so in my layout.cshtml
i basically copied everything across and
i downgraded my
shiny new.net5 razer application
to use bootstrap 3
and copied over the css and javascript
files from the old
web forms application and so i
i created this and
then i went in and in my home controller
i added an index thing here and
i added my view here which does this
and so when i run this application
you will see he said confidently
that an error occurred while processing
the request
because my connection
string is wrong in this version of the
application
and let's try that again
it's not a proper demo if it doesn't
crash first time
there we go um so
that's running over there so i mean
localhost 2401.9 at the moment
and if i go to localhost 5001
you can see that i've got my slightly
broken home page
from my wingtip toys
2. so my the
the default page is wingtip toys and
where i've replaced the page
i've changed it to wingtip toys too so
this is my
um my asp.net core 5.0 application but
if i go to
about this just proxies back through
to the um actually no that is
i i struggle to remember okay so this is
yeah here we go
the about page is coming from the same
place
from the old um server and
the products page is coming from the old
server but the home page is coming from
the new server
so if i go into uh products on
here and then i go add to cart
and you see we've got two things in my
cart there and i go
back here um my
cart uh item here is not showing up
for reasons um
so this this works very nicely
and i thought i think i'm onto something
here and i think this this would help a
lot of people out
um and so um i started thinking through
the
the sort of additional issues and i'm
actually working on web forms
applications
um during the day at the moment on my
consultancy work
um and tragically uh i am working
on maintaining and supporting legacy web
forms applications
because you can't replacing them is so
difficult
but i have been exposed to a lot of web
form stuff and one thing that i've
noticed
um happens a lot in web form
applications one thing that is
used a huge amount is session
web forms applications love session they
love session and they love view state
um and if a web forms application
wants to if a web forms page wants to
redirect
to another web forms page and pass a
parameter
while it does it it won't do that by
adding a query string to the url
for the page that it's going to pass to
no it will put the parameter into
session
and then it will just redirect to the
other page and then the other page will
load and get it
out of session sessions very very
important
and so if you're going to gradually
migrate a page at a time
from an old web forms application to a
new core application
you need a way for them to be able to
share session
and and work on the same session state
and so the first thing that i
implemented
in my specialized proxy for this
was a way to share session um
and on the server side um
it's really weird both these things are
servers so when i say back end
i'm talking about the web forms
application and when i say front end i'm
talking about the asp.net core
application even though it's not front
end in the sense
that it's not a spa it's not an angular
application or anything like or react or
anything like that
so in the back end application um we
added a session api handler
and we drop it in as an api handler so
that it can be distributed as a nuget
package
and it implements our http handler and
you just
pass it a get and the key for the value
that you want
or a put so you can update session as
well
and and it shares the session and then
from the other side from the cocoon
application or the front end application
we have recode cocoon proxy and we have
a session
uh provider in here and this is not
it does not integrate with the built-in
session in asp.net core because the
built-in session in asp.net core is much
better behaved
it does not allow you to say hey can you
just put this enormous object graph into
session for me please
um because uh that doesn't scale
um and another thing you see a lot with
web forms applications
is that they have sticky session
or sticky routing so
in the rare case where they are actually
running multiple instances of their
server for redundancy and failover
they uh they use in-memory
session storage so that they can dump
huge object graphs that won't serialize
into them
um and then they just make sure that uh
each client gets
sticky rooted to um to the same server
every time they make a request so that
their session stays
intact asb net core doesn't do any of
that and the only thing you can put into
session or get out of session
in asb net core is a byte array um and
that's right and good and that is how it
should be
so what the cocoon session provider does
is it just provides its own session
implementation
that you can register with dependency
injection and pass stuff around
and it will cache values over the course
of a request so if you
call session.getvalue multiple times it
won't keep going to the backend server
and then when the request ends and the
session the scoped session object is
disposed
it updates the back end server with all
those bits of information
oh and it has this brilliant
this is interned numbers from
zero to nine because
when you're doing when you're setting
tags in in diagnostics and things
and you want to do a count you want to
put a count on something
then if you just go oh i've got an
integer so i've created my integer and
now i'm going to
put it on this in this dictionary of
string object and so you'll box that
integer
um and if you end up doing that a lot
then then you
you do a lot of allocated things which
is bad so if you
this is just a general tip if you have a
situation where you are constantly
boxing
an integer and you have a constrained
range of integers that it could be
then just once create a static read-only
object array with those integers in it
and then index into that array
and you will not need to box integers
repeatedly
see this is the kind of thing that
starts to matter when you're doing
asp.net core coding
because performance is king and
everything's so fast and you don't want
to slow it down
didn't matter at all in in web forms
applications
you know in web forms applications we'd
just box a few integers
just to keep the cpu busy while we were
doing something else
because because we just didn't care
um so yes this is this is the session
wrapper here
and so this gets passed around and then
somewhere hiding in my mvc cocoon
application i've got a tag helper and
i've got a cart link tag helper here
which gets a shopping cart injected into
it and my shopping cart
is in my service thing here and this
gets cocoon
session um injected and then
when i want to get the count of how many
items are in the cart
we go to get count async and then we say
session dot get async
cart id and that returns back the cart
id that's set in the session on the
other side
but what the session provider is
actually doing the cocoon session
client is it's copying across
any cookies that have been set
by the backend application
to in its call
so that session on the back end just
works magically didn't have to do
anything clever there at all
um and so that handles session and i
think session will start to work if i
log in so if i log in this takes me back
i don't want to use any of those thank
you this is now
uh the back end application you can see
we've got our cart 2 there
and if i log in as admin and the
password on this is p at
dollar dollar word no
p a
dollar dollar wrd
yes there we go um
so now i'm back onto my my home page
there and my cart
tag helper has stopped working why is my
cart tag helper not there
what is wrong with you views
shared layout
that's that's my cart link there that
should be working i don't know why
that's not working
i'm not going to go in and debug it now
trust me it works
um most of the time it's just stopped in
this particular instance
i'm actively working on this on a sort
of
every other day basis and so stuff does
sometimes break trust me session works
it absolutely does i promise
um so that
was was the session uh side of things
dealt with
so the asp.net core app doesn't do
session itself it just passes back
through to the web forms app
and the idea is that um once your web
forms app is
has been completely strangled and has
died and you go to your asp.net core app
you implement an alternative version of
the session provider
that probably does wrap over asb net
core session and takes care of
serializing and deserializing objects
in that way one more thing about that
so the session serialization
is handled by message pack
because binary object serializer or
binary formatting
serializer binary formatter whatever
it's called
um is bad um
and you shouldn't use it and it's a
security nightmare and
it's being deprecated don't use it and
so
technically it's in.net 5 but they are
talking about putting the deprecated or
obsolete attribute on it
at any point and so it uses um message
pack serialization to pass things
backwards and forwards
um so that
that's how session is handled um
and so apart from session the other
thing
that you need to be able to share
between the two applications
as we just saw is authentication
and again the easiest way to do this
because lord only knows how web forms
applications authenticate themselves it
was
it was windows authentication or or
um kerberos authentication or
whatever it was the easiest way to get
this working
is just to leave the login page on the
old web form server
and let it do the login and set the
cookies that it's doing and all this
sort of stuff
and then in the asp.net core application
for authentication just ping a message
to the backend server and go hello are
we authenticated who are we
authenticated as
give me all the information and so to
achieve that
we wrote i wrote
an authentication handler and again on
the back end
there is an auth api handler and this
basically says if the context user is a
claims principle
because it let's let's hope it is if
it's a windows principle
then somebody's going to open an issue
on the github repository for this and
say
i'm using windows principles and they
don't serialize properly and i'll see if
i can fix it
but if it's a claims principle we can
say is it authenticated
and if they're not we just return a 401
which is fine
and if it is then we serialize the
claims principle
that was fun um have you ever tried
serializing the claims principle is not
designed to be serialized
a claims principle contains a claims
identity which has a reference to the
claims principle
and the claims identity has a collection
of claims each of which has a reference
to the claims identity which has a
reference to the claim which has a
reference to the claims identity which
has a reference to the claims principle
which has a reference to the claims idea
um and any sort of out of the box
serializer will just go
and die um so i wrote custom claims
principle serialization again using
message pack which is a superb format
and i love it a lot
and so the front end says to the back
end
um hello are we authenticated
and if the back end is authenticated it
says yes we
are and then that means that
um in the front end application
so if i go uh if i log in here
and i log in as add min and
uh p a dollar dollar wrd
if i go to admin in here
you will see that this is a terrible
terrible web forms page
and there's no kind of list of the
things that are in the database and you
just have this ad product and you can
remove a product by choosing it from
this
it's just it's it's not good and so
we can rewrite this admin page as
um as a lovely sort of proper modern
style web application
and we can have an add a new product
thing that goes to this lovely
page here and then we click submit and
and all sorts of good things happen
and so that's that's sort of the the
basic principle behind what i'm talking
about here
and the thing that i really like about
it
is that it is
primarily and its its inception
was for upgrading web forms applications
but as long as you can write the
necessary back end
services so as long as you can write the
the equivalent of the session
api handler and the auth api handler
you could use this to upgrade anything
you could use this to upgrade a classic
asp application
as long as you can find a way of doing
message pack serialization in vbscript
but you know you could wrap the message
pack serialization in an activex object
or whatever it was we used to do in
in classic asp you could use this to
upgrade a php application
although you could also just run your
php application on.net core
using peach pie um but yes you could use
it to upgrade a pearl
cgi application that was written in 1996
the possibilities are endless and then
so having kind of proved this out and
gone yet no this would work and this is
entirely feasible
um people who were watching on the trips
on the twitch stream started saying well
what about blazer
because when microsoft said no more web
forms
that we are not supporting web forms
it's a bad product and you're a bad
person for liking it
they said what we recommend instead is
blazer
um and i hadn't really mucked about with
blazer until
somebody started asking about it in here
that that punctuation thing at the end
there is an enterobang by the way and
it's absolutely my favorite punctuation
character it's an exclamation mark and a
question mark
in the same character because i
just have no idea which one which way
round they're supposed to go if you use
both of them
so we started looking into blazer
because
blazer is actually um it's easier to
write blazer applications than it is to
write razor pages or
or model view controller applications um
blazer
once i started playing with it and i was
very very privileged
in that because my first ever experience
with blazer happened on a twitch stream
um and i tweeted about it and
got retweeted and steve sanderson
actually turned up in my twitch stream
and watched as i learned blazer for the
first time
um and was going press shift and alt and
f12
um it was great but no blazer is
uh is really the ideal thing for for
migrating a web forms application
too um and there's a brilliant
um project by jeff fritz and people
called blazer web forms components where
they are
re-implementing um the sort of
fundamental web forms components like
uh repeater view and add rotator
and and all those things as blazer
components
to make it easier and they've got a
migration guide on there
and i'm hoping to sort of talk to jeff
and and
these people and say hey can we sort of
mention cocoon in here
because cocoon will quite happily work
with
a um a blazer application as well
so let's start out let's look at uh
blazer web assembly first
so this is a blazer web assembly
application um
and here's my blazer cocoon server
and so in here um we basically just say
so this is how we're setting it up in
asp.net call we add cocoon session
um we add scopes shopping cart we add
controllers with views and razer pages
and cocoon proxy
and db context pool oh this is another
interesting thing actually so
the wingtip toys application uses entity
framework
and i was a bit worried about that but i
copied
um the wingtip toys context across and i
just
this is using entity framework core 5.0
um and i pretty much just you know
copied it across and
it works with the same database the the
syntax for calling it is slightly
different
but it essentially just worked i i
didn't really have to do much mucking
about with that at all
um but yes and then in our
um in our
configure method here um we just have we
have use authentication and
authorization
and we have use endpoints and map cocoon
proxy with blazer
because there was a weird thing to do
with routing but if i run this
application
so this is blazer web assembly
and this
there you go um if you can see that this
is the webassembly application
running in the browser and
if i click this this has fallen back
through to the old wingtip toys site as
before
and if i click log in then i can
log in here as admin and p at
that no pa dollar word
and hit login no don't want to save that
and now okay so now the session's
actually working here
once i'd logged in um session did
actually start
throwing me um because the admin user
i've logged in as him a lot and
the shopping cart gets saved in the
database
um and the only thing uh
yes the the session id becomes
consistent
so i can see my cart there that'll take
me into
the web forms applications but if i go
into admin
you saw the little loading thing there
which is the giveaway that this is a
blazer webassembly application
and i pretty much just copied the razer
stuff across from
the mvc application but this is a blazer
admin page
for our asp.net web forms application
and yeah everything in here works in
just the same way
um and i have to say um
i was a little bit uh
skeptical about blazer when i when i
first heard about it
um and it wasn't that i thought it was
bad
it's that a lot of people were going oh
this is the best thing since sliced
bread
this is the savior of the internet and i
thought it can't be that good can it
but actually since i've started mucking
about with it yes it can it really can
um there's there's a lot of good stuff
to say about blazer um let me just drop
into that admin page so we've got our
pages here
um and our admin.razer page here
and i'm just going to run i know that
steve sanders i think steve sanderson
did
or somebody did a blazer talk earlier
but yes this
so there's my my html in there
and we say if products is null then just
show loading otherwise
render this table thing here and then we
have this
uninitialized async and so i had to add
an api
to my server application
so i've got my
admin controller here which has got a
api admin products and then that's
pulling stuff through because this is
blazer wasm which means we can no longer
just do
um talk directly to entity framework
um but yes you just do this and you say
products equals await get jason from
async
and then you say products equals
products.order by um
to array and then that magically sort of
triggers
something to change up here in in the
sort of way that angular and react
and things do and it re-renders the page
um
and that's it's that's just super super
awesome
um and so yeah the only uh
there's a custom thing in here called
cocoon authentication
um which is a custom blazer
authentication component
that makes an api call to the um
to the new front-end to
to the cocoon server the cocoon
front-end server which does the same
thing and goes to the back end server
to check if you're authenticated and
then returns the information back down
here so you get
uh the the claims principle comes down
to your
cocoon client and so that was good that
worked perfectly
um and so that was blazer wasm dealt
with
um and then i thought what about blazer
server because
there are still a couple of issues with
blazer wasm um
the big one being it's like a five
megabyte download the first time you hit
a blazer page
um because what i don't think i'd
appreciated
i thought blazer was um in my
head it was that you wrote an asp.net m
core nvc application and it compiled a
bunch of it to javascript
um and then threw that down into your
site but that's not what it does they've
compiled
like the whole of.net into wasm
and then it actually downloads net
standard assemblies
into your browser and runs them on a
net runtime that's what it and that is
nuts that is absolutely nuts
one experiment i'm planning on doing
soon is um
the microsoft open xml
package for working with office
documents
has a net standard build and so i'm
going to see if i can make a blazer
application
which can open an excel spreadsheet in
the browser without ever having to
upload it
to the server just as an experiment i'm
going to do that on twitch one day soon
it'll be on twitter when i decide to do
it but
um that big download for for a public
facing website especially a
public-facing website going hey
buy my fancy new slippers that are made
out of lucite
and electricity you want
that to load very very quickly otherwise
people are going to go and buy your
their lucite
electric slippers from somewhere else
and so you might want to do something
that loads a little bit faster
and you can't actually get something
that loads much faster
than blazer server because what that
does
is it renders the first page on the
server and then throws it down to the
client so
it's just a static html page and it's
got a tiny little bit
of javascript that goes down with it
tiny especially compared to things like
angular's runtime or even the react
runtime
um and then it has a web sockets
connection
um and the application runs on the back
end
on the server and it just sends tiny
little
like diffs down over the
websocket to the browser going hey
change that
change that so it's doing the sort of
like the the shadow dom the virtual dom
whatever that dom thing is that react
invented it's doing that but it's doing
it over a websocket
and that's really exciting because that
that makes for
super fast pages but still being able to
write all your complex business logic
in c-sharp instead of having to try and
um translate it into typescript and then
worry about angular's dependency
injection system
or reacts general awfulness and redux
and things of that nature and so uh can
i get it to work with blazer server and
actually it's pretty much the same thing
except instead of having two
applications i've got
one because blazer server runs all in
one thing and the only thing that was
really funky about it
was handling the routing
because blazer server just wanted to
handle
everything it did not want to proxy
anything at all
and so we had to put in a thing
that said use explicit blazer routes um
and so this finds out what all the
blazer routes are and you pass in type
of program
so it'll find all the routes in here and
then it just uses those
um and so now we have the same thing
with cocoon
um but running in blazer server mode
um and you can see actually we're still
logged in now we're still logged in
from the blazer wasm application because
the thing was still set
and we've got our admin page which is
done in blazer server and you can just
you can see how fast things load
in this now um but i can still go back
through and this is the old
web forms page at the back end and so
there you go
this is this is my master plan for
getting everybody including you you
lucky lucky person
off of the horrible web forms or the
horrible classic asp
or the horrible whatever it is you've
got running on the back end
and if you have got classic asp and
you'd like to look into this then drop
by the github repository
and say so and we can look at building
uh some classic asp
um components to make the authentication
and session work
if you want more information on it then
you can get that from github.com
visual recode cocoon so i should say
that yes this is um
it's kind of branded with visual recode
which is a commercial product but it is
not a commercial product it is
fully open source and apache license too
and
out there on the internet and not tied
to
visual recode in any way although visual
recode might support
it it will never require visual recode
all the packages are published and
in summary it's based on microsoft's
excellent work with microsoft reverse
proxy aka yarp
that's the github thing that's me on
twitter
and on twitch come join me on twitch
tuesday and thursday evening 7 p.m uk
time
where i work on cocoon and when i'm done
with cocoon
um i might try and make simple data 3
using source generators
you never know we'll see what happens
thanks very much for joining me ndc
manchester i hope that was helpful and
fun and i will see you
hopefully in real manchester next year
and we can drink boddingtons
and sing songs and and
make friends with people we've never met
before because manchester's brilliant
thanks very much bye
you want to stop sharing your screen
mark
thank you very much mr randall if you'd
like to stop sharing your screen
now uh we we have an entire dot-net rock
show waiting here in the studio if i
switch to the gallery view
there we go look at that we have a uh
a veritable rogues gallery including
i think you can see me in the corner of
my own screen there hello everybody
that's what i really look like right now
how are you all doing
so uh we just uh we got one one question
for you mark in the chat which is from
me
but i'm going to ask anyway because it's
my question um
do you think that we are going to see
any legacy apps that
they just figure out how to recompile
them straight to web assembly
instead of the whole take the legacy and
port that to core and then the core runs
on blazer and then blazer runs in the
browser
do you think we're gonna see like like
uh i don't know web forms
direct to webassembly so you can run it
in a browser
i did actually um this is way beyond my
ability to
to to investigate but um
blazers uh net runtime in in wasm
is based on mono and mono did have an
implementation of web forms
um and so i am wondering if you could
just take mono's
implementation of web forms which isn't
dependent on all the windows stuff like
the asp.net
web forms is but yes just take the web
forms
from mono and throw it into the browser
and just
run all those controls and and
um things that run at server now just
run at wasm instead um
i have a something to add to that effect
all right so um in dot net six time
frame
blazer wasm will be using ahead of time
compiling
which does what you're saying it really
compiles
everything directly to webassembly
before it goes
down to webassembly so you'll have the
disadvantage it won't be in a run time
but you have the advantage of speed and
also today
in dot net 5 you can use uh
pre-rendering in laser web assembly just
like you can in blazer server so that
speeds things up
and also lazy loading so that's it
yeah so there are ways and it is getting
faster but i think in.net six
steph will just become much faster yeah
um and my aim with cocoon is to have it
sort of um
sort of battle ready uh for the dot net
six
time frame so that there are beta
packages at the moment um
but yeah i'm really gonna start pushing
this when dot net six
comes along and blazer wasm is yeah
you're right
it's gonna wait it's gonna light up so
nicely
great presentation i enjoyed it so we
got a question
in the youtube chat steve collins says
hi mark any gotchas with both cocoon
pages and web forms pages sharing
cookies
uh no there's also a cookie so if you're
doing weird
encrypted cookie things um then there is
a thing that will
uh do a pass through on a cookie to
decrypt it from the back end
but for the most part if you're not
encrypting your cookies um or using that
that sort of security stuff it's fine
because
um it's not like a javascript front end
thing where you might have http only
cookies that javascript can't see
proxies always have access to the entire
http request and response
the only thing that there was a bit of
weirdness with was
when the back end server did redirect
the location header
um included the domain including the
port and so
i've put in a little thing that just
checks the response and if the location
header
mentions the um
the the sort of absolute url then it
changes it to
point to the same address but on the
proxy server but no i haven't
run into any issues with with cookies
other than those things
so there you go are there any gotchas no
nice answer
that was a very long way of saying shall
i use cocoon or msal for a new blazer
project
he says i've got a tenant and azure
um cocoon is if you've got a back end
thing
that you want to migrate um cocoon is a
brilliant way to do it
gradually uh one page at a time um
and yeah but you know if you're just
building a completely new application
then just
just build it in blazer um
and the really nice thing with blaze you
know start building it
if you want to use server now because in
net5
the wasm stuff's a bit slow that's the
build time there's quite a lot of
interpreting going on in the browser
um then you can run it on server for the
time being and then it's
it's pretty straightforward to to
migrate that to
laserwise wiser when dot net 6 comes out
but yes absolutely if you want to
migrate something if you've got a
website
even if it's asp.net mvc
and it's nicely crafted and everything
but you want to migrate it to blazer
then you can use cocoon
to do it one page at a time with no
downtime
fantastic thank you very much one last
question andy clark does it need special
config to handle tls
https um no
it's just whatever the the config is for
an asp.net core application
so your backend server you would hide
from the public internet so that would
no longer be available
and you would turn off tls on your back
end server i would imagine
or if they're running on the you know
you could
leave it on but yes so
uh the the proxy the cocoon the new
front end application
would essentially act as an ssl
termination point um
before hitting the back end server so
um there are no issues there fantastic
all right
uh very shortly we are going to be
handing over the
virtual stage here to close out ndc
manchester 2021
with uh carl and richard doing a special
live edition of dot net rocks with ian
cooper talking about test driven
development
but before we do that we have some
prizes that we have
failed to give away thus far we got a
couple of things left in the the ndc
swag bag here and so we are gonna run
the last of uh today's live quizzes
head on over to slido.com
ndcmcr or the code ndcmcr
um and we are gonna give away we got one
more live quiz for you here then we're
gonna do some uh
some draws so head over to
expo.ndcmanchester.com if you haven't
entered yet we're going to be drawing
the prizes for those
in a few moments um so we got one more
rapid fire quiz for you five questions
multiple choice to win a nbc conferences
or workshop ticket
and the special limited edition ndc
hoodies we got some of those coming up
for you as well
uh so just give it a minute let folks
get signed up for that now this round
is all about ndc it is testing your
knowledge out there of this uh
wonderful series of events that are
started out in i'm not going to tell you
because it might give away the answer to
one of the questions
um and has been you know growing
internationally over the years this
wonderful
worldwide community of speakers and
experts and enthusiasts and
people who just love getting together
and going hey look what i made the
computer do
isn't that awesome and then some of us
take it away and figure out how to get
paid for it
which is brilliant and uh so let's kick
off the uh the final quiz so first prize
is an ndc
uh conference or workshop ticket we got
a couple of hoodies for the runners-up
uh we are gonna kick off the quiz here
so what year was the first ndc
conference held was it held in 1988
days of c plus plus 1998 the days of
visual basic
2008 glory days of uh c-sharp and dotnet
3.5 or 2018 when it was all javascript
frameworks the correct answer is
uh 2008
and the winner of that question is
douglas cameron congratulations douglas
but it's very very close douglas and
vincent neck and neck on the timing
let's have a look at the next question
which one of these cities has not hosted
an
ndc conference is it
porto in portugal copenhagen denmark
cape town south africa
or minnesota in the usa
which one of these cities has not hosted
an ndc conference it is
cape town south africa we have not yet
taken the ndc roadshow to africa
uh jacob hint hint are you listening my
friend
big plans um yes nbc porto we had the
inaural one of those two years ago nbc
copenhagen has been running for a couple
years
and uh nbc minnesota we kicked that off
a couple years ago all fantastic cities
that i cannot wait
to visit again and put a couple more
cities on the ndc
map of the world vincent has taken the
lead
10 seconds two for two lis elta douglas
cameron aiden earnshaw sergio azevado
let's have a look at the next
question how many total hours of viewing
has the ndc conference's youtube channel
had
in the last year so the last 365 days
how many hours of viewing has that
channel racked up
and how many of those were dylan's art
of code
which has been viewed something like 2
million times now
it is uh so the art of code is a
one-hour talk with 2.4 million views
um and that talk was only put live in
march last year
so uh the correct answer is a million
hours uh it's something like
1 million 40 000 and something so
there's been a lot of folks out there
watching a lot of amazing content on the
channel
uh subscribe now you're looking at it
the button is right there you click that
little button there
and you will be the first to know
whenever we do uh
conference content whenever we do
special partner content and whenever we
go live
with any events like the one that you're
watching right now you don't want to
miss out on any of that kind of stuff
let's have a look at the leaderboard
uh jakub b who who is does anyone know
this this jacob guy is um
jacob you are not allowed to win your
own ticket my friend there are terms and
conditions uh let's have a look at the
next one
so the next question how many people
applied to speak so not how many talks
how many different
people applied to speak at ndc
oslo in 2020 this was our flagship
conference it was online
in june last year how many people
submitted talks
to speak at that was it 222 333
444 or 555
it was 555 people
submitted 1 140
different talks and uh we had to pick
the kind of
80 or so best ones to accompany the
pre-booked speakers and things
if you've never been program committee
for nbc uh it is a very very
enlightening experience but yeah we had
555 people
submit content for that have a look at
the leaderboard
uh in the lead is robin and then uh
nicholas then douglas then kim
then milosh and uh finally
nbc manchester 2022 will be held at mosi
the museum of science and industry
what famous historical computer is on
display at mossy
is it colossus baby aniak or the phoonly
f1
uniblab from the days when computers had
a name
because there was only one of them in
the world
uh it is
baby is the correct answer um
the manchester small scale it was called
baby because it was only the size of a
room and the previous computer was an
american computer that was the size of a
warehouse
and so at the time it was very very
small you know only the size of a
shipping container or something
um and yes if you got a mousy it is in
the main hall there and mostly have done
what dirty dancing told you never to do
they put baby in the corner so when you
go there next year you'll be able
to see that mostly puts baby in the
corner and they're not ashamed to admit
it
colossus of course was built at
bletchley park to crack the enigma code
um eniac was the first numerical
integrating computer
built uh in i think at the post office
here in the uk and the phonely f1 was a
turbocharged overclocked pdp-10
that was used to render all the graphics
for the movie tron in 1982.
they literally they took a a pdp-10 and
they took out all the transistors and
replaced them with faster transistors
created this one-of-a-kind computer only
one in the world absolutely
sorry did you claim any x for the for
the english did i make a horrible
mistake there yeah no colossus
colossus was built by tommy flowers
no one told me i was wrong yet i needed
to get something in there
[Laughter]
and so at the end of that
robin is the winner robin you get a free
ticket to ndc manchester 2020
uh douglas lee mark and whoever's sixth
because um jacob can get a hoodie anyway
he's the one ordering them
um so we are gonna we've got all the
stats for these uh backstage we'll go
through those we will be in touch we'll
get in touch with you by email we'll
get those prizes and things sent out
thank you everybody for taking part
uh we are now going to
do the prize draws now uh those of you
who are some of the nbc events
we did this live we literally ran a
random number
queries against sql in real time
uh let me just flip that across there so
that's fine
um we are not doing that because i am
not going to run sql on
actual customer data on a live youtube
stream because if i press the wrong
button i'll show the wrong thing
and uh we all have to go to jail for
gdpr violations and we don't want that
but i am gonna run the prize draw live
now
and i am gonna give the names out if
you're on the stream watching
drop a message in the chat so we can
congratulate you on your winnings
uh if you are not on the stream live
don't worry we will be in touch we have
your details we'll get those prizes out
to you so first up
our partners at synopsys are giving away
a pair of airpods pro
like attorneys general and quartz
martial airport is the noun it's the
plural pro is a modifier they are air
pods
pro and the winner drum roll please of
the synopsis airpods pro
is uh gary fuller from prater reigns
limited
congratulations gary we will be in touch
we will get that sent out to you we are
giving away an
ndc workshops ticket to the folks who
registered over on the workshops booth
there
the winner of that prize is gonna be
drumroll please
it is andy clark from mr andy clark
congratulations andy you got an ndc
workshops ticket
now uh our friends over at black marble
they are giving away
five lego easter bunnies and five lego
brick heads lego
sheep so we are gonna draw those right
now the uh sheep
lego easter sheep easter sheep is that a
thing
i i don't remember easter sheep growing
up but yeah
they are given away so the five lego
easter sheep brickheadz prize winners
are going to be
rhiannon wrath mark oliver grant james
chris rogers and shae wong
congratulations all of you black marble
will we'll give your details to them
they will get in touch they will get
your lego sent out to you
the final prize draw of the day are you
running sql statements ordered by random
to do this prize draw
no i'm running sql statements ordered by
new id because random is evaluated
before the order of rows so it doesn't
actually give you randomness
this is educational and finally
the five winners of the uh
the the lego easter bunny sets from our
friends over at black marble
are anthony scott from buy box
kevin riley from riley waterhouse uh
muhammad javarundi from bid identity
james wadby from practice and uh kevin
reilly from
uh kevin reilly has entered twice unless
there's a riley waterhouse limited and
an rw limited
uh oh we're gonna draw that one again
kevin you can't win
two lego easter bunnies they'll breed
and you'll be overrun with them
uh adam hicks from iris software
congratulations
adam those are our lucky winners
congratulations all of you thank you
very much for taking part in that
now then i am going to hand over the
stage
to uh my my dear friends and
collaborators
in technology and comedy and educational
entertainment and all these kinds of
things
i am gonna push the.net rocks button
hmm
how's that do we have audio did that
work
hello hello one second
let's just figure out what's going on i
know what the problem is
it's all right uh there we go
everything's fine we're fine
everything's fine we're all fine here
how are you all right he got it
there we go hey hey how about that we
have audio
um the number of moving parts that don't
move
in this setup here is intelligent so
uh we're gonna do about an hour.net
rocks the slido is running
uh jump over there put your questions in
the stream they'll be taking those live
and then a stick around at the end of
this we're gonna drop a zoom link in the
youtube chat because hey what could
possibly go wrong
and join us for some post ndc manchester
drinks and chat be lovely to see you all
there
but right now please give a massive
welcome to
the nbc manchester stage dot net rocks
live richard campbell carl franklin and
special guest
ian cooper the stage is yours my friends
so richard should we tell the people
what to expect
because you know watching a.net rock
show
recorded live is a little bit different
from listening to the podcast
yeah i think the phrase watching the
sausage make
being made is correct yeah there's a lot
of sausage involved there's a lot of
sausage we will
stutter screw up and we'll say let me
say that again or edit point
and our wonderful editor brandon wen is
going to catch that when he's listening
to
every second of audio and he'll just
take out all the dumb
yeah so don't worry about it sounds
smart that's how that works
that's exactly right and one thing we're
going to do before we even start
is uh start our local recordings so
on one two three go we'll push the
record button guys is that good
yep ian you ready you know just me
ready one
two three go
and my wheels on the bus are turning
round and round i got a blinky red light
it looks really nice
okay the next thing we always do is
literally hold our breath for five
seconds so the ambient
noise can be removed later because we
don't have the luxury of
you know zoom and skype already screwing
with our sound
so go ahead hold your breath five
seconds go
welcome back to dot net rocks this is
carl franklin
and this is richard campbell we're live
at ndc manchester
online ian cooper is here but uh buddy
how are you
none of us are in manchester yeah yeah
okay well that's okay
dylan's in chester so somebody's in
manchester
i think dylan are you in manchester i'm
in london
oh he's in london so who isn't jakob's
gotta be in manchester
we had we had the manchester contingent
on the line this morning we did a panel
with jim cameron and martin thwaites
who's helping us put the whole thing
together uh but yeah the vast majority
of the people making manchester happen
are not in manchester
yeah that's okay we can pretend we did a
road trip stop in manchester and play
and actually did the show
in a uh in a club nightclub the club
yeah
yeah it was the string one of the more
stranger sets we've ever done but it was
a lot of fun
because manchester is known for two
things live music
and football hooliganism yes we saw both
of them remember the day we were leaving
it was like a two o'clock game
we got to the train station at 10 in the
morning and there was beer
everywhere everywhere the people have
been drinking since 8 in the morning
because
clearly the pubs open early when it's
going to be an early game and
it was it was a state of affairs and you
know you don't wear the wrong colors
in manchester you know you it's like
gang warfare you'll get
you'll get a wedgie an atomic wedgie
[Laughter]
they'll find pieces of being a dumpster
i don't know it's manchester bed things
get serious sometimes
and football is very serious right
but anyhow let's uh we let's start how
we always do
with a little thing we call better know
a framework
all right so what have we learned here
[Laughter]
we don't actually play the stupid music
when we refer to the stupid music
it's a lie yeah we talk about music we
don't actually hear it all it gets
inserted later
we've heard it as many times as we care
to we kind of know it yeah
yeah we kind of know it i could have
played it i've got i've got this handy
but that's not the same thing at all you
could actually put the
i could have put the music in it but
i've been thinking about it but i didn't
mess with brandon
all right well this is this is an edit
point don't worry the sound effects are
in a different channel i wouldn't even
send it to you
okay ready yeah all right buddy
what do you got well uh this is pretty
cool
uh go to a b p i o
with your browsers now this is an open
source web application framework for
asp.net core
and why do you think you might need
a framework for a framework yeah that's
a good question why would that's a good
claim
it is a good question so just to read
from the website abp framework is a
complete infrastructure
to create modern web applications by
following the software development best
practices and conventions
so it sounds fairly benign and
boilerplate
but it's only missing the word paradigm
and it would be bingo right
actually the word boilerplate is really
what it's all about so it
replaces the popular boilerplate
template project
with their own which has some things
in it that help you so it's
microservices ready
it's multi-tenancy ready and it even has
a blazer
startup template um uh helps you follow
ddd
uh in in the dry principle like it's
some really good stuff
and it's of course open source and free
to use so it's a it's a good
uh thing to check out i think cool
sounds like we should do a show on it
we should yeah and it's an open source
project right let's do
exactly so yeah take a look at
everything right
awesome that's what i got richard thanks
who's uh talking to us
i grabbed a comment on the show 1458
that's right going back to the before
times
july of 2017's we published a show but
we actually recorded it in
june at nbc oslo with one
ian cooper maybe you heard him never
heard of him and i entitled the show
the.net renaissance because that's what
ian wrote in his blog posts it was one
of those things i thought i think we'd
interviewed him maybe
four months before normally i don't i
have people maybe once a year or so it
was one of those things like i read the
blog i was on call and that ping dean is
like
we need to do a show on this because he
was talking about something i'd
certainly been aware of which was
that you know microsoft kind of turned a
corner.net had was was
ascendant again this very mature
framework had rebooted itself and there
was
this amazing community emerging around
it a really fun show and i
recommend it to you listen even though
it is you know pushing four years old
now
uh and this particular comment is
actually referring to me
this is from chris zink and admittedly
written four years ago
and chris says uh richard made this
comment during the show and i have to
correct it he mentioned that software
engineering is not a profession yet
in canada at least software engineering
has been a profession for almost 20
years
it is a regulated professional
engineering discipline all the
professional engineering licensing
requirements apply to anyone wishing to
call themselves a software engineer
again in canada you must be a licensed
professional engineer use the title
engineer you cannot legally call
yourself a software engineer unless
you're also ap
eng as well there have been accredited
uh bachelor of engineering software
engineering programs given by canadian
universities for a couple of decades
the point to all this is the profession
does exist for software engineering
there are mandatory
cpd requirements ethics professional
practice guidelines and so on
that define a mature profession most
provinces have licensing
paths that allow a current protection to
protect
let me say it again see edit points
magic
most provinces have licensing paths that
allow a current practitioner to get
licensed with some effort
the regulating bodies are responsible
for regulating the profession they're
working hard to get practitioners
licensed
the engineering regulators are doing
this because the there are major public
safety issues around many aspects of
software
okay let me say that again
the engineering regulators are doing
this because there are major public
safety issues around many aspects of
software
as an industry we need to understand
this and support the profession
and if you're looking for more
information you can go to
engineerscanada.ca
and they do have a whitepaper
specifically on what constitutes
software engineering
and i have been doing some reading uh
and we're in this interesting state
where here's this
body that is identifying engineers and
asking qualifications and so forth
but largely they are still kind of
pitching this to the provinces
so you know similar to the way the
united states work whether the states
sort of make certain rules
the actual regulation of software
engineering and all kinds of engineering
you said a provincial level so the rules
are different from province to province
and uh they there's not really any
enforcement around any of this right now
so they have the the ideas but they're
they're still very much pressing against
can we put more legal constraints around
this what does this look like i mean the
united states is
you know anybody can use any term for
and and just consider it a marketing
term
you know like pain reliever for example
could just be a marketing term it may
not relieve any pain at all oh no it's
just what we call
it yeah well there are there are rules
again
question of enforcement yeah right the
federal trade commission does have very
specific things about
generally they inform stuff like can you
call it
bourbon if it's in tennessee well yeah
that's a federal thing
and yes yes you can but only if it
doesn't do any
carbon filtration look at that daniel's
separate issue
so i mean chris great point uh
and i have to change my pitch on this
whole issue because obviously
there are groups getting together to get
more serious about what engineering
looks like and i
and you know the same rules apply in
engineering typically there's only one
png per project
like if you're talking about
constructing a bridge there's lots of
people involved in that
but not all of them need to be civil
engineers and much less have their ph
their their stamp so to speak so
we could see a time when certain classes
of software are built that way and one
would argue that some software is
already starting to be built that way
because
you know more than ever it's becoming
abundantly clear that
software's running the world and we
really ought to have some authorities
around
managing all of that yeah so chris thank
you for your comment
a copy of music by it's on its way to
you if you'd like a coffee beast to go
by write a comment on the website
at dotnetrocks.com or on the facebooks
we publish every show there as well
and if you comment there and i read it
on the show we'll send you a copy music
code
and you should definitely follow us on
twitter to keep up with dot net rocks
uh i'm at carl franklin he's at rich
campbell
hey send us a tweet you know you can use
the boilerplate
tweet template we don't mind
[Laughter]
all right it's my great pleasure to
welcome back to dot net rocks ian cooper
he is a polyglot coding architect in
london
a founder of i d nug
speaker tabletop gamer geek
he is also tattooed pierced and bearded
the gov
on at brighter command welcome back ian
hey that's that's el deana actually the
london.net user group which um
who we occasionally get some uh clashes
with in terms of uh
our events uh on twitter and that's
london ontario
right yeah little london not because no
nobody in canada called it new london
because who would do that nobody
who would do that i know we're the
littlest london
i guarantee it we're the littlest new
london
um anyway yeah i'm sorry my font didn't
really differentiate between a capital i
and a lowercase l so i was just reading
oh good but it's good to have you back
sir um we always too long
always learn something from you no
matter what we talk about
so what's on your mind lately sir
so yeah i was talking today about um
gesture development and i i give a
famous talk about that in
2014 at ndc oslo which
um i think was probably one of uh ndc's
highest rated videos until dillon stole
my crown with his art of code
um i thought it had something to do with
that yeah
but um uh yeah so i guess what it's
about is this
um there's kind of a fork that seemed to
happen
uh in in the way in the history of kind
of practice of
test driven development and this is the
way i think about it originally at some
point
the people like ken beck martin fowler
they're all working at the
chrysler corporation in um
in the u.s and then they come up with
some great uh practices
xp tdd et cetera and it's clear
i think people don't necessarily
understand when they when they produce
the practices and they publish them
they've been doing them for some time
uh and you know someone said we should
share this with the world
um and ken's book about tdd is that us
if you read it it's not really a great
beginners book
because it's actually him explaining a
practice that he's been doing for quite
some time and actually has quite a lot
of detail it's more like a master class
but one of the problems with with the
book is what happened is
that people who who kind of
read it and didn't really necessarily
get exactly what he was focusing on
um brought in a lot of uh techniques
from a much more classical approach to
testing so unit testing
integration system testing so unit
testing of course is either i take a
module
i test what is inside that module um in
a kind of black box sense usually
and in order to do that what i do is i
say well any other modules it talks to
i'm going to substitute those with some
kind of dummy
um then i'll integration test i'll take
two modules and i get them to basically
talk to each other
and then i'll finally do a system test
and the idea is to localize where the
defects happening i confess i'm doing
black box testing
i've got a unit under test and some
damage i know if there's a failure it's
the unit causing the failure
i'm doing integration it's the
integration of these two tested units
must be wrong right
but that has really nothing to do with
test driven development but
unfortunately what happens
is really that um people in common
parlance when they talked about tdd
they spoke about writing unit tests and
really that wasn't what anyone was doing
but what happened is that brought all
this baggage with it people said hey we
should isolate this thing
we should use substitutes around it um
so they created this model where we took
a class for example and we said hey well
that's
that's obviously our unit let's
substitute everything around it then
and let's basically inject all of its
dependencies um
because we can't use those that'd be
violating unit testing right
we can do an integration test later and
that'll test us talking to real things
might be a system test let this go to
mocks
we were in what was led to the growth of
a constructor that
had quite often a huge number of
interfaces
that was taking in a tight language or
even you know um
type types basically in in a dynamically
typed language
and these constructors already grew and
what happened particularly in
uh uh faculty type languages was we said
well we've got all these interfaces that
i depend on
and this object may satisfy that but
it's got all these interfaces it depends
on
we come up with these graphs of objects
so when we had to have
ioc containers um kind of built
uh so that we could essentially realize
these object graphs at one time
and this whole direction i believe was a
complete mistake you talk about you know
null
being basically the kind of million
dollar mistake this is a whole
path that you know if we could take time
back and say
hey maybe if we got to history when we
change the fork
when we went towards unit testing and
actually went to what
native practitioners began to call
developer or programmer testing so you
can go and look at what's called the ct
wiki
tutorial is a repository of old-school
agile knowledge the beginnings of xp and
tdd
and it defines what developer your
programmer test is and it says
essentially
it's a test where effectively i'm going
to test some behavior of my software
and i'm going to do that um by
essentially to make
doing the smallest possible change that
i can make
in order to implement some of the
acceptance criteria
and that its localization is simply um
in the event of my test break
that last edit i did which would be
quite small
that's what caused that failure and i
should either revert it
actually appears to always revert it or
maybe debug it for a bit and see if i
get
i can get unstuck and then effectively
move back
and that path doesn't really use mocks
it doesn't really need ioc containers
and it's a very different approach and
it's it's where people struggle
with a red green refactor right how does
that work right
if you've done all your thinking about
design up front such that you can inject
all these interfaces that describe the
collaborative objects you must have in
your head conceived of some kind of
class hierarchy etc
right you probably over designed
if what you do is actually say hey this
is behavior i need to get under test how
am i going to implement that
right so the example kent uses
throughout the book is
sort of a money class and he's got the
thing says well you know
i want to basically take two money types
of different currencies to add them
together
and get results in the first currency
that's a typical kind of requirement
he's building with tdd not just
basically a method on a class
and so what can we say is well here's
this behavior so that's why down in
author came along and said hey this is
maybe we should call this behavior
instead right um but that behavior
you would say well what's the simplest
thing i could do the smallest amount of
code i could write to move one step
forward towards that
right and you essentially say well write
a red test to prove that fails
a green test which is the the naughtiest
implementation i can think of you're
explicitly asked to do something
horrible like go to
stack overflow and say let's cut and
paste that in right
great now now i'm getting closer to that
yeah all the stuff that we
say oh you know those developers that do
that i guess you should do all that
do all that and make it get to pass as
soon as possible
then you kind of step back and you go
well that code looks awful
i can't show that to any of my friends
um hey but i could do some refactoring
now
what i could do is actually make that
now i know effectively what the
algorithm is that i want to do i could
refactor that right
and that's when design emerges um and
actually at that point because that's
under test
i could break out classes and do that
without new tests
right and the idea really is that
they're they're private they're inside
the module and they're export depending
on language so
in something like c-sharp they'd be
internal and not public
and you'd be saying well no one should
be calling those that's how i implement
it
i could because it's refactoring in a
couple of test time
decide well that was a really bad idea
i'm going to throw that away and redo it
right
so it gives you that kind of ability to
keep changing your implementation which
is the promise you've been factoring
and it reminds me of a joke ian
that a a tester walks into a bar orders
a beer orders zero beers orders
nine billion nine hundred ninety nine
million nine hundred ninety nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine beers
orders a lizard orders minus one beer
and orders
able to the first real customer walks in
and asks where the bathroom is and the
bar bursts into flames killing everyone
yeah exactly but it's not really about
testing right it's more about designing
an api and that's really what tdd is
behind and step by step
controlling scope so that you don't
write speculative code
and actually if you do it this way you
do get that promise
of self-describing examples
and i've been kind of on this war path a
bit because i feel
that we've got this direction
which isn't giving people the results
that they want that is very expensive to
do
um that ends up with these test suites
that are very fragile and led to people
going
these not working um and i'm like that's
because you're not really doing tv
no all your tests can pass and it could
still blow up in production
yeah yeah the unit tests and integration
tests and that
are so valuable but it's not a valuable
technique it's just a different
technique
right and i have to take people you know
when you're thinking about that
things like the test pyramid right
there's a certain sweet spot for doing
test driven development really
quite often around what is the problem
space the domain you're actually
addressing there are other spaces like
my user interface um where test driven
development
is not the technique you're looking for
but testing maybe unit testing and
testosterone maybe are
right end-to-end testing yeah and what
we need to do is clarify exactly what
tdd is and what problems it's good at
solving
and so that's part of our mix of kind of
qa tools that we want to use
and we should understand our tools
better it's the age of problem right
effectively you know
if i've only got a hammer i'm going to
be banging those screws in
right and really testing is a suite of
tools tdd make is a hammer and it's
great for nails but sometimes i've got
screws and i need my screwdriver
and we need to get a little bit stand
back and say what are the tools i've got
and which one's going to get me to get
me the best result
and there are two real results you're
looking at one is i want to get feedback
now
on decisions i'm making as i write code
and that's basically tdd
or hey i want to protect my software
against regression
against blowing up and production
production and that's more the classical
kind of unit test integration test kind
of model
that you've got going on um we need to
get a bit more sophisticated about that
conversation
uh yeah absolutely the the the challenge
here then
is to sort of an order of execution like
we've always been
pitched on this idea that we we focus on
the
testing would make us think more clearly
about what those apis should look like
that
that's right would do it is that just
putting yourself in the customer's shoes
yeah i think so i mean generally what
you should be working with is some kind
of user story where there's customer
defined acceptance criteria you don't
need tools like cucumber to do that you
can just be doing that in your ex unit
style tdd
and really what you need to say is hey
well i i'm going to test for something
what is what is it i'm actually trying
to achieve here right so ken's example
he's trying to achieve
building a class that will support money
um and he's trying to look at what are
the acceptance criteria i need to be
added if it's in two different
currencies right that's a criteria let's
have a test that shows me how i do that
right and that's what you're already
driving does but you're also exploring
how to make that sdk
usable and effective and and simple so i
do i teach a bit of a welsh parallel and
one example i do is a game of life
and one of the things i've i mean i make
them i
i shot a video of me doing it both
styles right doing unit testing
and doing tdd and it's very clear the
difference
in the one that i do a kind of more unit
testing approach
i end up with a quite over complicated
kind of design whereas the one i do tdd
i end up going you know what i just need
to pass in
this kind of array that represents
basically game of life my
tests are so much clearer you can read
the tests and see exactly
how the transformation is occurring
between the two game boards that i've
got
uh and that is part of what what you're
doing and saying hey
if i was a developer how would i want
this to work
how to make this clear what what what
the pit of success is for using this
this particular um api that i'm writing
right
um and too often it's more hey here are
all the weeds and the details
and by the way going up at this
documentation because you're never going
to figure out how to use all the weeds
in the details
without all this documentation so it's
really i mean isn't that just the kind
of a punt it's like look i'll put all
the things in here
you figure out what you want i think so
sometimes yeah i think i think we
as developers are inclined to say um hey
i could maybe
this will happen or maybe that'll happen
and i think it's a really i think it's
an attempt to be kind
it's like well that could come up i
better i better make sure that's that's
kind of solved
right and you're thinking of all these
possible things and you think well i get
paid back at some point in the future
because
this will come up and someone will go
hey that's really great you sold that
already
but the reality is quite often what
happens is that comes up and you're kind
of like yeah we had a stab at that
it wasn't quite right yeah um
but it needs to just get straight back
to the whole yagni like you ain't gonna
need it
figure out the basic case get the basic
case out there
and then use feedback to decide what the
set next case the next version is going
to look like
yeah it pretty much is and but even at
the level of writing my own code right
that's what you want fast feedback the
idea the test should be fast because
the reason for this requirement about
speed is i really shouldn't be
interrupting my development flow very
much
right i should be writing that looks
like it do a small change okay that
seems to be making progress
do a small change and it really helps
people
quite often to work in that kind of
really tiny question
i've only got have so much in my head
right
yeah i managed to justify spending a lot
of money on testing infrastructure to
keep test times
under 15 minutes my theory being
that was as much time as it took for the
for the dev to stand up declare himself
a god
and then walking walk over to get some
coffee and by the time he got back with
his coffee
all of the errors were there right all
the problems because
what we were finding was they still
stood up to call themselves a god when
he got coffee but
you know the tests were gonna we're
gonna run to the end of the day like we
were you know doing those kinds of
models
so they worked on something else and by
the time they got the error reports back
the code was out of their head anyway
yeah particularly and i used to find if
you're running ci suites back in the day
and you had this whole kind of
model where it was too slow and you ran
them overnight then then
it created what i would always call
plausible deniability therefore the next
morning
wasn't my change yeah it worked on my
desktop yeah i
used to say i wanted to play this game
like pin the towel the donkey somebody's
job was effectively in the morning to go
around figuring out exactly who's
changing caused the problem
and then kind of like you say okay you
fix it um
which is kind of an enormous waste of
effort really but if you could give the
people the feedback now
they'd be like okay i can't escape this
right well and now there's no excuse we
have the cloud right like you can
distribute a huge this huge test suite
across a bunch of servers
for a few minutes and then tear it all
back down again
so it actually doesn't cost that much
but that
you checked in this code and minutes
later these are the errors we got back
like just it's short circuits that whole
debate
yeah and i think eventually you're still
in the same context right that's the
other big thing i mean
talk about developers and you know not
interrupting them because it kind of i i
guess the way i perceive it is
i've built up a model in my head and it
doesn't take a lot for that model to
have to be ejected from my memory to
deal with something else right
um and then i have to rebuild that whole
model and there's a certain point of i
don't want you to
have to eject that model between testing
runs
so you know i don't want to really think
ah maybe i'm going to go away and do
this
other thing that i've got on my to-do
list and i'll start writing that
email i'm thinking of a story from a
project that i'm working on
we had this issue where you know this
null reference exception was happening
and it wasn't the code that was
expecting that
to not be null it was the code that was
sending the null that was the problem
and so the developer uh just said you
just did a test for null and if there
was
if it was null just we'll just
exit right just return
and and then you know we couldn't find
the real problem which was that
this thing over here that was calling it
was passing no so it's
it's good to to not do null checks
sometimes especially when you're
developing you know
or at least do something constructive
when it is null
but it'll those things will help you
find the real problems
but it was just an interesting thing
that came up yeah fail faster sometimes
like i think you know underrated we can
we can swallow and catch stuff because
we don't know what to do with it right
and actually a better thing to do is to
crash at that point because yeah
at least don't fail silently like on on
air
resume next like that that's just evil
right yeah yeah yeah
i'll just people remember what that
means richard yeah
i don't even remember what that is yeah
roll the
dice around man
yeah dragging out old languages right i
do think we're in a time now where we're
starting to
think that being opinionated right that
this is how i work this is what i do
and and no secrets like
failing loudly making it very clear this
is what made me unhappy it makes for
better software software's too
complicated as it is
everything that can be expressive and
and out
and forthright so forth that's you spent
a lot less time
chasing these ghosts around yeah i mean
i was thinking about this the it's a
slight tangent but
in relation to you know running software
in containerized environments like
kubernetes where
you know in some cases um when you get a
sort of transition error or something
you're talking to like i
work on an open source library um
brighter which deals in messaging
and there's this whole question i can't
ask myself is you know how sophisticated
should we should we be
at uh coping with the loss say of a
broker and sitting there continually
retrying etc
because the trouble with that is it can
be very hard to observe that from
outside
whereas if i just crash then you know
someone right in the scheduler can say
okay great well i'll pause and restart a
new
a new uh a new instance right to replace
that one
and that's this problem where you know
by being quiet and silent about the
failure
i'm thinking that oh i'm helping the
operator but in fact actually i'm not
because he can't now observe the error
and take it take a simple action
right right you can't reproduce it yeah
yeah you thought you were being clever
you know yeah but he looks like his
monitor right you know i'm still running
right but maybe i'm not doing anything
useful
but it's in a state that's corrupted you
know so
you really do have to hey uh guys hold
that thought while we pause
for this very important message
all right and we're back it's dotnet
rocks i'm carl that's richard
hey hey and uh that's ian cooper we're
talking about tdd
and the the problems that that uh have
uh plagued us about this and
ian it's interesting to hear somebody
say you know i think we got it all wrong
and there are better ways to to test
your application
and i'm concerned that you know the
alert listener missed that part where
you said
now unit tests are still important
integration tests are still important
so i guess what i'm saying is what is
the prescriptive
kind of fix for this you know tdd
uh behavior that uh that people
have been doing now for years yeah sure
so i think the thing is this right
um decide that you are in a position
where
a test first approach is going to help
you
and really the context for that is i am
i have a requirement that's reasonable
to find
i've got some say user stories or use
cases with acceptance criteria
and it's kind of a domain problem
usually it's a problem basically i'm
going to deal with it in terms of
entities et cetera rather than
technology
and i want to essentially explore how
i write code that solves that kind of
main problem
right and then i focus my efforts on
saying okay
um let's take the simplest kind of thing
i could do to move towards that criteria
quite often it's essentially something
that says you know
um i'll return zero in this in this
condition right
that's right a couple lines of code get
started and then you say well what's the
what's the simplest move i could make
towards the you might be initializing
uh a kind of base level uh thing so
taking the example of money
right that ken was using you'd be like
saying i need to create a money class
that basically has
kind of zero value great i can test it
at zero
also that seems like a good start right
and then maybe now i think well
maybe i need to set a value to it and
test it still got that value okay maybe
i should add two of them right
and you and you build up kind of that
functionality of acceptance fraudulent
towards
um getting something each time you're
trying to express a behavior right
separate and then when you do that
really try and follow a red green
factor and really trying to avoid using
any kind of mocks
right generally speaking you know you
can work in different architectural
styles like
um i tend to recommend ports and
adapters and now
rephrases clean architecture because it
cleanly separates
here's my domain around that is things
that basically do i o so i can focus on
that thing and i can add i o later right
and then i can i can use tdd to do that
it's in sweet spot
and then when i'm saying hey i'm going
to test my ui or i need to test actually
how it's just this database say you know
hey is that the best tool in the box
maybe actually unit testing this is is
fine or even just
you know testing it in by running it
right and having a look
and saying okay i've had a look at that
right and so if you do things where
you're testing by looking at just
running it then you're really a problem
you're solving now is regression
right you're saying hey i need to write
some tests to make sure that keeps
running right
so i can write some tests that just
check that's going to run still
i'm not exploring that i don't need to
explore that
so my common example of this is a lot of
code where i'm saying
oh well i've got this idea of an entity
that i need to save for the data store
all right
in general in a lot of cases what i'm
doing is probably got some data access
object wrapper
and i'm just going you know what i need
to get the docs up i just implement that
there's no exploration
there's no real kind of like how does
this actually work it works when
effectively i say
stuff to the database right i could i
could check i could label check that as
i work through it
once it works i go okay that's the
working code i need to ch
i write a little test now you can use x
unit tools to do that for you
but you know they're agnostic to what
that to approach you're using
and kind of you can do that there right
to check that
maybe it's doing a ui right you can use
i think one of you were mentioning to me
earlier
in snapshot tools and i did have a
colleague who wrote one of those we're
effectively just saying hey compare this
ui to the
to the image basically and see whether
we've moved bar buttons and you know
around into the wrong place and they've
shifted a few pixels to the left and
that isn't
okay a good tool for that is playwright
for
net wri ght
um yeah that's a good end-to-end tester
for for ui and i like that because you
can basically tell it you know
fill out this form right here push the
button wait until
some id shows up on the page and now we
can test that and you can actually write
a script that goes
through the whole thing and hopefully
gets the desired
result and all i need to do is just bear
in mind you know that's not really what
i'm not doing tdd but i'm doing i'm
doing qa and that's perfectly fine
both of these things are equally
valuable right and there's this notion
called the testing pyramid that kind of
says
hey i can draw a pyramid right in the
bottom is unit testing at the top
is essentially um you know manual
testing
and as i go from up i'm getting
it takes me longer to get a result um
and those results are less easily
repeatable
so obviously because you know i would
prefer to
get repeatable results um that are fast
i might want to put a lot of my effort
into getting a lot of the problems i can
solve with ttd solved with tdd
but there are other things that tdd is
just not the right thing to solve and
you use the correct techniques for those
right
and we all know we're joking about you
know someone walking to the bar right
eventually but
actually you know shipping code to a
small number of users will find you
things that
you just never expected yeah look
they're going but why would you do that
um you know well but there's also sets
of personalities that really like that
work i mean
i also think that's not a replacement
for qa
it's an addition to qa and it takes time
in cultivation
you know you know i i think back on like
windows created the slow ring fast ring
thing
and what really happened was most people
just put it on a secondary machine and
never looked at it
didn't actually take it out for enough
exercise so they weren't getting
the useful feedback until they actually
pushed patches
into production so to speak and broke
things
so it you've really got to evaluate
these different strategies like
i kind of think we're abusing our
customers via the cloud with this
where we're not really finishing
software we're just sticking it out
there
and letting them finish it for us by
forcing them to give us feedback
by crashing the app because uh they
expect you know version one there's
going to be some errors oh but you know
we can get it's an interesting one
because uh because i
when i when i started my career i
shipped disks i used to work on
medical software and ship disks and i
can remember
a fault that i i'd added to the software
um that shipped and we had to ship all
the disks again
and uh i was a young junior developer
and my boss to teach me a lesson sent me
down to the department helped me
make me pack all the disks that i had
had to be re-sent out
that i would learn by doing basically
that particular job
quite how much we're older and more
mature now we don't ship disk we slip
disks
yeah very true um but but
i mean i think the thing is the whole
the purpose of talking about things like
testing production of course is that we
can't predict everything anymore right
now
and it's more saying when you when you
do release something
uh there's sufficient complexity that
you're going to have to accept that the
first thing that you release is probably
broken
that's what to me that's what it means
for testing and production doesn't mean
hey actively don't do any qa
just ship the thing and let it explode
it's more
accepted by the time it gets to
production you're still testing
yeah you'd hope that some group of
customers are going to be able to
successfully use it
yeah and that you slip that new version
out bit by bit
right so you don't break everybody at
once to create total chaos but it's
almost like
do a release listen get that feedback oh
everything's going well right now
add a few more and wait until the
screams start and then stop
shipping it and start dealing with the
screams
and what's your what's your advice
richard never ship um
6 p.m friday night yeah geez don't
ship anything
don't change anything on a friday unless
you like working weekends tomorrow
right before vacation ship it yeah out
of here
thanks for playing you wonder why i went
to nepal
phones don't work there remember my out
of office message it literally gave you
lat long to send the helicopter if you
really need me
this is where you need to be climbing a
mountain
in nepal right now and i'm willing to be
interrupted if i get video of you
picking me up in a helicopter that's
acceptable but otherwise
no yeah the um
friends don't do that to friends sort of
thing is that room yeah yeah
but i i think there's a respect angle on
this that you
you're right we're never gonna test for
all scenarios but we should test for
some
and then really being careful with
who you break and how you break them you
know we we got into a situation in
strange loop where
there were some customers that wanted
the leading end features really really
bad that they were willing to take risks
and they went on this
beta program so they got those bits
first and there were other customers
just like
i i will accept a modest performance
improvement
do not break my site right and they you
know they were sort of in the
conservative ring
so part of this was just listening to
where the customer's at giving them that
choice
and and building our deployment
practices around those things so we
could really learn
well i think i think the thing i mean
you're talking about you know um
licensing of engineers and
and and the risks uh one of your
correspondences talking about the risks
that effectively that
we get from a world that's contin
running on software and i think that we
you know we we underestimate uh
that we could we can make people's lives
you know quite miserable
um because a stealth state depended on
it's not going to work for them the next
you know a few hours or you could flat
out kill them ask the folks who got on
the boeing 737 max
like there were some hardware decision
failures in there too but it was also
a lot of software like no kidding or
the fig you know i'm gonna just keep
picking on boeing it's the starliner
spacecraft that didn't make it to its
correct orbit because
literally a time and date problem like
straight software
mistakes and only after it was up in
orbit did they do the rest of the
testing you realize oh if it continues
on this path
it's going to be destroyed and they
managed to fix the software enough to
recover the spacecraft but still
that was jordi laforge that fixed it i
think that's what the visor is all about
right
augmented reality in the 90s i think the
pandemics also taught us that i mean i
mean there are other things that we
that we think perhaps are less vital
that it turns out can become but i
thought right so
you know i need to get groceries shipped
to my house because i can't you know
if someone can't leave because you know
they're too vulnerable clinically
really risk going to the supermarket
that's essentially now become a really
essential service for them right
yeah all of a sudden yeah i ended up
talking to organizations
that had not unified their
purchasing a return process from
in-store to online
so the stores had inventory but you
couldn't buy it online
and you couldn't go to the store because
the stores were closed because they you
know two different teams that built it
at a point i want to uh invite anyone
who's in the slido channel
to ask questions for ian this would be a
good time to take questions
i'm watching it so uh ask away
continue so you know it's all those
little mis things you've done along the
way just not
actually you know one team built the
software for the on for the online
product one team built software for the
in-store product
never got around to merging the two and
all of a sudden here we were in a
situation where it's like
people need this these products like
this is serious
and you you're broken because of a dumb
software thing
because they didn't do an integration
test well just
you know wasn't important yeah all the
products were selling who cares
yeah but even things like you know if
i've got an app on my phone to get a
to get a taxi right so i get a cat right
actually you know that can be a
situation where if that doesn't work for
you
you may be in a vulnerable place or
position right yeah
i mean i've been you know in situations
with the small small children we've been
you know
out some effectively you wanted to get
them home right and you suddenly
discover you can't get service or
something
and that's actually become that turns
from something that basically is an
annoyance into
quite a drama for you um and and i think
that we we underestimate
you know as the world build gets more
and more built on software and becomes
more and more dependent on the
the dream we've kind of sold them i've
had that exact same
issue uh not because of lack of service
but because there were no uber drivers
or lyft drivers
in the area uh because of the pandemic
yeah yeah yeah and we we've actually
been
stranded at places for hours because
there's you know we thought we could
count on
that service but that's a another story
yeah but i think you know but we i i
think the problem is of course
uh i think it was bruce schneier once
said i think we're talking about
basically you know the
the dying of newspapers and he said you
know you were promised the future you
weren't promised it would be better
and i think we we don't always think
through
um the house of cars that we're
potentially constructing right yeah
now we're only as strong as our weakest
link but also
i mean if i think there's a recurring
theme in this episode it's like you
listen you're not your customer
yeah your customer uses your product
differently your product is more
important to your customers importing
your customer in a way that's not like
you
you are not your customer and so if
you're not listening to them if you're
not
actually you're missing out on what your
products actually about just because you
built
it doesn't you know doesn't mean you own
it really ultimately once it's out in
the world
like any piece of creation once it's out
in the world the people interacting with
it are as
have as much to do with it as you did i
learned a really important lesson when i
was a very
genuine developer and i was fortunate in
that era really to you were kind of more
quite super nuts so i went out on site
when it was kind of deployed to the
first um
site and people's early early days of
kind of
office automation and people were just
really doing data entry
so it's quite a simple app for a junior
uh engineer to build something
just you know that field so get into the
data in click ok move on to the next one
a little bit of validation so that i
didn't get control
and i sat down with the the crew they
were basically on the doctor entry
and quite rapidly they gave me a
piece of feedback that i'd never thought
about which was
that essentially i i hadn't really
thought about tabbing right
and tab order and i was making their
life misery
because those people worked really fast
and were tabbing between fields the
whole time
uh and the tab order was basically for
them dictated by what was on the paper
form that they were entering
and that simple thing i was making their
their
their every moment painful you know you
know
i've got some validation on there you
can't enter dates that are basically you
know
they're crazy but it's kind of like it
doesn't really help us what really helps
us is the fact that the table matches
the field order on basically
the paper document right yeah it's an
interesting different set of priorities
and and
of course the moment you see it you get
it but you got to go see it
yeah so are are we kind of stuck
in this development practice now like
tdd's been around a while ddd like this
whole
genre like are we looking for a new term
a new name
a new practice it's interesting right
because dan north you know
renamed it behavior-driven development
but then that went away and became
something i think quite different if
it's become really a full
kind of agile approach to delivering
software now bdd
um i don't know whether i think we are a
moment
where um tdd is
has kind of got people who who are in
favor
and also some people who dislike it
enough that
you can kind of present back and say i
think many of the problems that you are
uh afflicted with are due to the fact
that you're using the wrong
technique here you're not actually doing
tdd you're doing your testing
the reason you're finding it difficult
to get this nail into the wall
and you keep complaining basically that
nails are rubbish because you're using
the screwdriver
yeah hey let me hand you a hammer right
and so i think we are at an opportune
moment when we can begin to really
reverse
uh some of the muddier thinking here and
it's once you do it it's
it's one of the keys to this kind of
more actually
people talk about other sorts of
problems like you know overuse of
patterns
when it's unnecessary etc that kind of
thing once you get into this model of
tdd it becomes clearer because you can
say well i've got this green
passing test it tells me what i need to
do just to solve the problem but it's
rubbish
but now i understand the context i can
figure out do these patterns really
apply here do i need
those to help clean this code up and
there's other
conversations that i see emerging on
twitter that's all time saying is this
pattern valuable or is this pattern
actually been
negative because people have gone away
and implemented it without thought
something like this technique can say
hey well i can tell you the answer in
the green
phase it's whether you're going to need
it now that's a target for your
refactoring or not depending on what on
because you know the you know the
context better now right
we have a comment from uh neil who says
one of the biggest problems for grocking
tdd is the lack of meaty examples
the contrived money example is great but
it's hard to apply in one's real
projects
and that's very true i think that you
know
there is this difficulty that says these
contrived examples don't help you
because they don't
they fall apart when you hit kind of
real problems like well what do i do
with the i
right um every hello world example
yeah i definitely agree with that i
think the answer probably is
more i mean internally i recommend you
do kind of caters
right and explore doing tdd a lot in
this technique until it becomes kind of
more you say okay i'm going to really
push myself for this two hours to do it
this way
um and then you learn new kind of master
memory that helps you then apply to
wider stuff
i think there's another answer really
which uh um
is you know people doing streaming and
stuff more so um
and twitch streaming and stuff to
actually do more demonstration of trying
to solve problems around
larger projects right what's this
problem of if i have a complex enough
domain to be real i have to bring the
domain to you as part of what i'm doing
but i think maybe that may be what some
of the answers how we actually solve
some of this this training problem
was showing more solid examples of
working in the style with bigger domain
spaces
yeah yeah i mean
part of me wonders if it's just that
when you actually get into the meat of
really understanding software
being built this way it's not so complex
you can't explain it meaningfully like
that's hard too and you also pretty
quickly dive into some proprietary
aspects like
one of the things i found in really well
architected
apps is that the secret sauce is
abundantly clear
like the value proposition of software
and that's often things that leadership
is
uh pretty perspective also one of the
things you said was
don't use mocks and so i guess that
means you can't
really test anything that has service
dependencies
yeah unit testing so that's not the
right test for something that
uses a service so the generator of three
i mean ken
outlines three cases where you might
want to use marks right so one is a
shared fix like a database of our file
system where one test can affect the
other
right and has to do with basically two
tests interfering otherwise it's slow to
talk to
so it's over a network um and the other
is it's fragile to talk to right
um and those are the three cases that's
that's where he says you use marks
replace those things
yeah um i think if you have a decent use
of a led architecture that helps because
you can say well those things are
actually outside this layer right i'm
just focusing on my domain and i don't
worry too much about those
um and i then tend to use other
techniques the kind of more
the test after a unit test for testing
those i feel they're better so
for example if your data comes from an
api endpoint
you could make an npi endpoint that
returns data that you can test against
and use that for your test yeah that's
that's an okay use of a mock because i'm
really substituting for something that's
fragile
uh slow or multiple tests are going to
impact right
but it's like the faster class
dependency thing that
that became the kind of mantra of the
people who treated this as a kind of
plus you could also like put some
in intentional delays in your api
um you know to to sort of simulate what
happens is
it's a way to look at this what the
problems i solve with mocks
are the are going to be replaced with
problems with integration later
yeah exactly what we don't want to
really solve are problems where
two classes are collaborating and i want
to mock one out
of those collaborators right which means
i'm not presuming their
piece is going to work this way and i
put it in the mock and i'm invariably
wrong
yeah and generally in a lot of cases
it's an implementation detail
your public surfacer of your module
doesn't need that
it's something you build as a result of
refactoring to clean up your green code
you've got this small class that does
this thing has a single responsibility
it helps you as a developer
to understand and manage that code but
the consumer the consumer of your code
that's just additional complexity they
don't really want to know about because
it doesn't help them answer the question
of how do i use your code
right right i get it awesome
yeah good stuff so what's new for you
ian what's next
what's in your inbox uh my inbox we're
trying to get v9 of brighter the open
source project i work on helps you do
messaging really between two services
out the door we got a bit delayed we had
a couple of people who had
um a potentially so uh
one of them uh you guys know turkey
henderson i can't remember you met him
uh ever i think the name sounds familiar
i don't think he got him on the
show but i think he's good at the events
took a good slug off
uh to look after his child um uh
so we got slugged down a bit by that but
um
uh well but that's i think a very
positive thing understandable strike
taking you know your
your very fair share of uh child care uh
responsibilities when childish young
so um but yeah so um v9 is going to have
some
um better support what we call outboxes
and inboxes
so really stuff that essentially helps
make sure that the message is delivered
or removes duplicates
we've got some rewrites to um uh kafka
and our sns and sqs from aws kind of
provide us making more robust
and we actually i mean transports it for
the transports are kind of an
interface that you implement and they're
fairly straightforward and we've
none of the core team were actually on
as years we never really had one for
as your service but which is a huge hole
um we knew people have written them
and they're out there and we're like can
we have one right and of course if
people were like oh it's a proprietary
secret my boss won't
we've got one back in now so we've got
one we know runs in production
uh at scale and that's going to come out
hopefully in the v9 as well so people
all the people
on azure don't have to roll your own
anymore right we've actually got someone
to contribute one back to the project
which is a big win for us i think
what we wanted we always wanted to try
and avoid is ones that are speculative
we don't know
somebody's actually tested this code and
run it in production that's one of our
kind of guarantees and so that's been
really good for us we've gone back in
so that's that's what i'm doing there
it's very good on that
yeah i mean i thought i've got a focus
still i think for me on that kind of
messaging side
microservices domains et cetera cool
well uh ian cooper it's been a pleasure
it always is a pleasure
always learn something you always have
some new perspective on stuff
and thanks again for being on dot net
rocks today
and we'll see you next time on dot net
rocks
and now we can stop recording and i
believe dylan's going to invite
everybody for a drink hello
yeah he put that message
[Laughter]
yes hello folks and thank you very much
thank you carl thank you richard thank
you ian
and uh this is it we are done that was
nbc manchester just remains to say a
final huge
thank you to everybody who has helped
make this happen to our amazing speakers
so we had a stacy cash more this morning
talking about you know using blazer and
static apps and
building your brand we had uh ian cooper
doing in a td
revisited uh we had uh janani sabir
we've had steve
sanderson we had irena scurtu on uh
martin and jama this morning talking
about the technology scene in manchester
and all the great stuff that's happening
up there
mark rendell talking about
migrations.net rocks heather
downing it's been a fantastic program
thank you to all of our partners
for uh sticking with us and helping make
this happen
uh thank you speakers thank you to all
of you because if it wasn't for you
we would just be having a really really
complicated
zoom call with each other so thank you
everybody out there
who has tuned in for all of this what we
are going to do now there is no official
uh after party mainly because all the
equipment that i used to run
live stream concerts is currently being
used to host ndc manchester
um we are going to run a bit of music on
the stream i am going to drop the link
we've been running all this and
we got a little zoom backstage area
where we've been doing all our talks all
day
we're going to invite all of you in
there come and join us on zoom say hello
um i'm certainly gonna open a beer
because i've been sitting here all day
and i'm extremely thirsty
grab yourself a time appropriate and
lifestyle appropriate beverage whatever
that might be for you
um come in meet some of the crew hang
out i'm going to drop that link in here
in a second
uh just remains for me to say thank you
very much to everybody who put this
together
we will see all of you soon online
offline in person
who knows these are uncertain times but
whatever happens we are gonna roll with
the punches
and keep on trucking and please welcome
to the ndc manchester virtual stage
uh some people who might look ever so
slightly familiar
some of you who've been at ndc events in
the past
playing us out with their variation on
the disney classic ducktales please
welcome
the line breakers thank you very much
we'll see you all soon
go
[Music]
life is like a
act like they all
[Music]
[Applause]
texas
[Music]
when it seems they're headed for that
final
contract shady word he never fails
the worst of messes they call success
[Music]
that's the reason they got it
hit those targets
[Music]
your api is the hall of shame
darling you give rest a bad name
[Music]
is
okay
[Music]
your api is
a bad name
[Music]
[Applause]
updates fail cause the database locks
breaking and changes every time your
every release takes our system offline
whoa it's no surprise
[Music]
your api is
a bad name
[Music]
your api is a hall of shame
you give rest a bad name
it falls apart and we take the blame
your api is
a bad name it falls apart
and we take the blame you give rest a
bad name
[Music]
your api is a hall of shame
you give rest a bad name
you